COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING. AS
WE BEGIN THE PROCESS OF WORKING
OUR WAY THROUGH THIS STATE
EDUCATION BUDGET TODAY AND IS
VERY UNUSUAL CIRCUMSTANCE.
BECAUSE OF COURSE WE HAVE TO DO
BECAUSE OF THE CONSTITUTIONAL
DEADLINE THAT WE'RE FACING. TO
PASS A BUDGET I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE KEEP THINGS IN
PERSPECTIVE DURING THIS RATHER
DIFFICULT PROCESS. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
TODAY IS MEMORIAL DAY. IT'S A
DAY TO REMEMBER ALL OF THOSE
MEN AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM MORE
THAN ONE POINT ONE MILLION OF
THEM. WHO IN THE WORDS OF
ABRAHAM LINCOLN GAVE THE LAST
FULL MEASURE OF DEVOTION. TO
MAKE SURE ACTUALLY THAT WE
COULD BE HERE TODAY TO DO THETHINGS. THAT WE ACTUALLY NEED
TO DO. AND AS WE START TODAY I
ALSO WANT YOU TO REMEMBER ALL
OF THOSE SOULS WHO HAVE LOST
THEIR LIVES. IN THIS NEW BATTLE
WITH COVERT NINETEEN. AT ALMOST
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND OF THEM
WE'VE NOW LOST MORE AMERICANS
TO COOK AT NINETEEN THEN WE
LOST MILITARY MEMBERS TO THE
DURING THE ENTIRE. VIETNAM WAR.
SO LET'S KEEP ALL OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR HEARTS AND
MINDS TODAY AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
WITH HIS HEARING. AND NOW THE
PROCESS. IN RESPONSE TO THE
CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS%
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING A
SENSUAL HEARING AND IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WHAT CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES. AS WE
COMPLY WITH THOSE ORDERS WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL. WITH
TESTIMONY BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
BEING PROVIDED REMOTELY WITH
THE USE OF A VIDEO CONFERENCING
SYSTEM. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES. OR
COMPUTERS PARTICIPANTS WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MUTING AND I'M
GETTING THEMSELVES WHEN THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ANSWERED
EVERY TIME YOU HAVE A COMMENT
OR QUESTION YOU USED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE STATE YOUR AME
AND THE AGENDA ISSUE TO WHICH
YOU ARE REFERRING. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELEPHONE
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THE MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY.
WHEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON YOU ARE
USING TO WATCH THE HEARING.
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN THIS
REGARD. I WILL BE THE ONE TO
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE.
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. MAYBE SOME LAG TIMES
FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE USE. OF NEW
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO THAT ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
FIFTEEN ISSUES FOR DISCUSSION
ON TODAY'S AGENDA IN ADDITION
TO THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR WE
HAVE TWO AGENDAS FOR TODAY'S
HEARING PART A INCLUDES K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION AND
EARLY EDUCATION ITEMS. AND PART
B. INCLUDES HIGHER EDUCATION
ITEMS I WOULD LOOK LIKE TO NOTE
THAT FOR TODAY'S HEARING WE
WILL BE HEARING ALL OF THE
ITEMS ON AGENDA AGENDAS AND BE.
PRIOR TO TAKING ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT AND VOTING. ONCE WE
HAVE HEARD ALL OF THE ITEMS ON
THE AGENDA IS WE WILL HAVE ONE
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO COMMENT ON ANY ITEM
ON THE AGENDA. SUBSEQUENT TO
THAT PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD WE
WILL VOTE ON THE AGENDA ITEMS.
WE WILL UNDERTAKE ONE VOTE TO
ADOPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
LISTED IN THE AGENDA. OR MORE
PROBABLY TAKE SEPARATE VOTES IF
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WISH
TO PULL ITEMS FOR A SEPARATE
VOTE. BEFORE WE GET INTO THE
AGENDA ITEMS THAT ARE HEARING
LET'S ESTABLISH A CORPSMAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH. YOUR SENATOR
LEYVA YOU'RE LIVING HERE
SENATOR MORALE MORALE HERE
SECRETARY NOTES A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
DEPARTMENT WHO ARE ALL
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY
LET'S MOVE TO AGENDA PART AA ON
K. THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION.
FOR THE FIRST DISCUSSION ITEM.
WHICH IS ITEM SIXTY ONE HUNDRED
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ITEM
SIXTY EIGHT SEVENTY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ISSUE NUMBER
ONE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
OVERALL. BUT DESPITE OF
ANALYST'S OFFICE WHO WILL
PROVIDE US WITH AN OVERVIEW OF
PROP NINETY EIGHT FOR THE FIRST
DISCUSSION ITEM. HELLO GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND
GROUP BROUGHT THE LIVES THAT
ARE LOST OFFICE I'M A MY I DID
WANT TO JUST PROVIDE YOU SOME
BROADER- MEMBERS TOOK TO
WALKING THROUGH THE DIFFERENCES
ON HIM IN A REVISION COMPARED
TO JANUARY ON TO SET UP THE
CONTEXT FOR SOME OF THE
SUBSEQUENT CONVERSATIONS THAT
WILL OCCUR BUT THIS THROUGHOUT
THIS HEARING. FIRST IN TERMS OF
THE- OVERALL CHANGES IN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
MINIMUM GUARANTEE OVER THE
THREE YEAR PERIOD- THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE IS DOWN SEVENTEEN
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
COMPARED TO THE JANUARY LEVELS.
MOST OF THE REDUCTION OF
THIRTEEN POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IS A REDUCTION IN THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEED AND IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THE MAJORITY OF THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE REDUCTION IN
THE GUARANTEE IS DUE TO THE R.
R. REDUCTIONS IN CITY GENERAL
FUND REVENUES AS A RESULT OF
THE STATE NOW I'M INTRIGUED. I
WOULD NOTE THOUGH THAT- THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEED A
CALCULATION DOES INCLUDE FOUR
AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS IN
REVENUES FROM NEW PROPOSALS OF
THE ADMINISTRATION OUR- NEW
REVENUE PROPOSALS THAT THE
RESTRICTION OF COUPLES OF ME
REVISION. I'M WITHOUT THOSE ARE
PROPOSALS I GUARANTEE WOULD BE
ABOUT ANOTHER ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS LOWER. I DID-
IT- BLUE OVERALL NINETY NUMBERS
AND THE STORY SOME OF REMOTE
CONTROL AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
I DID JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT FOR THE PURPOSES OF- K.
TWELVE FUNDING BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT THOSE ARE THE NEXT ISSUES
THAT WILL BE IN OUR DISCUSSION-
THE STORE IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT
ONCE YOU INCORPORATE. A VARIETY
OF OTHER FUNDING SOURCES THAT
ARE PART OF ME REVISION- SO-
AND PART OF THE MITIGATING
ACTIONS THAT ARE OCCURRING SO
WE THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT. A
VARIETY OF OTHER ACTIONS THAT
ARE GOING ON SCHOOL FUNDING IS
ROUGHLY FLAT IN THE MIRROR
VISION FROM THE- REVISED TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY LEVEL TO WHAT'S
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
THAT'S FOR A NUMBER OF FACTORS-
FIRST OF ALL. ANY OF THE
REDUCTION THAT ARE IN THE
MAYOR'S. ARGUABLY ASKED. FOR
I'M IN BED IT'S A TOTAL OF FIVE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
THE CURRENT AND BUDGET YEAR-
THAT- BUT- IN DEFERRALS FOR OUR
SCHOOLS. WHAT THAT MEANS WHEN
THE STATE IMPLEMENT THE
DEFERRAL INSTEAD OF OUR- OWN.
AMERICAN VALUES MUSIC SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN USE INTO THEIR
CASH RESERVES. OR THEY CAN GO
OUT TO THE MARKET AND BORROW
FUNDING AT RELATIVELY LOW
INTEREST RATES IN ORDER TO.
CONTINUE TO OPERATE PROGRAMS.
AT THEIR CURRENT LEVELS. I'M I
MADE SO THE SAY ANY TO ME
RETURN. FROM THE OTHERS THE
OTHER- NOTABLE ACTION HERE IS
FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
IN. FEDERAL FUNDING THAT IS.
SORT OF A DISCRETIONARY BUT THE
STATE HAS DECIDED THAT THE MERE
VISION IS PROPOSING TO PROVIDE
TO SCHOOLS- BUT IS NOT REQUIRED
TO BE ON. OVERALL THERE'S ABOUT
FIVE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS GOING UP TO SCHOOLS. IN
TO READY A FUN SOURCES THAT ARE
ARE. RELATIVELY FLEXIBLE FOR
THEM. FROM ONE POINT ONE POINT
FORTY FIVE BILLION IS FROM THE-
FEDERAL CHARACTER GONNA GO ALL
BASED ON THE TITLE ONE PARTY
FORMULA. THE STATE. DOESN'T
HAVE MUCH CONTROL OVER. I'M
GOOD AT ALL AND FUNDING IS
GOING UP BASED ON FORMULA BUT
THE MAIN REASON DOES INCLUDE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN.
REVENUE THAT'S COMING FROM A
CARRIAGE ACT THAT COULD BE USED
FOR A VARIETY OF PURPOSES AND
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
CHOSEN TO USE. OR SCHOOL
SPECIFICALLY. AND FOR THE
LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION GRANT
WHICH I KNOW IS A SEPARATE ITEM
ON YOUR DISCUSSION. THE OTHER
NOTABLE ARE. ISSUES THAT ARE
PUT OUT IN TERMS OF HAVING
PHYSICAL EFFECT ON SCHOOLS IS
SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE IS
BEING DISCUSSED IN IN SUB FOR.
AND THAT IS THE- CHANGES TO-
BUT- SOME. ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THOSE PROVIDED IN THE NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET. THAT WAS
INTENDED TO BE TO PROVIDE LONG
RUN- DOWN OF UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES UNFUNDED PENSION
LIABILITIES FOR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- THAT
PROPOSAL WHICH WAS GONNA
PROVIDE LONG RUN RELIEF- NOT AS
MUCH IMMEDIATE BUT- SIGNIFICANT
OVER THE LONG RUN. HAS NOW BEEN
CHANGED TO- PROVIDE BE USED TO
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE. RELIEF AND
REDUCING RATES FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN. OUR IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO- SO OVERALL THE LONG
TERM SAVINGS WILL BE WILL BE
SMALLER BUT THEY WILL BE MORE
IMMEDIATE. IN IN THE NEXT
YEARS. THIS IS ANOTHER
IMPORTANT FACTOR THAT'S-
AFFECTING KIND OF. SOME
COMMENTS ON SOME OF THE-
INDIVIDUAL POSSIBLE LET'S SAY
NOT FOR THE SPECIFIC ITEMS
RIGHT NOW I'M JUST HAPPY TO.
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SIR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANY
COMMENT. GOOD MORNING GENERAL
ROD AND SENATORS AND THIS IS
JESSICA HOLMES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE MAY
REVISION BALANCES ARE AVAILABLE
RESOURCES- AND MAXIMIZES
SUPPORT FOR ELEAZAR THIS
DIFFICULT TIME. AS MR CABRAL
MENTIONS THAT CROP NINETY
GUARANTEE HAS BEEN REDUCED DOWN
BASED ON CHANGES IN REVENUES.
AND WE ARE PROPOSING TO FUND IT
AT ITS MINIMUM GUARANTEE LEVEL
HOWEVER- WE DO PROPOSE ALSO
QUITE A BIT ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO HELP SUPPORT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. DEAL WITH THESE CUTS.
WE DO THIS AS MR BALL AGAIN
MENTIONED BY PROPOSING TO
INCREASE REVENUES AT. ALL
FUNDS- MAINTAINING INCREASED
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING THAT
WE PROPOSED AT A JANUARY-
INCREASING THE STIRS PERS
PAYDOWN OF EMPLOYER RATES IN.
202-020-2020 ONE AND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND PROPOSING
SEVERAL FLEXIBILITIES FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
ADDITIONALLY BASS WILL TALK
ABOUT IN THE LATER ITEM WE ARE
PROPOSING TO PROVIDE AND
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OVER SEVERAL
YEARS. I'M IN THE FORM OF A ONE
TIME OVER PREPARATIONS OF ONE
POINT 5% OF ALL GENERAL FUND.
THIS TOTAL AMOUNT REPRESENTS
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TEST TO-
AND TEST ONE THE FUNDED LEVEL
IN BOTH TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
AND TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
AND WE ARE ALSO PROPOSING TO
REVENGE TEST ONE OF THE
GUARANTEE. UP 240% FROM ITS
CURRENT THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT.
WE BELIEVE ALL OF THESE
PROPOSALS WILL ALLOW SCHOOLS
TO. RECOVER FROM THE CURRENT
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN MORE QUICKLY
THAN THEY OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE TODAY-
I HAVE A TEAM HERE WITH ME. ON
SPECIFIC TO PROP NINETY EIGHT
MY COLLEAGUE- AND READY WILL BE
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THE PURPOSE OF EDUCATION ANY
COMMENTS. YES THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN ROCK AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
STEPHANIE GRACE AND SHE STUCK
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION HERE FOR
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TWENTY THURMAN AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US HERE TODAY. AS YOU KNOW THE
KOBE NINETEEN CRISIS HAS
DRAMATICALLY IMPACTED NEARLY
EVERY FACET OF LIFE. HM WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S WORK
TO KEEP EDUCATION FUNDING I'M
CHANGE DURING THE CURRENT YEAR
AS ALLOCATION OF FOUR POINT
FOUR BILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS
FOR K. TWELVE WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CUTS TO EDUCATION FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR. PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE SEE THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA THE PROPOSED
10% REDUCTION TO THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA WOULD
BE A SIGNIFICANT CUT AT ANY
TIME. BUT THIS IS NOT ANY TIME
THE LCF CUTS SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED NOT JUST IN RELATION
TO THE PREVIOUS YEAR'S FUNDING
BUT YOU THE INCREASED COSTS
WILL STILL OPERATE IN THE TIME
OF COPING NINETEEN. WHEN
SCHOOLS REOPENED THEY WILL FACE
MANY NEW CHALLENGES SCHOOLS
WILL HAVE TO RECONCILE THE
PHYSICAL LIMITATIONS OF
CLASSROOMS AND SCHOOLS IT SAYS.
THAT THE CLOSEST SYNCING
REQUIRE. TEACHERS PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING TO DEVELOP- AND
READINESS FOR NEW AND CREATIVE
APPROACHES TO KEEPING. THESE
ARE JUST A FEW SAMPLE STRAIGHT.
UNDER AND IT NEEDED TO WE CAN
SAFELY OPEN SCHOOL. WHICH WE
ALSO IT'S CRUCIAL FOR STATES TO
REAL. ECONOMY THIS. SCHOOL
REALLY ARE AT THE SAME ARGUE.
SCHOOLS FROM A LIST EAR AND
CURSED CONNECT. TO A TEACHER OR
STAFF MEMBER ACCESS TO INTERNET
AND DEVICE. SUPPORTERS
EMOTIONAL WELL AND- MEALS FOR
MANY OF OUR- TO SCHOOL ARE THE
ONLY PLACE THEY FEEL SAFE. AND
ARE PROVIDED WITH THE ACADEMIC
AND PERSONAL NURTURING THE
DESERT. AS YOU KNOW HEALTHY
SCHOOL MEALS PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
FOOD SECURITY SAFELY THAT
SAFETY NET FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN. RESEARCH
CONFIRMS THE LINK BETWEEN WELL
NURSE STUDENTS AND ACADEMIC
SUCCESS OVER SOME STUDENTS
SCHOOL MEALS AND MOST
SIGNIFICANT. DAY THROUGHOUT THE
PAST TEN WEEKS OUR SCHOOLS HAVE
BEEN ON THE FRONT LINE OFFERING
CRITICAL MEAL SERVICES. THE CD
HAS RIGHT. FOR TWENTY FIVE
FEDERAL WAIVERS AND HAS ACCRUED
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED AND NINETY
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCY
WAIVERS FOR NON CONCRETE MEALS
AND MORE I. THINK THREE AND
STATES THE COMPANY CONDEMNING
BECAUSE ALL EXACERBATED THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. EVEN BEFORE
BEFORE THIS. BEGAN
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN. AN
INTERESTING THEY GOT IN ACCESS
NOW THIS TIME OF DISTANCE AND
ARE RELIANCE ON RIGHT AND- THE
NEED IS EVEN. SICK SIGNIFICANT
IN LATE MARCH THIS YEAR. FORM
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE TASK FORCE
CO CHAIRED BY SENATOR LEYVA AND
WITH LEGISLATORS FROM BOTH
HOUSES INCLUDING SENATOR
MCGUIRE TO ADDRESS THIS GAP.
FOR NOW AND INTO THE FUTURE
CALIFORNIA NEEDS AT LEAST FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
LAPTOPS AND THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND WIFI HOT SPOT.
TO CONNECT EVERY STUDENT TO THE
INTERNET AT HOME. WE NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER AND BE CREATIVE
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT GOING
TO BE EASY BUT WE'RE LOOKING TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR TO FIND WAYS TO AVOID
CUTS TO EDUCATION FUNDING. AND
PROPOSITIONAL REVENUE SOURCES
TO ENSURE SCHOOLS HAVE THE
FUNDING THEY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL OUR TEAM IS HERE TO
ANSWER ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TOM. COLLINS RUN ISSUE
NUMBER ONE ANY QUESTIONS
MEMBERS FROM THE DIOCESAN LABOR.
SEVERAL NO SIR OKAY HEARING THE
QUESTIONS LET'S MOVE ON TO-
ISSUE NUMBER TWO THIS HAS TO DO
WITH THE SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT
PLAN AND PROP NINETY EIGHT TO
THE EXTENT THAT THAT THIS IS
NOT BEEN COVERED LMAO. YES
CRAWL DELAY- SIDE I THINK THAT
THE- MEETINGS ALL THE TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE PROPOSAL-
EARLIER OF THE PROPOSAL IS TO
CREATE A SUPPLEMENTAL- PAYMENT
PLAN FOR- SCHOOLS BEYOND WHAT'S
IN THE PROBLEM AND EVEN I'M
GUARANTEED. BEGINNING IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. I'M NOT
OBLIGATIONS WOULD BE ONE POINT
5% OF GENERAL FUND REVENUES PER
YEAR- AND OUT WOULD BE IT WOULD
ADD UP TO ABOUT THIRTEEN
BILLION OVER A MULTI YEAR
PERIOD. AND IN ADDITION THE DM
TEN YEARS FOR SOME OF WHAT SOME
OF THOSE PAYMENTS WILL BE ONE
TIME PAYMENTS BUT SOME OF THEM
WOULD BE ONGOING PAYMENTS WOULD
INCREASE OF NINETY EIGHT OVER
THE LONG RUN. I MEAN
SPECIFICALLY THE STAR OF
GENERAL FUND IS GOING TO
SCHOOLS. OR THE SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN A MINIMUM
GRADE WOULD GO UP FROM 3540% BY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. WE
CONCERN WITH THE ALTHOUGH WE
WRECK YOU REJECT IT. I'M THINK
ARE. ARE CONCERNED JUST THAT
THE- WHOLE DOES COME.
TECHNOLOGY HAND. MOVING FORWARD
AND HOW TO MANAGE THE BUDGET
PROBLEMS. I'M INDIA. OUR MULTI
YEAR OUTLOOK- THE STATE IS
FACING DEFICITS WHILE THE SAME
TIME MAKING THESE ADDITIONAL
PAYMENTS. FROM THE SCHOOLS. AND
WE WOULD NOTE THAT- THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE WILL GO UP AS
REVENUES INCREASE AND NOTHING
CURRENTLY PREVENTS THE
LEGISLATURE FROM. PAYMENTS
ABOVE THE MINIMUM GUARANTEED TO
CHOOSE TO DO SO WE JUST
RECOMMEND YOU DO SO. THE WILL
TO GIVE YOU MORE. I'M YEAR TO
MAKE THE ABOUT HOW MUCH YOU CAN
IS OUR- R. COMMITTED TO PROVIDE
SCHOOLS ON HOW ONE YEAR BY YEAR
BASIS. THANK YOU SIR- RESOLVE
THE PERMANENT FINANCE IBM.
FORGOT THAT MY DAD'S CAR
CHANGES DEPENDING ON THE ISSUE
AND I SHOULD HAVE GIVEN YOU THE
FIRST SHOT AT THIS SO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
UNDERSTOOD THIS IS ERIN ALREADY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND ALL
YOU'RE NOT MISS HOLMES MY- I AM
I'M NOT WAS VERY ASTUTE OF YOU.
SHARE. BUT I'M HERE TO COVER
THIS ISSUE- SO AREA DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE LIKE I SAID- I WOULD
THINK MY COLLEAGUE MS HOMES
AND- EDGAR CABRAL SO I REALLY
FOR GIVING REALLY A GREAT
OUTLINE OF THE PROPOSAL I WILL
GO OVER THAT. WHERE I WOULD
JUST- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY WE
KNOW SUPPORT OUR PROPOSAL AND
WE FEEL THAT IT PROVIDES A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
UNCERTAINTY FOR SCHOOLS IN THE
YEARS COMING OUT OF A TIME WHEN
AT THAT WE ALL. UNIFICATION
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN FOR THEM AS-
IN MANY OF THEM YOU KNOW WE'RE
STILL CONTINUING TO MAKE
CHANGES AND ADAPTS TO LIFE POST
THE LAST RECESSION AND WITH THE
ADVENT OF THOSE EFFECTS IT'S
INTERESTING SO MANY THINGS HAVE
CHANGED OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS- AND SO WE- ARE PROPOSING
THIS. AS A WAY TO HELP THEM
MAINTAIN RESILIENCY IN THE
COMING YEARS AND KIND OF A
MIDDLE GROUND WHERE. WE CAN
STILL PUT FORTH A TRANSPORT
SHIP WHEN IT COMES TO. PARTS OF
THE BODY OUTSIDE OF PROP NINE
EIGHT BUT WE FELT IT THIS WAY
THIS WAS A WAY TO REALLY
MAXIMIZE- THAT GROWTH. AND
RETURNING THEM BACK TO THE GYM
TRAJECTORY- THEY WERE ON
BEFORE- CODE NINETEEN SO I'LL
LEAVE MY COMMENTS ABOUT BUT
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SIR DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. ANY COMMENTS. A
DIFFICULT SITUATION. OUR ONLY
COMMENT IS THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THESE ARE DIFFICULT SITUATIONS
OR SUPPORT OF ANY ADDITIONAL
EACH OF ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO EDUCATION. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING SPECTRA DOES ANY
QUESTIONS ARE LEVEL YEAH
SEVERAL. OKAY THIS IS A HOLD
OPEN ITEM SO- WE'LL MOVE ON TO.
ISSUE THREE IT'S- ITEM SIXTY
ONE HUNDRED DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ISSUE THREE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
REDUCTIONS AND DEFERRALS. I
HAVE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN
THE BATTING CAGE. THIS SPAM UP
I CAN'T HEAR YOU. OKAY CAN YOU
CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW SENATOR OCT
CLEAR AS A BELL THANK YOU.
AMBER ALEXANDER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TO HELP
DISTRICTS MAINTAIN SOME LEVEL
OF FISCAL STABILITY DURING THIS
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN THE MAY
REVISION STRIKES A BALANCE
BETWEEN REDUCTIONS IN
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
EXPENDITURES AND APPORTIONMENT
DEFERRALS. BUT THE QUICKLY ONE
POINT NINE BILLION AND I'LL SEE
IF I THOUGHT PORTION WENT FROM
201-922-2020 ONE STANDISH IN
ALL THREE POINT FOUR BILLION IS
ADDED TO THAT AMOUNT IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FOR A TOTAL OF FIVE
POINT THREE BILLION IN ELSE
EFFECT- ALL SCHEDULED FOR
PAYMENT ON TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. THE MAYOR VISION
ALSO INCLUDES TRAILER THE
LANGUAGE TO ESTABLISH A PROCESS
FOR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
TO SEEK AN EXEMPTION IF
APPORTIONMENT OF GIRLS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL CREATE A
DOCUMENT OF HARDSHIP.
ADDITIONALLY THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO REDUCE REDUCE ALSO
AFFECT FUNDING BY TEN PERCENT.
OR SIX POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THIS PRODUCTION INCLUDES
THE ELIMINATION OF A TWO POINT
31% COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT.
AND MAKING THESE ADJUSTMENTS TO
THE ALSO AFFECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S GOAL WAS TO
EQUITABLY REDUCED THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING PROVIDED FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU MA'AM HELLO. YES I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE
ANY MAJOR CONCERNS WITH THE
OVERALL STRUCTURE IN TERMS OF
THE BALANCE OF DEFERRALS AND
REDUCTIONS I THINK WE WERE JUST
SO WE JUST HAVE A COUPLE OTHER
OPTIONS BESIDES THAT YOU
CONSIDER IF YOU'RE TRYING TO
MAKE OTHER REDUCTIONS OUTSIDE
I'LL SEE ABOUT- OR OUTSIDE OF
THE BASE OF THE EFFORTS OF
PUTTING HIM OUT I'M- WHAT WHAT
AREA IS IT RELATED TO THE WHY
WOULD THE MINIMUM CITY
PROVISION OF LCF. ADD ON TO THE
FORMULA THAT WAS PROVIDED-
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR
SOME DISTRICTS ARE MOVING
FORWARD- THROUGH MOSTLY. THIS
FUNDING SOURCES IT'S GOES TO BE
TO GET DISTRICT THE- WHO.
PROPERTY TAXES ARE ONE IS.
BEYOND OUR BUT WHAT THEY WOULD
UNDER I'LL SEE IF I STILL THERE
SINCE EVEN EFFECTIVE. LEVEL ARE
GREATER THAN I'LL SEE UP. AND
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY BASED ON
ANY PARTICULAR- DETERMINATION
OF NEED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL SO.
WE BREAK AMANDA ARE ONE OPTION
WOULD BE TO. ELIMINATE THIS
PROVISION WHICH WOULD SAVE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION GENERAL
FUND. THAT COULD BE USED
PRODUCTION ART. AVOID
REDUCTIONS IN OTHER AREAS.
ANOTHER ANOTHER ALTERNATIVE TO
THE LEGISLATURE IF YOU DON'T
WANT TO GET RID OF THE THIS
PROVISION COMPLETELY SCRAMBLED
MY- SPECIFIC. REDUCTIONS TO THE
MINIMUM STATE AID OR TO OTHER
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS FOR
BASICALLY DISTRICTS WHOSE. ARE
WITHIN THE REVENUES PRIMARILY.
FROM PROPERTY TAXES. WHEN THE
EMBLEM LC CUTS. THE WAY THAT IS
IT MAY IS BY. REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF GENERAL FUND OF THE
RECEIVES. IF YOU'RE A BASICALLY
DISTURBING YOU DON'T GET
GENERAL COUNTRY EFFECT AND
THERE IS NO REDUCTION FOR YOU.
AND SO WHEN WAY TO ONE ONE.
OPTION FOR YEARS TO COME-
IMPLEMENT LANGUAGE IT SAYS THAT
THERE WILL BE REDUCTIONS TO OUR
BASICALLY DISTRICTS UP IN
PROPORTION TO A 10% CUT TO
HEALTHIER PRODUCTS. YOU CAN
WOULDN'T WOULDN'T INSURE ALL
DISTRICTS ARE FACING THE SAME
KIND OF REDUCTION ON THE YEAR
OVER YEAR BASIS. BUT ALSO MEANS
THAT YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE A
CONDITIONAL REDUCTIONS IN OTHER
PARTS OF. THE THANK YOU SO-DEPARTMENT WHICH- ANY REMARKS
WE ALREADY EXPRESSED OUR
CONCERNS AROUND THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA CUTS.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS WITH US ANY
QUESTIONS SETTLEMENT TOMORROW
LET ME ASK YOU ONE OR TWO OF
FINANCE MAYBE YOU COULD RESPOND
TO THE LA- THIS PROPOSAL- IN
PART OF THE PROPOSAL RELATED TO
BASIC AID DISTRICTS AND
CATEGORICAL FUNDING AND THE
OTHER POINTS THAT WERE MADE.
WHAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
MENTIONED- IN THE IN THE
OPENING REMARKS AREN'T CAN'T
WHAT'S REALLY TOP 5210%
REDUCTION- EQUITABLY ACROSS THE
BOARD. SO WE DIDN'T TAKE THE
APPROACH OF APPLYING IT AT THE
BASE GRANT- WHICH WILL BAN YOU
KNOW REDUCED- SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION GRANTS FUNDING AS
WELL AS FLOW THROUGH THE
FORMULA- OUR INTENT WAS ALSO TO
APPLY THAT IN PERCENTAGE.
RECENT REDUCTION TO THE- TOP.
IN THE FORMULA INCLUDING
MINIMUM STATE AID. I'M HOME TO
SCHOOL AND BASIC AID AND SO
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION BUT OUR OUR GOAL I
THINK. WHAT'S REALLY IN LINE
WITH BRAIN- ACROSS THE BOARD
DOWN BY 10% THANK YOU LET ME
ASK ONE ONE QUESTION RELATED TO
DEFERRALS- I ASK IT BEFORE-
SHOULD BELIEVE I DID DURING
THE- BIG BUDGET OVERVIEW
HEARING- ON THE MAY REVISION
BUT- WITH RESPECT TO DEFERRALS.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE LIMITED. RESERVE
ACCOUNTS AND LIMITED ABILITY OR
PERHAPS NO ABILITY. TO BORROW
AFFECTED FLEET TO COVER
OPERATING EXPENSES. IN THE
INTERIM. AMBER ALEXANDERAGAIN-
WITH FINANCING THERE IS TRIBAL
LANGUAGE I'M SPECIFIC TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY WONDER CROSS TO
PROVIDE AN EXEMPTION FOR LEDS
THAT WOULD FIND THEMSELVES. IN
THAT CIRCUMSTANCE. THERE IS NOT
AN EEMPTION PROCESS FOR
NINETEEN TWENTY- BUT BUT OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THAT THAT
IS GOING TO BE A JUNE TO JULY
DEFERRAL AND SO IT'S REALLY
GOING TO BE A MATTER OF- YOU
KNOW MAYBE ONLY A SCENE THAT
CAME. I'M JUST A MATTER OF
WEEKS LATER THAN THEY OTHERWISE
WOULD HAVE SO AT THE END.
HOPEFULLY THEY'LL BE ABLE TO-
TO PLAN AND NOT BE AS IMPACTED
BY IT RIGHT AFTER PEARL. GOING
FORWARD IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE
ARE MINDFUL AND THE ONLY ISSUE
YOU KNOW MAY HAVE SOME
DIFFICULTY AND WANTED TO
PROVIDE THAT EXEMPTION PROCESS
FOR THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES DO WE
HAVE ANY IDEA HOW MANY
DISTRICTS WOULD BE. IMPACTED IN
THAT WAY. WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION- ABOUT
ABOUT HOW MANY LEDS TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF THAT PROCESS WHEN
IT WAS PUT IN PLACE DURING THE
LAST RECESSION. I'M IN OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT IS THAT IS
THAT AT AT THAT TIME- IT WAS
REALLY ONLY A HANDFUL OF ELLIE
IS THAT NEEDED THAT EXEMPTION-
GRANITE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE VERY
DIFFERENT- THAT'S GOING AROUND
SO. WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT REALLY
IN A POSITION TO SAY YET- YOU
KNOW HOW MANY LEDS ARE GOING TO
NEED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
RECOGNIZING THAT THESE ARE
IMPRESSED AT TIMES THAT WORK IN
OURSELVES AND. OKAY WELL. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- THIS ITEM AS WELL
AS A HOLD OPEN ITEM LET'S MOVE
TO ISSUE NUMBER FOR CATEGORICAL
PROGRAM- TRIGGER REDUCTIONS AND
LET'S START WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THANK YOU GENERAL
THIS IS JUST GOING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO WE'VE
PROPOSED- TO PUT SEVERAL OF THE
REDUCTIONS THAT WE SPOKE ABOUT
EARLIER I'M INTO WHAT'S CALLED
A TRIGGER ALTHOUGH I THINK SOME
PEOPLE ARE REFERRING TO IT IT'S
REVERSED TRIGGERED BECAUSE THE
IDEA BEHIND THIS WOULD BE THAT.
TO THE EXTENT THAT REAL FUNDING
AND THIS INCREASED FOR
EDUCATION- WE WOULD USE THOSE
FUNDS THE FIRST CALL THOSE
FUNDS WOULD BE AND TO REDUCE
THE PRODUCTION IN L. C. S.
5210% ACTION LC ADDITIONALLY WE
ARE PROPOSING TO INCLUDE THE
REDUCTIONS TO CAP ORACLES- IN
THAT. A TRIGGER AS WELL.
SPECIFICALLY IN THE CATEGORICAL
REDUCTIONS WE'VE PROPOSED 50%
CUT. IN MANY OF OUR
CATEGORICAL- AND THEN OTHER
REDUCTIONS OF DIFFERING LEVELS-
IN SOME WHERE YOU KNOW THAT
THAT THERE WERE SOME.
SITUATIONS WHERE- 50% REDUCTION
IS NOT. POSSIBLE FOR EXAMPLE IN
THE AFTER SCHOOL GRAMS THAT WE
HAVE AND WE REDUCE THIS DOWN TO
THE PROPERTY NINE MINIMUM
FUNDING LEVELS SH SO- THOSE
REDUCTIONS WERE ALL INTENDED TO
INSURE THAT WE COULD REDUCE A
GENERAL PURPOSE RUNNING THROUGH
ALL SEE ABOUT. AS LITTLE AS
POSSIBLE AND PROVIDE AS MUCH
FLEXIBILITY. FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AS
POSSIBLE AND HOW THEY UTILIZE
THEIR FUNDS TO ADDRESS
REDUCTIONS IN REVENUES DURING
THIS DIFFICULT TIME. HAPPY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE THANK YOU. THANKYOU-
DIFFICULT CHOICES HAVING TO BE
MADE HERE HELLO. IF I WOULD
DECIDE ON THE ON THE CITY
PROGRAMS. THERE WILL BE A
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON SOME OF
OUR COMMITTEE CALLS RELATED
PROPOSALS IN EUROPE IN THE NEXT
ITEMS IN YOUR AGENDA MY
REFLECTION. ON OUR AFTER SCHOOL
I WOULD JUST NOT ONE OPTION FOR
YOU TO CONSIDER THE WAY THAT
THE REDUCTIONS RACES WOULD BE
ABOUT A 15% REDUCTION IN THEIR
RATES. THE PER CHILD RATES THAT
THEY RECEIVED- ONE ONE OPTION
IS TO GIVE THEM SOME MORE YOUR
PROVIDER SUPPORTS ABILITY TO R.
TO RETAKE THE REDUCTIONS BY
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
THAT THEY SERVE- AND
MAINTAINING THE AMOUNT TO PAY-
BASE SPEND PER CHILD THIS WOULD
ALLOW WE RECOGNIZE THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY A TRADE OPTIONS TO
REACH YOUR CHILDREN IT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT. MIGHT BECAUSE
IDEAL BUT- OTHERWISE THEY MIGHT
HAVE TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTIONS TO THE KINDS OF
ACTIVITIES AND PROGRAM
OFFERINGS AT THE CALENDAR FOR.
BUT I SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND SO.
THIS WILL BE RIGHT BACK TO. FOR
PROVIDERS MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
WHETHER WOULD PREFER TO HAVE. A
EATS SOME BETTER PRODUCE MORE
ARE ROBUST PRO. WITH YOU
CHILDREN. TO MAKE SOME
REDUCTIONS TO THOSE KIND OF
ACTIVITIES SO THAT THEY CAN
SERVE MORE CHILDREN. OR
CONTINUE SERVING THE SAME ON
THE SERVER. THANK YOU I LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING SOME FURTHER
CONVERSATION ON THE- ON THE CTE
PROGRAMS WHEN WE GET TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF SECTION
BECAUSE I AS I RECALL. YOU HAVE
SOME. RECOMMENDATIONS FOR.
VERSUS ONE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM OVER ANOTHER AND I'D BE
INTERESTED IN. HAVING SOME
FURTHER CONVERSATION ABOUT
THAT- THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THANK YOU TERRORIZE
WE UNDERSTAND THESE ARE
DIFFICULT CUTS ALL THE WAY
AROUND AND DON'T HAVE ANY
SPECIFIC COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES FOR LEVEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE YOU KNOW THESE
ARE DIFFICULT AND UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES BUT I JUST WANT TO GO ON
RECORD SAYING THAT I ABSOLUTELY
CANNOT SUPPORT A BUDGET THE
CUTS A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
OUT OF OUR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM.
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT RE OPENING
AND WE'LL TALK MORE ABOUT CHILD
CARE AS WE GO THROUGH THE
BUDGET. WHEN WE THINK ABOUT RE
OPENING OUR ECONOMY. IF PARENTS
DO NOT HAVE A PLACE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN TO GO. NO ONE GETS OFF
WORK AT TWO OR THREE O'CLOCK IN
THE AFTERNOON SO OUR OUR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS. ARE MORE
CRITICAL THAN THEY HAVE EVER
BEEN IN I APPRECIATE THE LA-
SAYING THAT THEIR CHOICE COULD
BE TO REDUCE THE DAILY RATE. OR
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN THAT THEY SERVE I
DON'T REALLY THINK THAT'S A
CHOICE- AND I UNDERSTAND LIKE I
SAID THESE ARE DIFFICULT TIMES
BUT IF WE'RE TRULY GOING TO
REOPEN OUR ECONOMY. AND ALLOW
PARENTS ESPECIALLY WORKING MOMS
TO GET BACK TO WORK THEY HAVE
TO HAVE THESE. AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND WE JUST STARTED
MAKING SOME PROGRESS WITH OUR
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND WE
HAD A LOT OF OUR DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS. BUT AFTER SCHOOL IS
JUST CRITICAL AND ESSENTIAL AND
I THINK WE CAN FIND A BETTER
WAY. THANK YOU MR CHAIR. THANK
YOU SIR LEVINSON MARONEY
QUESTIONS. OKAY. ISRAELI
CREATED I THINK THIS IS A HOLD
OPEN ITEM SO LET'S MOVE ON TO.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. WHICH IS
FEDERAL CORONAVIRUS RELIEF
FUNDS.AND THERE IS A STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ATTACHED TO THIS
SO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING AMBER ALEXANDER WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
ADMINISTRATION. INDICATION
INCLUDE A STRONG FOCUS ON
EQUITY FOR VULNERABLE STUDENTS
LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION IN
SUPPORT FOR HELPING SCHOOLS
THROUGH THIS ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
TO THIS END THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A ONE TIME INVESTMENT
OF FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION AT
TWO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
TO ADDRESS LEARNING LOSS
RELATED TO COVERT NINETEEN
SCHOOL CLOSURES. FRIENDS MAY BE
USED FOR A VARIETY OF PURPOSES
INCLUDING EXTENDING AND BE
INSTRUCTIONAL SCHOOL YEAR
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL ACADEMIC
SERVICES ARE INTEGRATED SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE. FOR
ACTUALLY DRILLS OR DEVICES FOR
BOTH IN CLASSROOM AND DISTANCE
LEARNING. ONE AND A HALF
BILLION OF THESE FUNDS WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED TO L. A.'S BASED ON
THEIR SPECIAL EDUCATION
ENROLLMENT COUNTS BUT THE
REMAINING TWO POINT EIGHT FIVE
FIVE BILLION BEING DISTRIBUTED
ON A PER PUPIL BASIS TALLY ACE
THAT GENERATE CONCENTRATION
GRANT FUNDING. THIS METHODOLOGY
IS INTENDED TO TARGET FUNDING
TOWARDS AT LEAST WITH THE MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS NAMELY
THOSE FOSTER YOU ENGLISH
LEARNERS LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
AS A CONDITION OF RECEIVING
THESE DOLLARS ELEAZAR ALSO BE
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE AN-
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY PLAN.
DESCRIBING HOW THEY WILL USE
THE FUNDS IN FULL COMPLIANCE
WITH FEDERAL LAW. HOW THEY WILL
MEASURE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE SERVICES THAT THEY'RE
PROVIDING WITH THESE DOLLARS
AND HOW THE L. E. A. WILL
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS ARE
PROVIDED WITH THE PRICES AND
CONNECTIVE ITTY. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE REGARDING THE PROPOSAL.
WELL BEFORE WE GET TO OUR
QUESTIONS AND I THINK WE'LL
PROBABLY HAVE A COUPLE- LET'S
MOVE TO THE LA L. YEAH. I'LL
JUST I'LL DESCRIBE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION HERE FOR YOU THE
RECOMMENDATION HERE IT WOULD
BE. TO PROVIDE THE SAME LEVEL
OF FUNDING TO PROVIDE THE FOUR
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR THE
LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION ARE.
CRAP AND TO. DISTRIBUTE THE ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES **** IN THE MAY
REVISION. I BET THEY'RE
CHANGING THE DISTRIBUTION ARM
AND THE TECHNICIAN THAT WOULD
BE TO DISTRIBUTE THE TWO POINT
NINE BILLION. R. TWO R. ELLIE
IS IN PROPORTION TO THEIR TOTAL
I'LL SEE IF I'VE BEEN DOING AS
OPPOSED TO THE INDUSTRY
PROPOSAL WHICH ONLY PROVIDED
FUNDING FOR THOSE WHO RECEIVE
CONCENTRATION GRAB A- THE STAFF
OF THE MISSION ALSO ADOPTS A
PLEASE LOOK CREDIBLE LANGUAGE
OR WHATEVER. WHAT'S THAT'S WHY
ALLI IS- CAN ALSO USE THE FUNDS
FOR WRAPAROUND SUPPORTS AROUND
THE STUDENTS THAT ARE SIMILAR
TO THE KIND OF SCHOOL PRIDE IN
THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS MODEL.
AND A BIG CAN USE IT TO
SUPPLEMENT EXISTING BEFORE
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS- THAT.
SHOULD TROUBLE TO MORE AND- BUT
WE HELP WITH. LOSS OR OTHER SHE-
OKAY THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. IF YOU WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF ANY ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT CAN BE
SHIFTED TO EDUCATION. OKAY WELL
LET ME- SOME REAL WOULD YOU
GIVE ANY QUESTIONS FIRST FOR ME
ASK A QUESTION OR TWO THEN.
FINE IT'S PERHAPS YOU COULD.
SORT OF TELL ME WHAT THE
RATIONALE WAS BEFORE SELECTING
A CONCENTRATION GRANT.
ALLOCATION FORMULA FOR THIS
FEDERAL FOR THESE FEDERAL
RELIEF FUNDS. WE CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A YOU
KNOW A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
WAYS THAT YOU CAN GO ABOUT
DISTRIBUTING THESE THESE
DOLLARS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
GOAL WAS REALLY TO- TARGET
THESE FUNDS TOWARDS THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS- AND WE
FELT LIKE CONCENTRATION GRANT
FUNDING BECAUSE IT IS
GENERATED- YOU KNOW BASED ON A
PERCENTAGE. OF AUSTRIA'S
FLOWING AND FOR REALLY WHY I
APPROPRIATE MEASURE TO DIRECT
FUNDING TOWARDS THAT
POPULATIONS THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO TARGET. BUT IT DOES YOU
WOULD ADMIT THAT IT DOES CREATE
A- SYSTEM OF WINNERS AND LOSERS
HERE WERE SOME DISTRICTS GET NO
MONEY IN OTHER DISTRICTS GET.
MONEY CORRECT. THERE CERTAINLY
WOULDN'T- THERE CERTAINLY WOULD
BE SOME LEDS AND BECAUSE THEY
DON'T GENERATE CONCENTRATION
GRANT DOLLARS WOULD WOULD BE-
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS PRODUCT I'M
FINDING THAT AGAIN- THAT THAT
WAS INTENTIONAL ON OUR PART
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T FEEL- LIKE WE
NEEDED TO TARGET THESE FUNDS
TOWARDS THOSE. AT LEAST WITH
THE HIGHER POPULATIONS. OKAY
WELL AS YOU SEE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO GET TOGETHER AND WORK
ON THIS BECAUSE WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO. TAKE CARE OF THOSE WHO
WERE ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
FOSTER KIDS FREE AND REDUCED
LUNCH THE DISADVANTAGED.
STUDENTS FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND ARE. IN EARLY
AGE BUT WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S AT THE SAME
TIME AN APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF
FUNDING. IN ALL DISTRICTS- THAT
CROSS THE STATE- AND AS I
RECALL. IN THE THIRTY FIRST
SENATE DISTRICT FOR EXAMPLE.
THIS FUNDING FORMULA LEAVES OUT
OF A FORTY OR FIFTY THOUSAND.
KIDS AND THAT'S THAT'S A
DIFFICULT SITUATION SO WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO GRAPPLE WITH THAT
BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE
RESPONSE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONVERSATION CALLING SERVE
ANY. QUESTIONS ON THIS
SETTLEMENT OKAY OKAY. WE WILL.
TAKE CARE OF THIS WHEN WE GET
TO THE- VOTE ITEMS LET'S MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX. FEDERAL
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY
SCHOOLS EMERGENCY RELIEF FUNDS
THE S. FOR FASTER FUNDS. LET'S
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AMBER ALEXANDER WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED ONE POINT
SIX BILLION IN FEDERAL AMOUNT
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY SCHOOL
EMERGENCY RELIEF FUNDS. OF THIS
AMOUNT 90% OR ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION WILL BE ALLOCATED TO
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES IN
PROPORTION TO THE AMOUNT OF
TITLE ONE I'M FINDING THAT THEY
RECEIVED FOR CORPORATE RELATED
COSTS. SPECIFICALLY FINDINGS
PROVIDED TO HELP SCHOOLS
RESPOND TO CORONA VIRUS AND
RELATED SCHOOL CLOSURES. MEET
THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS IMPROVE THE USE OF
EDUCATIONAL TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT
DISTANCE LEARNING AND TO MAKE
UP FOR LOST TIME LOST LEARNING
TIME. I'LL NOW TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUES WILL TOUCH
BRIEFLY ON HOW THE REMAINING
10% OF THE ESR FUNDS WILL BE
USED TO SUPPORT KOBE NINETEEN
RELATED STATE LEVEL ACTIVITIES.
GOOD MORNING ENHANCE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WILL
TOUCH BRIEFLY ON A SIXTY THREE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS JUST
BEING ALLOCATED FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
SPECIFICALLY THIS FUNDING IS
GOING TO BE AVAILABLE TO HELP
EDUCATORS ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES THAT NUMBERS ARE
INSTRUCTIONAL CHALLENGES
RESULTING FROM THE COLD AT
NINETEEN CRISIS. OF THE SIXTY
THREE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
SPECIFICALLY FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS HAS BEEN ALLOCATED TO
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO
DEVELOP PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES AND RESOURCES.
FOR L. E. ASE TO ADDRESS. ARE
TO DEVELOP CONTINUITY PLANS TO
HELP THEM DEVELOP STRATEGIES TO
HELP IN THE EVENT OF A SCHOOL
CLOSURE SPECIFICALLY TO
MAINTAIN. THE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT ABLE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT OF SUCCESS FOR ME
TO FACILITATE DISTANCE
LEARNING. ALSO THESE RESOURCES
WOULD HELP ELEAZAR ADDRESS
CHALLENGES ARE RELATED TO THE
TRAUMA THAT HAVE RESULTED FROM.
COPA NINETEEN CRISIS TO HELP
STUDENTS THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
LEARNING LOSS CHALLENGES AND
ALSO THE RESOURCES WOULD BE
DEVELOPED TO. ADDRESS
OPPORTUNITY GAPS WITH A
SPECIFIC FOCUS ON HELPING THE
ENGLISH LEARNER STUDENTS OUR
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS AND
YOU KNOW STUDENTS AND UNIQUE
POPULATIONS. WELL THE PROPOSAL
ALSO ALLOCATES EIGHT POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO THEIR
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE TO
DEVELOP PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EDUCATORS TO
ADDRESS ABOUT LEARNING LOST.
ALSO THE PROPOSAL PROVIDES
EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. LEARNING ACADEMY THIS
IS RESOURCES FOR OUR SCHOOL
LEADES TO HELP WITH LEARNING
LOSS AND TO ALSO HELP WITH THE
CHALLENGES OF DISTANCE
LEARNING. AND FINALLY THE
PROPOSAL ALLOCATES SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO USE THE SUBJECT
MATTER PROJECTS WITH A SPECIFIC
FOCUS ON MATHEMATICS SCIENCE
AND ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS. WELL
THE PROPOSAL AND OF THE TOTAL
THAT'S YOUR FUNDS ALLOCATED
FIVE UP 210% STATE LEVEL
ACTIVITY WE'VE ALLOCATED ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE AFTER STATE OPERATIONS
SUPPORT TO HELP THE DEPARTMENT
ADMINISTER THE FUNDS AND
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
MONITORING OF THESE PLANS. WILL
NOT PASS IT ALONG TO MY
COLLEAGUE LISA RESEARCH. GOOD
MORNING LEAVE THE RESIDENCE THE
PARDON OF FINANCIER OF THE ESR
FUNDS ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSED TO GO TO THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL- GRANT
PROGRAM. THIS IS THE SAME
PROPOSAL THAT WAS PRESENTED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HOWEVER
INSTEAD OF USING THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND WE SHIFTED THEM. THOSE OLD.
AS YOUR- WHAT WE CALL THE
NINETEEN AND YOU HAVE YOU HAD
DISCUSSED BALDWIN AT AN AMBER
PRIOR ON THE PANDEMIC HAS
ACCESS ACT EXASPERATED
CONDITIONS OF POVERTY AND THE
IN EQUITIES WHICH LEAD TO OUT
BARRIERS TO LEARNING SO THIS
FUNDING WILL BE USED TO DEVELOP
NETWORKS OF COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
IN HIGH POVERTY AREAS TO BETTER
COORDINATE HEALTH TO HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICES SUPPORT FOR
HIGH NEEDS STUDENTS. THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THIS GRANT
AGAIN WILL BE JUST A-
ADMINISTERED BY THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. ALL WITH THE
APPROVAL AND IN COORDINATION
WITH THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION SO
WITH THAT WE I WILL OPEN UP IF
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION BY
THE WAY FINANCE THAT'S ABOUT
THE SMOOTHEST BATON PASSING I
THINK I'VE EVER SEEN. L. L. AND
YOU THOUGHT THIS IS GONNA BE
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION HERE-
SO THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IT
WOULD MAINTAIN THERE'S ONE AND
A HALF MILLION BITS OF THIS OF
THIS FUNDING OF JUST 10% SIX
OUT OF A GROUP GOING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF THAT'S PROPOSED
TO GO TO THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT
FIRST AID OPERATIONS. WITH THAT
RECOMMENDATION WOULD MAINTAIN
THAT FUNDING BUT THEN THE
REMAINING HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THREE POINT TWO MILLION WOULD
BE USED FOR DIFFERENT PURPOSES
SIXTY THREE POINT TWO MILLION
WOULD BE USED FOR OUR CHILD
NUTRITION REIMBURSEMENT
ADMINISTERED TO ALIENS WHO
SERVED OR WILL CONTINUE TO
SERVE SCHOOL MEALS FROM WHEN
KOBE. ARE TO GAP THROUGHOUR
BEGINNING OF THE SCHOOL YEAR-
THE ACTION BUT ALSO NO KNOW
THAT THIS THING IS UP SOME OF
THOSE ADDITIONAL FUNDING CAN BE
USED FOR PURPOSE- FUNDING WOULD
BE USED INSTEAD AND THEN THIS
FUNDING WOULD THEN BE
REDIRECTED TO THE LEARNING
PROCESS. BLACKROCK BUT I DID
HEAR HEART BEAT THE- IT
INCLUDES SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION AND NUTRITION
FUNDING. THAT WAS PART OF THE
FEDERAL AT IS NOW IN THE MAIN
REASON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AS WELL ZERO GUY AS HOW THAT
CAN BE SO IF HAPPENING BE USED
THIS PURPOSE WOULD BE A WE USE
THE THAT'S I MEAN. I'M NOT
CURRENTLY THERE'S A HIGH
MILLION FOR SCHOOLS WE OPENING
SO WHAT GRANT WHICH ARE GOING
TO ALL A OF STUDENT BUT FOR ALL
OF THEM WHO ARE NOT WHO HAVE R.
OR NON CLASSROOM EXCLUDING
AUSTIN BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND THIS FUNDING THAT COULD BE
USED VERY EFFECTIVELY FOR
THINGS LIKE CLEANING SUPPLIES
EQUIPMENT SOCIAL. EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS WERE
INTRIGUED. THANK YOU SIR TO
PERPETRATION ANY COMMENT. I YES
WE JUST LIKE WHAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE'S ABILITY TO PASS
THE BATON TO SMOOTHLY WE HOPE
AND AIM TO DO THE SAME THING
AND WHEN IT IS OUR TURN TO
TRANSITION WE UNDERSTAND THE
SENATE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WHICH WAS COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WE PREFER YOU
PREVIOUSLY SUPPORTED COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS BUT ALSO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL CHILD NUTRITION
FUNDS AS WELL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR CALLING A QUESTION
CERTAINLY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IT DOES SEEM LIKE THERE'S
SOME CONFUSION AROUND THE CARES
MONEY AND HOW IT CAN BE SPENT
SO I'M JUST HOPING THERE WILL
BE SOME GUIDANCE THERE I KNOW
THAT THAT WOULD BE EXTREMELY
HELPFUL FOR THE- THAT'S COOL
EACH SCHOOL AND THE
NUTRITIONIST SO JUST.
ADVOCATING FOR SOME GUIDANCE.
SEVERAL QUESTIONS YES I DO HAVE
PLEASE YEAH I'D LIKE TO KNOW
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT CAN SHARE
YOUR THINKING ABOUT WHY NON
CLASSROOM. BASED SCHOOLS THAT
RELY ON SITE BASED RESOURCE
CENTERS TO PROVIDE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION- HAS BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM THE FEDERAL CARES ACT-
SUPPLEMENT FOR LEARNING LOSS
PLEASE. ANYBODY. WELL SIR I
THINK EARLIER WAS SIMPLY
PRESENTING THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION- HELLO DO YOU
HAVE ANY INSIGHT. I WOULD I
THINK- BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE INTENT IS IN PART
BECAUSE IF THESE ARE PHYSICALLY
RE OPENING- IF YOU'RE
PHYSICALLY OPENING SCHOOL SITES
AND SOME OF THE COSTS ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT AND THAT'S
WHY THE- FUNDS RECORDED BUT I.
RECOGNIZING SEVERAL I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE SOME. OF
MY CLASSROOM BASED PROGRAM TO
HAVE SOME. ON WHAT SOME PEOPLE
ARE NOT THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY
FULLY ONLINE AN THERE ARE- OR
FULLY AT HOME AND THERE ARE A
LOT ABOUT PROGRAMS THAT DO
OCCUR ON C. SIX SCHOOLS ARE.
MAYBE WE NEED TO TAKE ANOTHER
LOOK AT THAT I MEAN I'VE IF YOU
LOOK AT THE DESCRIPTION IT'S
PRIMARILY DESIGNED TO HELP THE
SCHOOL. RE OPEN PRESUMABLY A
SCHOOLTHAT'S GOING TO TAKE
STUDENTS ON SITE CLEANING
SUPPLIES EQUIPMENT TRAINING. IN
TERMS OF HOW TO DO THAT RE
OPENING BUT PERHAPS. PERHAPS
THERE IS SOME ASPECT HAVING TO
DO WITH THESE. NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS WE CAN
TAKE A LOOK AT IT AND WE'LL BE
HAPPY TO DO THAT. YOU CAN.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COLLEAGUES LET'S MOVE ON TO.
ANOTHER DIFFICULT ISSUE ISSUE
SEVEN CALCULATING ADA AND
INSTRUCTIONAL REQUIREMENTS. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION ON
THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM BUT-
LET'S GO AHEAD AND START WITH
THE ELIO. THE SERVICE IS NOT AN
ISSUE THAT'S SPECIFIC TO YOU
YEAH THAT'S INCLUDED IN THE
MAIN REASON BUT I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR YOU ALL TO
CONSIDER AND DISCUSS AND I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT. WE
READ SOME COMMENTS IN A
PREVIOUS SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING
AND I THINK MANY OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE RAISING THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE I'M NOT.
SURE R. ONE HOUSE SCHOOLS ARE
FUNDED. YOU WILL SEE IF FOR
SPECIAL ED. OR OTHER MAJOR
PROGRAMS WITHIN. THE COMING
BUDGET YEAR AND THEN WHAT ARE
THE- CONSTRUCTION REQUIREMENTS.
IN THE EVENT OF SCHOOL
CLOSURES. AND JUST PROVIDE SOME
BRIEF CONTEXT- WHEN- THE
EMERGENCY EXECUTIVE ORDER WAS.
WAS ISSUED IN IN MID MARCH- THE
LEGISLATURE SUBSEQUENTLY PASSED
SB ONE SEVENTEEN. WHICH ARE.
TRYING TO PROVIDE SOME OF THE
SCHOOL OF STABILITY FISCAL OUR-
PREDICTABILITY FOR DISTRICTS IN
AND THEN. A COUPLE OF THINGS
ONE IT SAID THAT. IF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DO NOT OFFER A FULL
HUNDRED NEEDY SCHOOL YEAR. THEY
WILL NOT FACE FISCAL PENALTIES
WHICH ARE CURRENTLY IN LAW. IF
YOU DON'T HAVE A HUNDRED IT'S
CLEAR TYPICALLY WE HAVE YOU'RE-
YOU'RE ALL SET. I MEAN GETS
REDUCED. THE SECOND THING IT
DIDN'T. IS IT STOPPED. TURNING
EIGHTY EIGHT OR TEN MINUTES-
AFTER FEBRUARY TWENTY NINE. AND
I. THINK AGAIN THE IDEA WAS. SO
THAT SCHOOLS WOULD NOT BE HURT
BY THE FACT THAT. MANY STUDENTS
WERE COMING ACROSS SO THAT THE
RECORD YOUR DRINK- SERVE AS- AS
THE- CULMINATING OUTBREAK. AND
SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SO
THAT. THESE ARE THESE ARE
MEASURES THAT WERE. INCLUDED
FOR THE- OF THE FISCAL YEAR BUT
THEY DO. CONTINUE INTO THE YEAR
TWENTY FOUR ONE AND SO WANT TO
PUT QUESTION TO. WHAT WHAT IF
ANY KIND OF MEASURES THIS DO
YOU TO INCLUDE IN YOUR TWENTIES.
ONE BUDGET CONSIDERING THAT
THERE ARE NO RIGHT NOW WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF CLARITY ABOUT
EXACTLY WHAT WE OPNING WILL
LOOK LIKE. WE DON'T KNOW IF
THAT IF SCHOOL OPEN AS THEY-
ARE INTENDED BEFORE AND WE
DON'T KNOW IF THERE MIGHT BE A
POSSIBILITY OF. ADDITIONAL
SCHOOL CLOSURES AS- ADDITIONAL
OUTBREAKS FLARE UP. OVER THE
NEXT COMING YEAR- SO THAT THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF WAYS TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES BUT IT IS AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION FOR- SENDING
SIGNALS TO. THE FUEL ABOUT. HOW
IT WILL BE FUNDED. I THINK IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT ISSUE NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF THE FISCAL STABILITY
BUT ALSO BECAUSE IT FROM FROM.
YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY HERE
TO SOMETHING QUITE A MESSAGE
JUST SCHOOL DISTRICT ABOUT WHAT
YOU EXPECT THEM TO DO. DURING
THESE CLOSURES AND WHAT KINDS
OF. DISTANCE LEARNING SHOULD
BE. PUT IN PLACE. IF THE IF
ADDITIONAL CALLS WERE TO OCCUR.
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WHEN THIS
OCCURRED IS THAT EVERYTHING
HAPPENED VERY QUICKLY IN MARCH
THAT THE ROAD RIGHT THERE'S A
LOT OF GUIDANCE PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT ADDED THERE WAS
THAT. EXACTLY WERE SPECIFIED
THAT. ARE YOU KNOW- ELLIE'S
WORK TO THE BEST OF THEIR
ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE.
HIGH QUALITY INSTRUCTION
THROUGH A DISTANCE LEARNING
FORMAT. BUT THIRD BUT BEYOND
THOSE KIND OF STATEMENTS THERE
WAS NOT A LOT OF CONCRETE.
REQUIREMENTS OR EXPECTATIONS
AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT-
AS PART OF THE BUDGET PROCESS
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
WEIGH IN A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THAT. WHAT YOU THINK. FOR
EXAMPLE NO NEXT QUESTION.
SHOULD BE FOR SCHOOLS. THANK
YOU SIR. FINANCE GIVEN THE SICK
OF THE BUT ISSUE WERE ACTUALLY
A BE INTERESTED IN YOUR
COMMENTS. CERTAINLY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- GENERAL OFFICE SO I
JUST CALLED DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE DON'T HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THIS PROPOSAL AND
AT THIS TIME HOWEVER WE DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS WITH THE IDEA OF.
HOLDING HARMLESS EIGHTY A. M.
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO THE
FIRST THING THAT I WOULD NOTE
IS- MOST SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
GOING TO RECEIVE A VERY SIMILAR
AMOUNT OF FUNDING PLUS THE
PRODUCTIONS AND I'LL SEE ABOUT-
AS THEY DID LAST YEAR BECAUSE
WE DO HAVE A HOLD HARMLESS
ALREADY BUILT INTO I'LL SEE
ABOUT THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
RECEIVE- THE SAME EIGHTY EIGHT.
IN THE PRIOR YEAR AND BECAUSE
WE DIDN'T HOLD HARMLESS
NINETEEN TWENTY- THAT WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY REFLECT ON COULD%
NINETEEN AT CHANGES IN DNA. I'M
SO THAT'S ALREADY BUILT IN- AND
I THINK TO THE EXTENT YOU KNOW
THERE'S A CONCERN ABOUT HOLDING
PEOPLE HOMELESS IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO I THINK THAT THAT'S
DEFINITELY. A CONVERSATION WE
CAN HAVE- IN TERMS OF- OTHER
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE WITH
WITHHOLDING HARMLESS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND WE'VE HAD SOME
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
HOLDING HER LIST IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AND AGAIN YOU KNOW WE
MADE THAT DECISION AND- THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. IN A TIME OF IT
EVEN MORE CERTAIN THAN WE HAVE
NOW- IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN COOK AT NINETEEN
AND I THINK AT THE TIME IT WAS
CERTAINLY AND I THINK IT
REMAINS THE CORRECT THING TO DO
BUT WE ARE HAVING SOME
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
THAT- INCLUDING THINGS LIKE WE
HAVE. AN OUTSTANDING ISSUE THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF ED ON ESPECIALLY
XFINITY ON THE EIGHTH INNING. I
WE HAVE SOME LEDS THAT DID HAVE
INCREASED YEAH THE BRIDGE WE
KNOW CUT OFF TO. ON AND HAD
KNOW K. OF YOU KNOW. AM I TO
WRITE TWENTY THE STADIUM AND
THEN YOU KNOW WE TO SORT OF
DOUBLE COUNTING. AND DOUBLE PAY
FOR I'LL SEE IF THAT. WAS NOT
LONGER AND LONGER. I NEED TO
CREATE A CLICK A FACT WHEN YOU
WERE FIRST BACK TO AN EDA
FUNDING FORMULA- THAT COULDN'T
REALLY BE A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
THE SCHOOL INTO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. AND COUNTY OFFICES
EDUCATION CHARTER SCHOOLS WHEN
THEY REVERT TO. A NORMAL EDA
SO- THESE ARE JUST SOME THINGS
TO KEEP IN MIND- AGAIN I THINK.
WE ARE WE- THINK OF THIS MORE
AS A TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
CONVERSATION AS OPPOSED TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CONVERSATION.
THANKS AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THERE'S ALWAYS ALREADY A WHOLE
WHOLE DORM WAS BUILT INTO THE
LC HAVE. YES THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. YES THANK YOU WE I
WE NEED TO BE PREPARED FOR THE
IMPACT THAT THIS IT INTENDED TO
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME IS GOING TO
HAVE IN THE COMING YEAR MANY OF
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
ELEAZAR ARE ALREADY PLANNING
FOR WHAT THEIR INSTRUCTIONAL
MODELS WILL LOOK LIKE THEY'RE
SERVING THEIR FAMILIES OUR
COMMUNITY NEEDS AND IN ORDER TO
HAVE FLEXIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR INSTRUCTIONAL MODEL WILL
MEET THE NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES THEY WILL
NEED THE FLEXIBILITY FOR ADA
AND INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES SO
HOLDING HARMLESS THIS YEAR IS
WONDERFUL. WE'D ALSO LIKE TO
LOOK TO SEE AND EARS AND GOING
FROM THE ENROLLMENT EIGHTY
SYSTEM AND REALLY REALLY
LOOKING AT THE INSTRUCTIONAL
MINUTES REQUIREMENT AS WELL WE
ARE IN THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
MOVING INTO TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. REPRESENTS
FACTS AND REPRESENTS THE
DIFFERENT INSTRUCTIONAL MODELS
THAT OUR STUDENTS WILL NEED TO
BE SUCCESSFUL. WELL LET ME
START OFF THE QUESTIONS HERE
WHAT WHAT WOULD BE THE WHAT
WOULD BE THE NEGATIVES
ASSOCIATED WITH. HOLD HARMLESS
IN THE IN THE IN THE BUDGET
YEAR WE'RE DEALING WITH NOW
BUILT INTO THE L. C. F. F. AND
IF THAT NEEDS TO BE ENHANCED
ENHANCE IT. AND THEN. TAKING A
LOOK AT. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AT SOME LATER DATE
WHAT'S THE NEGATIVE TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. I GUESS THIS GOES TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
DID THAT MAKE SENSE. HELLO CAN
YOU CLARIFY YOUR QUESTION
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO LOOK TO
SEE IF THAT'S MORE OF A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND M.
SERVICES THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION VERY INTERESTED IN
THE FINANCE POSITION THERE'S A
THERE'S A HOLD HARMLESS BUILT
INTO THE LC A FAITHFUL TO THE
BOOK WHICH WILL TAKE CARE OF AT
LEAST LARGELY TAKE CARE OF THE
CURRENT OF THE BUDGET YOU'RE
WORKING ON NOW. AND WHEN YOU
TALK TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. FINANCE IS
CONCERNED ABOUT GOING OUT THAT
FAR FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
THAT FINANCE LISTED. INCLUDING
THE CLIFF EFFECT AT SOME POINT
WHEN YOU HAVE TO TREAT THIS
THING UP. SO WHAT WHAT WHAT
WOULD BE THE DOWNSIDE TO
DISTRICTS. TO THINK ABOUT. THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO BUDGET WHEN WE GET TO THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET.
SO MANY HAND THIS OVER TO
ELIZABETH YOUR SIGN DIRECTOR OF
OUR SCHOOL FISCAL SERVICE'S
DECISION DIVISION. THAT'S A
PRETTY GOOD BATON PASSED. HE
TERRORS HEALTH. THANK YOU
SENATOR ROCK I THINK- DISTRICTS
ARE PLANNING ON A MULTI YEAR
BASIS AND SO WHEN THEY DON'T
HAVE THAT WHEN THERE'S THAT
UNCERTAINTY WHAT WHAT TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO LOOKS LIKE IT
JUST IT MAKES THAT MULTI YEAR
PLANNING MORE DIFFICULT. HI
WELL WE MAY NEED YOU TO GET
WITH FINANCE AND TALK ABOUT
THIS CLIFF EFFECT AND HOW WE
CAN MITIGATE THAT- AS WE MOVE
FORWARD ALEX QUESTION CERTAINLY
WILL. SEVERAL QUESTIONS WHILE
YOU GUYS RIGHT. OKAY THIS IS A
HOLDOVER I FIND HIM SO LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT
SPECIAL EDUCATION. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN LEAVES RESIDENTS
GAVE WITH THE- HARTMAN OF
FINANCE IRAN I'M SO SORRY SO
SORRY THERE'S SOMETHING- SOONER
THAN THE REVISION MAINTAINS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
INCREASING SPECIAL EDUCATION
RESOURCES AND ALSO IMPROVING-
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING AND
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE WITH THE
GOAL OF REALLY IMPROVING THE
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS WITH THE
MOST EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS. AS
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES A
NEW BASE FORMULA WHICH WOULD
INCREASE THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
BASED WORKPLACE RIGHTS R. TWO
SIX HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION
PER ADA THIS IS DOWN SLIGHTLY
FROM THE SIX SIXTY PROPOSED AT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS A
RESULT OF. REDUCING OR REMOVING
THEM BUT ABOUT YOUR COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT. INCREASING
THE BASIC FORMULA IS REALLY IN
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENT
IDENTIFICATION AND ALSO THE
COST ASSOCIATED WITH PROVIDING
THE FEDERALLY MANDATED SERVICES
FOR THOSE STUDENTS HAS
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY OVER
THE YEARS. AT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL ALSO
MAINTAINS THE WORKGROUPS AND
STUDIES INCLUDED IN GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. WHICH BEGAN THE STATE'S
PROCESS OF TRYING TO GATHER
DATA AND INFORMATION ON OUR
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS AND
THE SERVICES THEY'RE RECEIVING.
TO BETTER INFORM THE NEXT
PHASES OF OUR- SPECIAL
EDUCATION REFORM BOTH IN FOR
THE FOR MY AND ALSO FOR
PROGRAMMATIC REFORMS. ON THESE
REFORMS WILL REALLY FOCUS ON
EQUITY AND IMPROVEMENT IN THE
CURRENT SPECIAL EDUCATION
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM. SO THE
MAY REVISION- MAINTAIN THE WORK
GROUPS BUT ALSO ADDED A TWO
ADDITIONAL WORKERS ONE IS FOR
AN IEP TEMPLATE ADDENDUM WHICH
WILL FOCUS N ESTABLISHING IN
THE- US- DISTANCE LEARNING
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICE
MODEL. LL WHITE PIECE SO THAT
SHOULD THIS. HOPEFULLY NEVER
AGAIN BUT SHOULD IT HAPPEN
AGAIN I'M ALL STUDENTS HAVE A
SERVICE PLAN IN PLACE WHICH
DOES PARENTS HAVE SEEN AN
AGREED TO AND IT SHOULD. BE A
LOT BE GOOD FOR BOTH PARENTS
AND THE STUDENTS AND THE OTHER
IS THAT ADAM WORKGROUP STUDY ON
OUR OUT OF HOME CARE I'M AS YOU
KNOW AFTER THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM OUR OUT OF HOME
CARE FUNDING HAS KIND OF BEEN
FROZEN AND ALSO WE REALLY NEED
TO GET IN THERE TAKE A BETTER
LOOK AT HESE PROGRAMS THE
SERVICES AND ALSO- ALL OF THE
SERVICES PROVIDED STUDENTS THAT
RECEIVE THE OUT OF HOME
PLACEMENT. SO WITH THAT I
WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU FOR THAT HELLO. IF THERE'S
ANOTHER ISSUE WHERE THERE'S A
STAFF RECOMMENDATION HERE- AND
SO I WAS JUST GONNA WALK WALK
THROUGH WITH THAT
RECOMMENDATION IS BECAUSE THE
MULTIPLE COMPONENTS HERE- SO
THIS IS AN ALTERNATIVE TO THE
ARMY REVISION PROPOSAL- INSTEAD
OF PROVIDING. THE SIX HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIVE MILLION IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR B.
SPECIAL EDUCATION RATE
INCREASES IT WOULD PROVIDE FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE MILLION.
THE GRAVEYARD THE ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED MILLION THAT'S FREE UP
AND WOULD BE USED TO AUGMENT
FUNDING FR. STUDENTS WITH LOW
INCIDENCE DISABILITIES THESE
ARE- THE DEGREE OF STUDENTS WHO
HAVE VISUAL HEARING OR
ORTHOPEDIC IMPAIRMENTS. ON THE
NEXT- PART OF THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO. CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE FIFTY MILLION FOR
THE GOLDEN STATE THE MAIN
REASON PROVIDES FIFTY MILLION
FOR THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER
PROGRAM THIS WOULD STILL
PROVIDE IT BUT IT WOULD SHIFT
FUNDING TO- DEPARTMENT STATE
OPERATIONS- AND THEN THERE
WOULD BE- EIGHT POINT SIX
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING TO
ASSIST. IN PROVIDING OUR
REGIONAL ALTERNATE ALTERNATE
DISPUTE RESOLUTION SERVICES
JOBS ARE HIGHER THAN WHAT'S
INCLUDED THE MIRROR- THE- B. R.
ONE ADDITIONAL THING THAT
INTEGRATIVE LANGUAGE CHANGES
HERE- THE THEY WOULD HAVE TO
ADOPT A MARRIAGE PROPOSAL THE
SACRAMENT RECOGNITION WENT TO
SHIFT FUNDING FROM THE
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
STUDY. AND TO WORK GROUPS- FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY IN SPECIAL ED-
DELIVERY OUTCOMES THOSE WOULD
BE- MOVES FROM ABOUT NINETY TWO
FEDERAL ID A FINES AS WAS IN
THE MIRROR VERSION- AND THAT
WOULD BE ADDITIONAL PLACEHOLDER
TRAINER BILL LANGUAGE TO AMEND-
TO BROADEN THE SCOPE OF THE
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
STUDY- AND TO INCLUDE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF DISTANCE
LEARNING. I EAT PEAS ARE YOU
GET DONE BUTTONS IN THE RECORDS
RELATED. TO DEVELOPING A
STANDARDIZED AP TEMPLATE. IN
THE FINALLY RATHER HAVING A- OR
ON ON HOW TO HOME CARE. THE
WEST AFRICAN NATION WHERE.
ADOPTABLE GONNA REPORTING WHICH
TO DO OUR OUR TO THE A- FOR
THAT PROGRAM. THANK YOU SIR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE THE SIGNAL TO
CONTINUE THE WORK ON REFORMING
SPECIAL EDUCATION WE SUPPORT
THE SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATION TO
SPECIALIZE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND UNLIKE THE SENATE
PROPOSAL TO RETAIN THE CURRENT
pFORMULA UNTIL REFORMS AND
RESEARCH IS FINALIZED WE WOULD
APPRECIATE A COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH AND BE INVOLVED IN ANY
CONVERSATIONS MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR COMMENTS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
APPRECIATE THE ATTENTION THAT-
FOLKS HEARD A DEVOTING TO A-
SIR LEAVE ANY QUESTIONS. THAT I
HAVE NONE SO WELL LET'S MOVE
ON- THIS MOVE WILL REVISIT THIS
ISSUE AGAIN A LITTLE BIT LATER.
THE NEXT ISSUED DEPARTMENT-
THAT SIXTY ONE HUNDRED APPROACH
OF EDUCATION AND FIFTY ONE
EIGHTY DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ISSUE NUMBER NINE.
CHARTER RATE REDUCTIONS AND
GROWTH ADJUSTMENTS DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
JUST COMPOUNDS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO THE REVISION
INCLUDES SOME REDUCTIONS TO
RAPE OR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
AND LIKE TO NOTE THAT- THIS WAS
DONE WITH CAREFUL CONSIDERATION
AND NOT TAKEN LIGHTLY- BEFORE
ANY. ON GOING REDUCTIONS WERE
MADE TO RATES- FINANCE LOOK
VERY CLOSELY AT ANY
UNENCUMBERED- OR UNUSED ONE
TIME FUNDS THAT COULD BE
REDUCED FROM THESE PROGRAMS ARE
SET TO MITIGATE ANY IMPACTS. ON
THESE RATE REDUCTIONS- TO
ENSURE THAT WE WERE IMPACTING
PROVIDERS AS LITTLE AS POSSIBLE
SH I'M IN THE AREA OF RACE AND
OTHER THE OTHER THE OTHER. LENS
WE WERE LOOKING AT THIS THROUGH
WAS- FOCUSING ON MAINTAINING AS
MANY SPOTS AS POSSIBLE GIVEN
THE IMPORTANCE OF CHILD CARE
AND HELPING. THE ECONOMY
RECOVER- THE RATE REDUCTIONS
THAT WE DID TAKE WERE EVER AT
ELIMINATION OF A 1% OUT ON TO
THE STATE PRESCHOOL FULL DAY-
REIMBURSEMENT RATE AND 10%
REDUCTION TO THE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE. AND THE
REGIONAL MARKET REIMBURSEMENT
RATE. FROM RECOGNIZED THAT
THESE RATES WILL BE DIFFICULT
FOR PROVIDERS TO ACCEPT-
HOWEVER WE DO YOU PROPOSE TO
MITIGATE THESE IN SOME. WAY BY
ALLOCATING SOME FEDERAL CARES
ACT FUNDS FOR ONE TIME
STATEMENTS TO HELP. PROVIDERS
ADDRESS SOME OF THE COST OF
CODE NINETEEN ON AND SOME OF
THE- COST OF SMALLER. GROUP
SIZES THAT MAYBE REQUIRED
CONNECTING TEAM WHICH I'M HAPPY
TO ENGAGE IN A DISCUSSION- OVER
THINKING ABOUT ALL OF THIS- END
UP PLEASE LET US KNOW IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS HAPPY TO
ANSWER THEM. WELL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I'D I WOULD
APPRECIATE THE FINANCE REACTION
TO THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
ONCE IT'S DESCRIBED HERE HAVING
TO DO WITH THE ZERO TO FOUR
POPULATION TO TRY TO. TAKE CARE
OF RATHER THAN HAVE AN
AUTOMATIC REDUCTION TO TRY TO
TAKE CARE OF THE ELIGIBLE
POPULATION AS BEST WE CAN BUT
LET'S MOVE TO THE LA NEXT.
DISTRO JUST A COUPLE COMING
THAT WE HAD A FEW SUGGESTIONS
REGARDING ALTERNATIVES TO- TO
RATE REDUCTIONS- FOR ALTERNATE
WAYS TO TAKE THE REDUCTIONS
SPECIFICALLY ON THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE REDUCTION- WE WOULD
RECOMMEND RATHER THAN ACROSS
THE BOARD REDUCTION THAT THERE
BE A REDUCTION THAT'S BASED ON
THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE
SURVEY. TO ENSURE THAT FAMILIES
HAVE ACCESS TO THE SAME- FIRST
QUESTION OF THE MARKET IN THEIR
AREAS ACROSS THE STATE. THE WAY
THAT IT SHOULD MATTER NOW WE
HAVE CONCERNS THAT IT MIGHT BUT
NOW THAT MIGHT NOT BE THE CASE.
WE ALSO NOTED A COUPLE OF OTHER
PLACES IN THE CITY WAS
INTERESTED IN. MAKING
REDUCTIONS OUTSIDE OF. SPECIFIC
RATES- OR SLOTS AMERICA A
COUPLE OF AREAS CONSIDER. ONE
REBOUND BUT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER REDUCTIONS
AGAIN. ADMINISTRATORS ARE
ACTIVITIES ARE. ALSO ESTIMATE
AGENCIES- OR REDUCTIONS TO
THEIR COURT HEARING IMPROVEMENT
SYSTEM THAT'S FUNDED THROUGH
COMPANY AID- THE OTHER DAY WE
WERE NO IS. THERE IS FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN. SIXTY FOUR
PENDING THAT IS SCHEDULED TO.
IT HAS. TO BE BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO BE USED
FOR ADDITIONAL GENERAL
CHOCOLATE SAUCE. WELL THERE'S A
LOT THAT HAD NOT BEEN ALLOCATED
YET NOBODY HAS BEEN AWARDED
THOSE FUNDS. AND SO ONE OPTION
WOULD BE TO REDIRECT HAPPENING
RATHER THAN GOING OUT TWO SPOTS
TO BE USED. TO MINIMIZE THE
RATE REDUCTIONS THAT ARE. I'M
OLDER SPECIFIC COMMON ABOUT I
WOULD. TO DIE TALKING ABOUT THE
STOPPER. WHICH IS. MORE BODIES
OUT NOT ABOUT THE BIGGER
PROPOSALS BUT ABOUT THE CHOKER
OUR GROWTH ADJUSTMENT WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT'S IN STATUTE. SO
UNDER CURRENT LAW- THUS THE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM THE ALTERNATE
PAYMENT PROGRAM JOHN TUCKER
THEY ARE. ADJUSTED EVERY YEAR
BASED ON. DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION ON THE YOU'RE
YOU'RE CHANGING THE ZERO FOUR
POPULATION- RECENTLY BECAUSE
THOSE ARE THE FOCUS HAS BEEN
DECLINING THAT HAS BEEN A
NEGATIVE ADJUSTMENT- AND IN
THIS- IN THIS BUDGET THERE IS A
REDUCTION OF ABOUT SIXTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS WHEN YOU ADD
EVERYTHING UP. AND THERE'S A
TWO POINT 55% REDUCTION IN THE
SORT OF CORPORATION PROJECTED
SO THAT'S WHERE IT COMES FROM.
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION HERE
WOULD BE TO REJECT THAT
ADJUSTMENT- IT SO TO. NOT MAKE
THE REDUCTION AND THEN TO
CHANGE TRAINABLE CHANGE
LANGUAGE SO THAT- IN YEARS WHEN
THERE IS A NEGATIVE- A
REDUCTION IN POPULATION ARE
OBSERVABLE. PUBLISHING BUT
THERE'S NO JUST. IT WILL
PROBABLY GO TO THE OF EDUCATION
WELL IT'S STILL FOR FINANCE.
YOU COMMENT ON A COUPLE THE
POINTS MADE BY ELIO INCLUDING
THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE FOR
USE OF THE- FAR MORE IN THE
REDUCTIONS IN THE LAND OF
FIFTY- THAT HE WAS FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EXAMPLE
THAT WAS REFERENCED. CERTAINLY
JUST GO HOME DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO WE ARE CURRENTLY
ARE OUR STAFF ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH ELIA STAFF TO
ENSURE THAT. THE PRODUCTION
TAKE INTO THE ARM R. MAKES THE
MOST SENSE IS DONE AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE. AFTER ACTIVELY
WORKING. WITH ELIAN STAFF.
STILL PRODUCING. AT ACHIEVING
THE SAME AMOUNT OF SAVINGS BUT
THAT'S BEING DONE- AS EQUITABLY
AS POSSIBLE SO THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE VERY MUCH
OPEN TO AND WORKING ON RIGHT
NOW SH REGARDING THE FUNDING I
BELIEVE THE THIRTY NINE YOU
REFER TO AS THE PROP SIXTY FOUR
FUNDS. WE HAVE CONCERNS-
REGARDING WHETHER OR NOT GREAT
CHILD CARE RATES AND BACK FILL
WOULD BE- AN ALLOWABLE USE OF
PRODUCTS SIXTY FOUR FUNDS- THE
LANGUAGE IN PROP SIXTY FOUR
REQUIRED. THE FUNDS BE USED TO-
HELP. MITIGATE THE IMPACTS ON
OTHER CANNABIS SED ON USE- IN
TERMS OF OPENING UP NEW SLOTS-
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS
OR CHILDREN- TO BE REMOVED FROM
SITUATIONS WHERE- THEY MIGHT.
BEGIN AND DRUG ABUSE- WE THINK
THAT THAT IS ALLOWABLE IT GETS
A LITTLE BIT GRAYER WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT- GREAT AXLES FOR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS SO- WE
HAVE SOME CONCERNS AROUND THAT-
REGARDS TO THE- THE- CHILD A
CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL.
ADJUSTMENT FOR THIS CHANGE ZERO
TO FOUR LESION. FOR US THAT IS
A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS THAT WE
MAKE IT THE STATUTORY
ADJUSTMENT THAT WE MAKE- AND AS
MR CABRAL NOTED IT HAS BEEN.
MORE NEGATIVE IN RECENT YEARS
AND REFLECTION OF DECLINING
BIRTHRATE. THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE DON'T HAVE A FORMAL POSITION
ON THAT AT THIS POINT HOW WE
WOULD THAT THAT WOULD CREATE A
REDUCTION IN THE AMOUNT OF PROP
NINETY EIGHT AND NINE NINETY
EIGHT RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR
OTHER- PRIORITIES. IN THE
OVERALL LARGER BUDGET PICTURE.
OKAY OUR DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THANK YOU. I HOPE I
CAN HEAR YOU. BUT YOU'RE IN
POSITION. SORRY YOUR HONOR
OKAY- GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD
MORNING STILL MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE NOT- MORGAN DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT ON BEHALF OF
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION JENNY GARMENTS SO
IN TOTAL THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE PROPOSE IS THREE POINT
SIX BILLION UP FOR EARLY
LEARNING CARE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WHICH IS A THREE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE MILLION R.
8% DECREASE FROM JANUARY AND A
FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
MILLION OR 13% DECREASE FROM.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY. WE ARE
GREATLY CONCERNED BY THE CASTRO
SYSTEM ESPECIALLY THE THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION IN
SAVINGS IDENTIFIED WITH THAT
TEN PERCENT. AS RATE CUT FOR
SUBSIDIZED EARLY LEARNING CARE
PROVIDERS GIVEN THE INTEGRAL
ROLE WE KNOW QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING CARE LADIES. AND BEST
SUPPORTING A STRONG ECONOMY.
AND EARLY LEARNING CARE REALLY
PROVIDES THE ESSENTIAL
CHILDCARE TO WORKING FAMILIES
AND IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN.
ADDRESSING SCHOOL READY MASS
ESPECIALLY FOR ITS MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN. WELL WE
UNDERSTAND THE FISCAL SITUATION
THE STATE FINDS ITSELF AND WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT THE PROPOSED
RATE KIND. RUNS COUNTER TO THE
SHARED GOALS OF THE
SUPERINTENDENT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE. OF SUPPORTING
ACCESS TO CARE. AT SHORING UP
HER BY ALL TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE'S CHILD CARE SYSTEM
SURVIVES THIS CRISIS. OUR
PROGRAMS WERE ALREADY
STRUGGLING WITH RATES THAT
BARELY ALLOWED THEM TO STAY
AFLOAT. FOR EXAMPLE WITH THE
GAC GOVERNORS JANUARY BUDGET
RATE PROPOSAL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM THE RATES WERE FOUR
THOUSAND LESS PER YEAR. THAN
WHAT THEY STATE CURRENTLY PAYS
FOR A VOUCHER CENTER BASED.
PART RESPOND TO MARKET RATE
SURVEY MANY PROVIDERS HAVE
CHOSEN NOT TO APPLY FOR THE
PRESCHOOL EXPANSION FINDS. IT
NEEDS LOW RATES AND IN AN
INABILITY TO SECURE BOTH SPACE
AND PAY FOR THEIR TEACHERS
AFTER A GREAT. ADDITIONALLY DUE
TO CODE IN NINETEEN LIKE HOUSE
DIRECTOR ARE REDUCING CHILD
CARE CAPACITY SO IT'S ACTUALLY
COSTING MORE FAR PROGRAM STOP
RATE RIGHT NOW. WE'VE HEARD
THAT IT WILL COST THEM ABOUT.
ELEVEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
CLASSROOM IN CO BUT IT JUST NOT
COST. RELATED TO HEALTH AND
STATE SANITATION AS WELL AS THE
REDUCED GROUP SIZES AND
ADDITIONAL STAFFING FOR
CHILDREN. R. ONE RURAL COUNTY
THEY GAVE US THE COST OF A
MILLION THE 10% CUT. WOULD COST
THE SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND AND
CLEAN ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THOUSAND TO ABOUT A
MILLION DOLLARS. IN ADDITIONAL
FUNDS WOULD BE NEEDED THAT
WOULD BE LOST. THE PROPOSED 10%
CUT WILL PROVIDE CATASTROPHIC
TO THE FIELD AND MY RESULT IN
MANY PROVIDERS GOING OUT OF
BUSINESS. BASICALLY CRITICAL
IASI ATHLETE IN LAS CAPACITY
THAT IS ESSENTIAL FOR A STRONG
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AS
CALIFORNIANS HAD BACK TO WORK
AND WE NEED TO KICKSTART.
VERSUS RESPECT CONNIE. WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE PROPOSED
MECHANISM OF THE RATE CUTS WILL
CREATE INEQUITIES AND HELP
FAMILIES ACCESS CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS THREE BATTERS ACROSS
THE STATE. AN IMPACT FAMILIES
LIVING IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE STATE DIFFERENTLY CURRENTLY
ALL FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS TO AT
LEAST 75% OF THEIR PROVIDERS IN
THEIR AREA. HOWEVER AS A RESULT
OF THIS PROPOSED RATE CAT
FAMILIES IN SOME PART OF THE
STATE WOULD BE ONLY ABLE TO
ACCESS 42% OF THEIR LOCAL CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS WITH THE FASTER
RATE. ONE FAMILIES IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE WOULD BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE ACCESSING ARTS
ACTUALLY INCREASE TAXES. ARE A
100% OF LOCAL PROVIDERS WITH A
FASTER RATE. WE APPRECIATE THE
SENATE HOLDING THIS ISSUE OPEN
AT THIS TIME AND ARE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THE LA- TO
HELP IDENTIFY ALTERNATIVE COST
SAVINGS TO THE SYSTEM SO THAT
THESE DRAMATIC CUTS CAN BE
AVOIDED CALIFORNIA RECEIVED NO
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL ID. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION- OF. CALLING THE
QUESTION SIR LEVEL. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
JUST- I'D LIKE TO THINK THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS STAFF FOR WHAT
I THINK IT'S BEEN A REALLY
PHENOMENAL JOB DURING THIS VERY
DIFFICULT TIME- LEADERSHIP
REALLY SHINES THROUGH WHEN
YOU'RE FCED WITH A CRISIS AND
I THINK THAT OUR GOVERNOR HAS
LET US VERY WELL. HOWEVER I DO
HAVE SOME DEEP CONCERNS ABOUT
THE 10% CUT. TO HEALTH CARE
WORKERS. THERE IS A SAYING THAT
SAYS DON'T TELL ME WHAT YOUR
PRIORITIES ARE SHOW ME WHERE
YOU SPEND YOUR MONEY AND I'LL
TELL YOU WHERE YOUR PRIORITIES
LIE. BY CUTTING OUR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS BY 10% IT SHOWS THAT
WE'RE NOT PRIORITIZING WORKING
WOMEN CHILDREN. OR THEIR
FAMILIES AND AS I STATED ABOUT
AFTER SCHOOL CARE I WILL STATE
ABOUT OUR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS.
THERE'S NO WAY THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY CAN GET GOING WITHOUT
OUR OUR CHILD CARE FACILITIES
UP AND RUNNING. NO ONE GOES
INTO CHILD CARE BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO MAKE MONEY ARE THEY
WANT TO GET RICH THEY DO IT
BECAUSE THEY LOVE CHILDREN THEY
LOVE OUR CHILDREN WHILE WE'RE
AT WORK. THESE ARE SOME OF THE
LOWEST WAGE WORKERS WHO HAVE
DONE A PHENOMENAL JOB
THEMSELVES BUT TRYING TO STAY
OPEN AND SERVE OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS SO THAT THEY CAN
WORK AND TAKE CARE OF ALL OF US.
AND AS I SAID ALREADY THE
ECONOMY DOES NOT RE OPEN
WITHOUT THESE WOMEN WHO ARE
DOING THIS JOB. SO I ALSO
CANNOT SUPPORT A BUDGET THAT
SUPPORTS A 10% CUT TO CHILD
CARE SERVICES I KNOW WE CAN
FIND ANOTHER WAY I KNOW WE CAN
FIND A BETTER WAY AND I KNOW
THAT WE CAN DO BETTER BY OUR
WORKING WOMEN AND THEIR
FAMILIES. SO IS THE CHAIR OF
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
AS A MOM AND AS A GRANDMA WHO
HAS A DAUGHTER A CHILD A
GRANDDAUGHTER IN CHILD CARE I
CANNOT SUPPORT A BUDGET WITH
THAT CAT. HOWEVER THAT SAID I
HAVE A QUESTION NOT JUST A
STATEMENT I'M NOT SURE WHO THIS
IS FOR BUT THIS IS REGARDING
THE HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION. IF
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD HARMLESS
THE FUNDING MY QUESTION IS MOST
DAY CARES HAVE. THEIR NUMBER OF
STUDENTS OUR CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
REDUCED SO IF I HAD EIGHTEEN
STUDENTS AND I'VE ONLY HAD
THREE. WELL MY FUNDING B. FOR
THE EIGHTEEN STUDENTS I USED TO
HAVE. FOR THE THREE I HAVE NOW
I WOULD ADVOCATE FOR THE
EIGHTEEN BECAUSE WE WANT THAT
DAY CARE CENTER TO STAY OPEN
AND GET BACK TO THOSE EIGHTEEN
STUDENTS. OKAY OKAY I'M BEING
TOLD THAT MIGHT BE A QUESTION
FOR THE NEXT ITEM SO I'LL LIST
HOLD A QUESTION OVER THANK YOU
MR CHAIR. CALGARY FOR THE
QUESTIONS IN A ROW. YOU'RE GOOD.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TEN FEDERAL CARES ACT
CHILD CARE FUNDING. THE FINANCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JESSICA HOLMES
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AS
ALLUDED TO PREVIOUSLY THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES A PROPOSAL TO
ALLOCATE THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL KERR SACKED
UNDOING ON THROUGH THE CHILD
CARE DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT.
FOR CHILD CARE- SPECIFICALLY
OUR PROPOSAL INCLUDES A HUNDRED
AND FORTY FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION- TO REIMBURSE THE STATE
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY CO
THAT NINETEEN REAL EXPENSES. ON
THESE INCLUDED FIFTY MILLION
PROVIDED FOR TEMPORARY VOUCHERS
FOR EMERGENCY WORKERS FIFTY
MILLION PROVIDED. FOR CLEANING
SUPPLIES AND SANITATION ON FOR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS ANOTHER
FORTY FOUR POINT THREE MILLION
FOR A VARIETY OF COSTS
INCLUDING HOLDING HARMLESS
VOUCHER BASED PROVIDERS FOR
THIRTY ADDITIONAL DAYS. AND
DURING CLOSURE AND- RESCINDING
FAMILIES TEENS FOR THE REST OF.
I'M SORRY FOR A PERIOD OF SIXTY
DAYS. WE ARE PROPOSING- AN
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR ICREASE
TO FURTHER RECENTLY USED IN THE
REMAINDER OF THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY FISCAL YEAR
SEVENTY THREE MILLION TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
FRACTURE. DECREASED NUMBER OF
DOCTORS AVAILABLE TO FAMILIES-
SPECIFICALLY THOSE WHO HAVE OUR
ADDRESS CHILDREN AND OUR
EMERGENCY WORKERS AND HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION PER
STIPENDS FOR CHILDCARE AND
PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS I'M
SPECIFICALLY TO HELP THEM
ADDRESS COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH.
I'M CO THAT NINETEEN- AS WELL
AS ADDITIONAL ATTENTION
REDUCTIONS I'M RELATED TO RATE
DECREASES OR- REDUCTIONS THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN ABLE TO STIR.
I THINK CRITICIZED. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE. WELL JUST TO CLEAR UP THE
ONE ISSUE I GUESS YOUR LAST
STATEMENT THAN WITH ADDRESS THE
QUESTION OF SENATOR LEYVA
HAVING TO DO WITH. REDUCTIONS
IN NUMBERS OF PARTICIPANTS IN
THE IMPACT ON. FINANCIAL
VIABILITY OF SOME OF THESE
CHILDCARE FACILITIES I BELIEVE
AND I DON'T WANT TO I DON'T
WANT TO MISS CHARACTERIZED- THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION- HOWEVER I
BELIEVE THAT AND SENATOR LEYVA
IS REFERRING TO HOLDING- TITLE
FIVE PROVIDERS HARMLESS FOR
CHANGES IN GROUP SIZE
REQUIREMENTS WHICH IS A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING- HOWEVER. OURS ARE
MORE ONE TIME IN NATURE I
BELIEVE SINCERELY THAT WAS
REFERRING TO SOMETHING THAT'S A
LITTLE MORE ON CALLING. MAYBE
YOU COULD BE MORE SPECIFIC ON
THE ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR STIPENDS FOR
CHILDCARE. THIS IS THIS BECAUSE
YOU DID IS THIS MONEY BEING
PROVIDED BECAUSE OF REDUCED
SIZE OF PROGRAMS. THE STIPENDS
WOULD BE PROVIDED- TO REFLECT A
VARIETY OF ADDITIONAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PROVIDING CARE
DURING THE NINETEEN. SO THIS
COULD BE THE ONGOING COSTS OF
CLEANING AND SANITIZING- THE
END THE INCREASED REQUIREMENTS-
FOR. SMALLER GROUP SIZES- AND A
VARIETY OF OTHER CHANGES THAT
PROVIDERS ARE HAVING TO MAKE IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
CARE DURING THE ACADEMIC. OKAY
WHEN WE GO AHEAD LET'S CENTER
LEVELS KERR I ASSUME IT'S A
FOLLOW UP QUICKLY AS WE MOVE ON
THANK YOU MR CHAIR SO- AND YOU
ARE CORRECT MY QUESTION IS
ABOUT THE TITLE FIVE PROVIDERS
IT WHEN I SEE SERVING THE
MAXIMUM NUMBER OF CHILDREN. MY
CONCERN IS JUST LIKE I SAID IF
YOU HAD EIGHTEEN BUT ONLY HAD
THREE NOW BUT YOU CAN STILL YOU
CAN STILL GET BACK TO EIGHTEEN
START CHILDREN WHO WOULD WANT
THAT TO HAPPEN. I MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE STIPEND
MONEY THE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION- DOESN'T NECESSARY
THEY'RE KIND OF TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS SO I'M JUST LOOKING FOR
SOME GUIDANCE ON HOW DO WE KEEP
THAT CHILD CARE CENTER OPEN WHO
CLEARLY ISN'T MAKING ANY MONEY
BUT HAS STAYED OPEN. AND I
DON'T KNOW IF I MAKING MYSELF
CLEAR BUT CAN BE IF IT'S A HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION CAN THEY
STILL BE REIMBURSED THE HEIGHT
THERE THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
CHILDREN THEY HAD I GUESS MAYBE
THAT'S WHAT I'M ASKING. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND- I DON'T AND I
DON'T NECESSARILY WANT TO
MISSPEAK. ABOUT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION HOWEVER I WOULD
NOTE THAT CURRENTLY TITLE FIVE
PROVIDERS. AS A CONDITION OF
THEIR CONTRACT HAVE BEEN HELD
LARGELY HOLD HARMLESS- DURING
THE CURRENT VIRUS PANDEMIC- AND
I. I ASSUME THAT THIS THIS HOLD
HARMLESS WOULD WOULD ACT
SIMILARLY AND I WOULD TURN.
OVER THE QUESTION TO YOU. I'M
CERTAIN OF A WORKING AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
MAYBE DESCRIBE A LITTLE BIT
BETTER WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE
WHOLE TOTAL FIVE. PROVIDERS
HARMLESS AND THROUGH THEIR
CONTRACTS. THAT WOULD BE GREAT
BECAUSE MAYBE I'M NOT
COMPLETELY UNDERSTANDING IT
EITHER. OKAY WELL BEFORE WE DO
THAT LET'S GO TO THE L. L. AND
THEN MOVED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HELLO. MR SAW ALL
THIS CRAP TO STOP
RECOMMENDATION I CAN. TALK A
LITTLE ABOUT THE EARLIER WITH
CONCERNS BUT I THINK. THE
DEPARTMENT MIGHT HAVE SOME MORE
SPECIFICS ON ON ALL THE
PROGRAMS WORK WITH BUT- THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE
TO ADOPT. THE MAIN REASON
PROPOSALS TO PROVIDE THE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION FOR. COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CURRENT
YEAR. AND THEN AT SEVENTY THREE
MILLION TO INCREASE OUR
TEMPORARY EMERGENCY VOUCHERS
FOR AT RISK CHILDREN OR
CHILDREN ESSENTIAL WORKERS. AND
THEN ALSO DEVELOPED VERY NINE
DOLLARS TO EXTEND FAMILIES HE
REVERSED UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH.
I'M FROM THERE IN TERMS OF
AREAS WHERE MOST AFRICAN NATION
WOULD WOULD VARY FROM THE MAIN
REVISION. ONE IS THAT THERE
WOULD BE AN EXTENSION FOR THE
EXPENDITURE OF FIFTY MILLION
RESPECTIVELY PROVIDED IN THE
CURRENT- THAT'S PART OF THE TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR. NINETY
TWENTY COSTS FIFTY MILLION WAS
FOR EMERGENCY ROGERS- THIS
WOULD. ALLOW THAT FUNDING TO
CONTINUE TO BE USED- TO ALLOW
EXTENDED TO. IT WHICH WOULD BE
BIG NEWS BROKE THREE TWENTY
ONE- THE NEXT THING THAT THE
RECOMMENDATION WOULD DO WOULD
BE TO ADOPT A DISCERNIBLE
LANGUAGE TO PROVIDE A HOLD
HARMLESS THE TITLE. PROVIDERS
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FISCAL YEAR I THAT. YOU KNOW IS
THE ARE. AVAILABLE TO SCAN THE
MAP NUMBER OF CHILDREN UNDER
WHATEVER THE RISKS ARE. BECAUSE
OUR TIME. THE CLOTHES YOU YOU
ARE. STRAP I'M- SORRY THAT I
BELIEVE THAT THE OLDER THIS IS
BASED ON NINE TWENTY CONTRACT
AMOUNTS MEANS. IF YOU'RE A YOUR
CONTRACTOR MAY TWENTY WERE
SERVING NEEDS YOU A COUNTRY
FREE T. AND WHAT THE TIME WE
WITH BEFORE THANK YOU THAT VERY.
A MAN IN THE FINAL OF THE STUFF
WOULD BE- IS A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR STATINS
ARE STILL BE THE SAME AMOUNT
EXCEPT THE STATE AND WOULD BE
PROVIDED IT WOULD NOT BE
PROVIDED FOR THE DIRECT
CONTRIBUTORS AND THEY ARE
RECEIVING A HOLD HARMLESS AND
INSTEAD IT WOULD GO TOWARD.
TEACHER I'M OTHER LICENSED
PROVIDERS BUT ALSO- WHAT'S
DIFFERENT FROM THE MAY REVISION
AS IT WOULD ALSO BE A FOUR
ACCOUNT WORKS IS WHEN PROVIDERS.
AND FOR MY SCRIPT WRITERS.
PERFECT THE PURPOSE. ANY
COMMENT. YES PLEASE ASK THEIR
NUMBER MORGAN HERE AT DEFEAT
SUPERINTENDENT ON BEHALF OF
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TO MEET THEIR MATCH
RACE WE REALLY WANT TO THANK
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
PARTNERSHIP SO FAR AND HELPING
US TO ADDRESS THE CODE NINETEEN
ISSUES AS THEY ARISE. WE
APPRECIATE THE IDENTIFICATION
OF RESOURCES THROUGHOUT THIS
EMERGENCY THAT ALLOWED US TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY CHILDCARE
CENTER WORKERS AND VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS SUPPLIES TO
PROVIDERS AND PRODUCTION FOR
PROVIDER PAYMENT WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF
EIGHT MILLION AND THEN BE
REVISED AWAY FAMILY FEES
THROUGH JUNE THIRTIETH. TWENTY
TWENTY AS WE KNOW OUR FAMILIES
ARE STRUGGLING. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE SENATE'S. THAT
MORE RESOURCES ARE NECESSARY
INTO THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FISCAL YEAR TO STABILIZE
CALIFORNIA'S EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE PROVIDERS. AND ARE HAPPY
TO SHARE ANY SPECIFIC DETAILS
THAT MAY BE HELPFUL WITH. SH AS
I SAID EARLIER WE RECOGNIZE
THAT ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS THAT
ARE OPEN DURING KOBE NINETY.
HAVING CREASED COST AND
FINANCIAL BURDEN REALLY OR WITH
EQUITY WE WOULD WANT THE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
PROVIDER SOLVENCY FINDS TO BE
AVAILABLE TO ANY OF OUR
SUBSIDIZES INSTEAD OF AN OPEN.
WHETHER THEY ARE PROVIDING
EARLY LEARNING CARE ST DIRECT
CONTRACTS OR THROUGHOUT YOUR-
IN RESPONSE TO SENATOR LEVI'S
HOLD HER LAST WHAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM OUR PROGRAM IS THAT. IN
THE BEGINNING LAST FAMILIES
WERE COMING TAKE CARE AND AS
SOME OF THE FAMILIES WERE
SHELTERING IN PLACE AND MAKING
OTHER. CERTAIN SITUATIONS WORK
RIGHT NOW MORE AND MORE OF THEM
ARE COMING BACK TO CARE
INCOMING AND WHAT WE'VE DONE
CURRENTLY S. HOLDER PROVIDE OUR
PROVIDERS ARE LESS. REGARDLESS
OF THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
ATTENDING AS LONG AS THEY WERE
INVOICE SCENE ASKED FOR THE
CURRENT COST KEEPING OUR STAFF
EMPLOYED AND ENGAGE WITH THEM
OR HELP HER LAST. MOVIE FORWARD
IT WOULD BE SOMETHING SIMILAR
AND ADDRESSING THE FACT THAT WE
WOULD WANT OUR STAFF STILL
RETAINS EVEN IF A GROUP SIZE OR
RATIO HAD TO DECREASE SHE SAID
THEY WERE LESS CHILDREN ENGAGE
THERE WOULD STILL BE THE SAME
NUMBER STAFF THAT WOULD BE
NEEDED. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
OTHER ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS THE COLLEGE
QUESTIONS EARLIER. I JUST WANNA
SAY THANK YOU THAT WAS VERY
HELPFUL. THE MAROON THE
QUESTIONS. OKAY RIGHT NOW
CONCLUDES PART EIGHT OF OUR
GENDER IF YOU WILL GIVE US-
FIVE TO TEN MINUTES WE'RE GOING
TO SHIFT TO PART B. AND MOVE
THROUGH- THAT PORTION OF THE
AGENDA AND THEN MOVE INTO
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
WITH THE PARTY
OF THE AGENDA BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE A NUMBER ONE IN
EDUCATION THE ITEM IS SIXTY
EIGHT SEVENTY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE ISSUE IS
ISSUE NUMBER SEVENTY SIX.
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA APPORTIONMENT
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AND DEFERRALS.
DO WE HAVE. THE REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO ADDRESS ISSUE NUMBER SEVENTY
SIX. GOOD TO HEAR GOOD MORNING
STILL. GOOD MORNING LAST
AFTERNOON- SENATOR RAWSON AND
MEMBERS MICHELLE NEW IN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I'LL
FIRST PROVIDE A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF THE PROPOSALS
INCLUDED AT THE MERRY VISION
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION. SO
DESPITE THE HIGH HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF THE COVE IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. SAID
MINISTRATION REMAINS COMMITTED
TO MAXIMIZING ACCESS AND EQUITY.
THE ADMINISTRATION ASKED THAT
THE STATE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES DO ALL THEY CAN TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA AND ITS
STUDENTS DURING THIS DIFFICULT
TIME AND EXPECT THAT THESE
REDUCTIONS IN FUNDING WILL NOT
HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT.
ON LOW INCOME UNDERREPRESENTED
OR DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS. TO
ENSURE THAT HIGHER EDUCATION
REMAINS AN OPTION FOR STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ECONOMIC
STATUS. THEY MINISTRATION HAS
PROPOSED TO ENSURE THAT CAL
GRANT AND MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS REMAIN
UNTOUCHED FOR ALL STUDENTS WHO
ARE CURRENTLY ATTENDING OR
PLANNING TO ATTEND. ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S INSTITUTIONS OF
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION.
ADDITIONALLY THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD LIKE TO SEE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES CONTINUE TO WORK
TOWARDS. PROVIDING FULLY ONLINE
EDUCATION OPTIONS WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON ENSURING THAT
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENT GROUPS
ARE ABLE TO ENROLL AND SUCCEED
IN THESE PROGRAMS IMPORTANT
UNFORTUNATELY AND IN RESPONSE
TO. THE CLEANING ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES THE STATE HAS
TAKEN SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO
ENSURE A BALANCED BUDGET
INCLUDING WITHDRAWING MOST OF
THE SPENDING PROPOSAL.
PRESENTED AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND MAKING SIGNIFICANT
FURTHER REDUCTIONS. FOR SOME OF
THESE PROPOSALS WE HAVE
INCLUDED LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
RESTORE THE PROPOSED REDUCTIONS
IF SUFFICIENT NEW FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR PROVIDED TO THE
STATE. AND WITHOUT- I'LL SPEAK
TO THE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA APPORTIONMENT AND
DEFERRALS. SO AS YOU KNOW DUE
TO A SIGNIFICANT. DROP IN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A BALANCE OF
REDUCTIONS IN DEFERRALS- IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BUDGET MOST
NOTABLY A REDUCTION TO THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA TEN PERCENT. WHICH WHEN
COMBINED WITH THE FOREGONE COLA
THAT WAS WITHDRAWN FROM THE MIX
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
TOTALED ROUGHLY SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS. IN
ADDITION THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSED A TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR AN APPORTIONMENT
DEFERRAL OF THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY POINT ONE MILLION FROM
CURRENT YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY. YOUR BUDGET HERE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND A
DEFERRAL OF SIX HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO POINT ONE MILLION
FROM BUDGET YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR. TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. WE WOULD NOTE THAT CURRENT
LAW HAS A HARDSHIP EXEMPTION
FOR PERSIMMONS DEFERRALS AND
MARY VISION PROPOSES A
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT. FOR THAT
HARDSHIP EXEMPTION TO BE MADE
APPLICABLE TO THE PROPOSED
DEFERRALS AND TRAILER BILL. IN
ADDITION TO YOU- TO THE
DEFERRAL TRAILER BILL THE MAYOR
REVISION PROPOSES. ADDITIONAL
TRAILER BILL THAT MAKES CHANGES
TO THE STUDENT CENTER POINT
FUNDING FORMULA INCLUDING
CLARIFYING. TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY RATES PURSUANT TO THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT.
EXPANDING THE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION FOR THE FUNDING
FORMULA BY TWO YEARS. TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR.
PROVIDING FLEXIBILITY FOR
DISTRICT SEES PRIOR YEAR DATA
WHEN CALCULATING THEIR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CUNNING FORMULA
ALLOCATION. AND REQUIRING THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO MAKE A
PORTION MEANT REDUCTIONS FOR
NON BASIC AID DISTRICTS AND
CATEGORICAL REDUCTIONS FOR
BASIC IN DISTRICTS. AND WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION HELLO. THANK YOU
CHARAKTER HOLSTEIN HOUSE AND
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. SO THERE ARE SEVERAL
PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU IN THIS
AGENDA ITEM ARE YOU JUST HEARD
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ABOUT THE APARTMENTS A PORTION
OF IT WHICH IS WITHDRAWN. THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL ON
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT.
FUNDING AS WELL AS ENROLLMENT
GROWS MOST NOTABLE REALLY AND-
MAY REVISION IS A FACE CUTS TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE APPORTIONMENT
OF FIVE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS- WHICH IS WHICH
REPRESENTS AN EIGHT PERCENT.
DISCOUNT TO COLLEGE'S CORE
OPERATING FUNDS. IF THE
COMMITTEE WANTED TO EXPLORE
ALTERNATIVES. TO MAKING JUSTIN
UNALLOCATED BASE CUT WE HAVE
SHARED SOME OPTIONS WITH STAFF
AND THESE ALTERNATIVE
REDUCTIONS REALLY SEEK TO
TARGET REDUCTIONS TO NON CORE
LOWER PRIORITY PROGRAMS WITHIN
THE COLLEGES. IN ADDITION TO
THE APPORTIONMENT CUTS ON THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSES A
DEFERRAL- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
MENTIONED SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY
TWO MILLION DOLLAR A DEFERRAL
AND PAYMENTS TO DISTRICTS TO
FUTURE YEARS. THAT'S PART OF
THE GOVERNOR'S CITATION ALL-
SOLUTION. NOW AS OF JUST A FEW
DAYS AGO YOU SHOULD KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD NOT YET
SPECIFIED WHEN COLLEGES WOULD
RECEIVE THIS DEFERRED- PAYMENT-
AND SO- I MEAN COLLEGES RECEIVE
PAYMENTS A MONTH OR TWO OR
LATER. SAY IN JULY OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. THE
PROPOSED DEFERRALS LIKELY
WOULDN'T WOULD BE MANAGEABLE BY
MOST IF NOT ALL DISTRICTS AND
AS YOU JUST HEARD THE MAY
REVISION DOES INCLUDE SOME
HARDSHIP LANGUAGE. FOR FOUR
DISTRICTS. SO DEFERRALS A CHIEF
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND SAVINGS-
WITHOUT GENERALLY AFFECTING THE
AMOUNT OF PROGRAM THAT THE
COLLEGES HAD TO- TO SPEND ON
SO- DEFERRALS ARE- A VIABLE
BUDGET OPTION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER OUT WE
DO NOTES AGAIN THOUGH THE
LEGISLATURE STILL NEEDS DETAIL
ON WHEN THESE PAYMENT.
DEFERRALS WOULD ACTUALLY BE
MADE DISTRICTS BECAUSE THAT
THAT'S PRETTY IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO BETTER IDEA HOW
MANAGEABLE JACKLEY THESE- THIS
PROPOSAL IS FOR WORK FOR THESE
COLLEGES. THANK YOU. JUST TO
CLARIFY- IN TERMS OF YOUR
APPEAL TURNER'S. THOSE ARE THE
ALTERNATIVES HAVING TO DO WITH
THE- COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAM
THE INTERCOLLEGIATE ATHLETICS
CALIBRATE. BUT ON AN ONGOING
BASIS AND THEN SOME ONE TIME
SOLUTIONS PROPOSED AGAIN
CALIBRATE SOME LOTTERY FUND-
RESTRICTION ELIMINATIONS AND
OTHER ITEMS. THAT'S CORRECT SO
IT'S A MIX OF I'M GOING. OF THE
DENTAL SOLUTIONS AS WELL AS
SOME ONE TIME ACTIONS THAT
COULD HELP THE COLLEGES GET
THROUGH THE BUDGET YEAR AND
HAVE MORE TIME TO PLAN FOR THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. THAT PROCEDURE
COMMENTS- I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. MORNING
AFTERNOON BY NOW. SENATOR ROSS
LISETTE NEVER AT MY STUDENTS
FOR COLLEGE FINANCE AND
FACILITIES PLANNING WITH THE
COVERAGE MANY COLLEGES. ARE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A VERY
TOUGH BUDGET FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER BUT
BEFORE WE PROVIDER OVERALL
REACTIONS WANTED TO JUST SHARE.
THE IMPORTANT ROLE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ME COLLEGES THAT
PLAYED ON AND THE COMPANY
NINETEEN RESPONSE- AND THEN
REMIND THE STATE ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE THAT WE CAN ALSO
PLAY IN THE RECOVERY- FOR
REEMPLOYMENT OF CALIFORNIANS
AND THE OVERALL ECONOMY. I'M AS
YOU KNOW TEN YEARS AGO THANKS
TO THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
TRANSLATED DIRECTLY INTO IT IT
TO OUR WORK FORCE AND FURTHER
WHITE IN CALIFORNIA. DEGREE GAP
THE GREATEST RISKS THAT WE NOW
SEE IN THIS PROPOSED BUDGET ARE
THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS TOWARDS
PROGRESS TOWARDS EQUITABLE
SUCCESS AND THE EFFORT THAT
WE'VE MADE AROUND THAT IT.
WEIGHS UP COMPLETION. AND I
DON'T NEED TO REMINDALL OF YOU
THAT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES ARE
THE LOWEST FUNDED SYSTEM OF
EDUCATION YET THE MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL FOR EQUITY
ACCESS. WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
WITH THESE PROPOSED. CUTS WE
WILL SOON REACH A BREAKING
POINT. THE PROPOSED CUTS
PROVIDE A ONE FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR DIFFERENCE COMPARED TO
WHAT WE SAW IN THE JANUARY
PROPOSAL THAT FOR COMPARISON IT
IS EQUIVALENT TO THE SAME LEVEL
OF CUTS WE SAW IN THE FIVE
YEARS OF THE GREAT RECESSION
ALL OCCURRING IN ONE YEAR THIS
REDUCES OUR CORPORATE STUDENT
LOAN FUNDING LEVEL BY 13%
COMPARED. WE COMPARE ALL OF THE
CUTS AND THEN IT ALSO RAISE
THEIR WORK FORCE PROGRAMS OUR
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS AS YOU MAY
KNOW- PROVIDE TRAINING AND
EDUCATION FOR TWENTY THOUSAND
FIRST RESPONDERS ANNUALLY- AND
THOSE WILL BE ESSENTIAL IF WE
ARE TO RECOVER. AND CONTINUE
SERVING CALIFORNIANS IN THIS
TIME. PHYSICALLY TO THE
PROPOSALS IN THE MAY REVISION
WE DO THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME
ELEMENTS THAT ARE WORTH NOTING
IN THEIR POSITIVES. WE THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR AGAIN THE
EMPHASIS ON COMPETENCY BASED
EDUCATION AND EXPEDITED EFFORTS
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF SHORT
TERM CAREER EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
WE APPRECIATE THE FLEXIBILITY
ARE RELATED TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN COSTS FROM THE 50%
MARK- AND NOT- INSURING THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO FURTHER PENALIZED
LIMITED FRIEND FUNDS FROM
COLLEGES. WE SUPPORT- OUR
EFFORTS TO MINIMIZE THE
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS FOR
COLLEGES SO THAT AGAIN WE ARE
NOT SENDING LIMITED RESOURCES
AND FURTHER INCHING DOLLARS ON
CAMPUSES THAT ARE NEEDED TO
OFFER PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
OCCULTATIONS STAFF. LORD AGAIN
THE BUY DOWN OF PENSION
LIABILITY EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION
RATES. WE APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF THE SYSTEM
SUPPORT. SYSTEM SUPPORT
PROPOSAL PRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR GREATER
ALIGNMENT BETTER COORDINATION
AND ELIMINATION OF SILOS ACROSS
A STATUTORILY REQUIRED SET
ASIDES AND IT ALSO PROVIDES
GREATER TRANSPARENCY- AND
EFFORTS THAT WILL ALLOW. YOU
IDENTIFIED COST SAVINGS THESE
COST SAVINGS WILL ALLOW US TO
BETTER SERVE OTHER UNMET NEEDS-
AND AGAIN PROVIDES THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE NEED
ESPECIALLY- AS WE ENTER THIS
RECESSION. LASTLY I WANT TO
MENTION THAT WE DO VALUE THAT
ARE THERE ARE CONTINUING-
PROPOSALS INCLUDED FOR CAPITAL
OUTLAY THESE PROGRAMS WILL KEEP
CALIFORNIANS WORKING. SOME OF
THE DEEP CONCERNING ELEMENTS OF
THE BAND I REVISION ARE ONES-
AS I MENTIONED REDUCTIONS TO
APPORTIONMENT THAT REDUCE
OVERALL- PER STUDENT FUNDING BY
13% ALL CUTS COMBINED. WITH A
STRONG WORK FORCE DOWN TO A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FROM
TWO HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT AGAIN
AT A POINT WHERE WE NEED MORE
EMPLOYMENT EFFORTS NOT LAST.
AND THEN LASTLY- CONCERNED
ABOUT CATEGORICAL THAT HAD BEEN
SUPPORTING MANY OF THE STUDENTS
THAT WERE LEFT OUT OF THE
CAROUSEL- AS YOU KNOW ARE THE
CARERS ACT ARBITRARILY LEFT OUT
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS
BASED ON THE DEFINITIONS
UTILIZED BY THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. EQUITY
AND ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM HAS
BEEN THERE TO SUPPORT THOSE
PROGRAMS IN THOSE STUDENTS THAT
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THOSE
DEFINITIONS. SO WE ARE. INSTEAD
CONSIDER A COUPLE OF OPTIONS
THAT YOU CONSIDER INVESTING
MORE IN STRONG WORK FORCE NOT
LESS AGAIN. WILL BE SENT WHEN
CALIFORNIANS BACK TO WORK RE
ENGAGING THEM- AND MEETING
THEIR REEMPLOYMENT NEEDS. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT COVER NINETEEN
HAS EXPOSED ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
DISPARITIES SO WE ASK THAT YOU
FURTHER INVESTING COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THOUGH ARE YOU MAY%
NEED TO TURN TO I'M COMIN OR
UNCONVENTIONAL OPTIONS SUCH AS
INVESTING THREE CALLS FROM NINE
NINETY EIGHT SOURCES WE DO
THINK THAT IT'S THE RIGHT THING
TO DO FOR CALIFORNIA IF WE
DON'T WANT TO FURTHER WIDEN.
THE DEGREE GAP. WE ASKED FOR
GREATER FLEXIBILITY IN USE OF
FUNDS OPTIONS ARE I THANK THE
TEAM SUCH. AS BY THE WAY UP THE
LOTTERY FUNDS IN DEATH. ON HOW
WE CAN YOU KNOW THE RESTRICT
DOLLAR. AND REVISITING PRO LIKE.
TO ENSURE THAT WE ALSO SERVE
STUDENTS SEEKING RE EMPLOYMENT
THROUGH THAT CATEGORICAL
PROGRAM. SO I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE SEVERAL OTHER QUESTIONS
AND I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS THOSE
LATER BUT THESE ARE SOME OF THE
INITIAL POINT AND OBSERVATIONS
FROM THE MAY REVISION. THANK
YOU SENATOR ROCK MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR CALLING
US QUESTIONS. SEVERAL MAYBE FOR
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM HI
HOW ARE YOUR INSTITUTION'S
POISE TO HANDLE THE DEFERRALS
ARE. THE PROPOSED. SO WHAT ARE
THE KEY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PROPOSALS- GIVEN THEY IF WE'RE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THOSE RESOURCES
SHORTLY AFTER THE START OF THE
FISCAL YEAR WE DO BELIEVE THAT
SEVERAL COLLEGES WILL BE ABLE
TO MANAGE THEM- WE FORWARD THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE RESOURCES
DIFFERED INTO TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO ALL WE KNOW THAT COLLEGES
WILL HAVE VARYING DEGREES- THE
ABILITY TO HANDLE THOSE I.
DEPENDING ON THEIR THEIR
PHYSICAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
LOCALLY- HOWEVER WE DO NOTE
THAT IT IS- A BETTER APPROACH
TO PROVIDE REFERRALS AND
OVERALL. LONG TERM AND
PERMANENT CUTS TO OF COURSE- AT
DEFERRALS AT A MINIMUM COME
BACK TO COLLEGES THAT WE CAN
REINVEST THOSE RESOURCES AND AT
ANOTHER TIME BUT WE ARE AGAIN
CONCERNED- WITH SOME DISTRICTS
IN ABILITY TO MANAGE- FOR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY. WHEN WE
FIRST THROUGH. TECHNOLOGY
INSTRUCTION OCCUR TO THEM
HOWVER THE DISTRICTS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS HOW
THEY'VE BEEN PERFORMING IN THAT
REGARD ARE THERE ANY
RESTRICTIONS STATUTORILY- THAT
ARE IN PLACE THAT WE NEED TO
DEAL WITH IN ORDER TO ALLOW.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM TO
EQUIP ITSELF AND THE STUDENTS
TO CONTINUE TO LEARN ONLINE IF
THAT BECOMES A- NECESSARY
CONTINUES TO BE NECESSARY OR
APPROPRIATE IN THE FUTURE.
SENATOR ROTH'S COUPLE OF THE
POINTS HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED
ACTUALLY IN THE BUDGET- CURRENT
STATUE THE 50% LAW REQUIRES
THAT- 50% OF ALL RESOURCES
RECEIVE GENERAL FUND RESOURCES
RECEIVED BY A COLLEGE THE
EXPANDED ON- SALARIES- AND
BENEFITS FOR TENURE TRACK.
MICHAEL T. THAT MEANS THAT-
COLLEGES HAVE HAD TO EXPEND A
LOT MORE- ON WHAT IS CONSIDERED
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE 50%
LIVE THIS YER AS WE
TRANSITIONED INTO ONLINE
LEARNING MODALITIES AND
DISTANCE. EDUCATION DELIVERY
THE EXEMPTION- TO CURB SHEET
THE ABILITY TO EXACT SOME OF
THOSE COSTS RELATED TO THAT
QUICK TRANSITION FROM THE 50%
LEVEL PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY
OTHERWISE WITHOUT THAT
FLEXIBILITY WOULD HAVE TO
FURTHER PENALIZED- COLLEGES BY
REDUCING THEIR APPORTIONMENT.
SO THAT'S FLEXIBILITY THAT- IS
VALUABLE AT THIS TIME AN
EXPANDED X. AT AN EXPECTED
EXPENSES. THE OTHER AREA THAT
WE'VE HIGHLIGHTED IS AROUND A
LOTTERY FUNDS THERE IS AN
ANTIQUATED DEFINITION IN THE
LOTTERY FUNDS ON WHAT IS
CONSIDERED- INSTRUCTIONAL
EQUIPMENT. INCLUDES DEFINITIONS
SUCH AS AUDIO TAPES AND DISKS-
WITH THOSE EXPENSES THAT ARE
NOT RELATED TO THE CURRENT
DELIVERY- OF TECHNOLOGY IN THE
USE. THE OTHER IS AROUND-
PROMISE PROGRAMS THIS IS STILL
INCLUDES DEFINITIONS FOR FULL
TIME STUDENTS AND SO- GREATER
FLEXIBILITY AND- UTILIZING SOME
OF THOSE FUNDS TO SERVE A
BROADER ARRAY OF STUDENTS THAT
MAY HAVE NEEDS CAN ALSO BE
VALUABLE. FOR COLLEGES IN
SERVING THESE POPULATIONS. WHAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
RESPONSE OR ANY. AND SO I HAVE
TO SAY I'M- I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
ALL OF THE CUTS WERE HAVING TO
MAKE A- THIS YEAR OR PROPOSE TO
MAKE THIS YEAR ACROSS THE BOARD
K. TWO FOURTEEN HIGHER ED. IN
THE AREA OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
I'VE COLLEGES I'M CONCERNED
THAT. OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
EXPECT TO BE THE ACCESS POINT
IN MANY CASES TO OUR FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS. AND OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES FRANKLY THE SOLUTION
TO- FOR MANY ANYWAY TO THE EVER
CHANGING WORKPLACE CERTAINLY
THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN THE
PAST. IN THIS TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY AND CERTAINLY. THE
WORKPLACE THAT WE'RE PROBABLY
GOING TO. EXPECT TO SEE POST
CODE SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO. TO DEAL
WITH THIS BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS NO OTHER
QUESTIONS. THIS IS A HOLD OPEN
ITEM LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
SEVENTY SEVEN. BECAUSE STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM ADULT
EDUCATION AND APPRENTICESHIPS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HI
MICHELLE NEWMAN AGAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AS NOTED
IN THE GENDER AND THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES A REDUCTION
TO THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM OF A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS- AT ROUGHLY
10% REDUCTION FOR THE ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAM- AS WELL AS
ANY- 15% REDUCTION IN
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTEEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
PROPOSED CALVARY. COMMUNITY
SYSTEM SUPPORT PROGRAM WHICH
WAS PROPOSED DURING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- AND
CONTINUES TO BE PROPOSED AT THE
MAY REVISION- WITH THIS
ADDITIONAL REDUCTION. BUT
WITHOUT HAVING TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. WELL
LET ME HAVE THIS GO A LITTLE
BIT OUT OF SEQUENCE HERE AND
JUST I WAS LOOKING AT. AT OUR
AGENDA AND THE INFORMATION THAT
WE WERE PROVIDED- OVER THE
WEEKEND AND- OUR AGENDA. HAS A
NOTED. IN ADDITION TO THE
TRIGGER REDUCTION THE MAY
REVISION ALSO PROPOSES TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO REQUIRE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS. TO
EXPEDITE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
TARGETED CREDIT OR NON CREDIT
SHORT TERM WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT FOCUS ON. ONE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND RESULT IN
JOB PLACEMENT TO RE SKILLING
AND UP SKILLING. AND THREE HAVE
AT LEAST ONE PROVEN EMPLOYER
PARTNER DEMONSTRATE JOB
VACANCIES AND SUBMIT
VERIFICATION TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN MY-
MARGIN NOTES TO MYSELF THIS
ISN'T THIS THE CALIBRATE
MISSION. AND HOW DOES THAT ALL
RELATE. I GUESS FINANCE. WHEN.
WELL THAT WAS GOOD. THE FASTEST
EVER. YES CHRIS FERGUSON WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO-
THE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE THAT YOU
SEE IN THE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM IS RELATIVE TO AN
EXPECTATION THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED WHEN THE PROGRAM
WAS ESTABLISHED AND THAT IN.
THAT PROGRAM EXPECTED COLLEGES
TO BE ABLE TO CREATE A PROGRAM
WITHIN SIX MONTHS AND OFFERED
THE FOLLOWING SEMESTER SO
CREATED THIS SEMESTER SAY THE
FALL SEMESTER AND OFFERED THE
SPRING SEMESTER THE FLEXIBILITY
IN THE LANGUAGE THAT WE PUT
FORWARD IS FLEXIBILITY THAT
WOULD ALLOW COLLEGES CREATE
PROGRAM MUCH MORE EXPEDITIOUSLY
THAN THAT SIX MONTH POP FRAME.
WHAT ENABLED TO DO DO SOMETHING
THAT A LITTLE MORE FLEX THAN
THEY DO TODAY BUT ALSO IT'S
WITHIN THE ACT HOW. IN THE
STRUCTURE THEY COLLEGES HAVE
WERE IT'S HELD HAD A LOCAL
POINT TO START THOSE. AT
DIFFERENT POINTS DURING THE
TRADITIONAL YEAR I'M SO IT'S
NOT QUITE THE SAME. OKAY WELL I
APOLOGIZE FOR GOING OUT OF
SEQUENCE I JUST WANTED TO IT
WAS JUST. INTERESTING TO ME AND
I WANTED TO ASK THE QUESTION I
APOLOGIZE I APOLOGIZE TO MY
COLLEAGUES AND APPRECIATE THEIR
INDULGENCE. HELLO ISSUE SEVENTY
SEVEN. THIS NEWS. YOU THINKING
THAT THE LEGISLATIVE OFFICE. ON
THIS ISSUE EMAIL ADDED STATE
PRIME SUPPORT CRITIC QUESTION
BECAUSE A COLLEGES THROUGH
QUESTION. BUT IT ALSO
SUPPLEMENTAL FOR THESE COURSES
THROUGH THE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM IS INTENDED TO REFLECT
CTE COURSES COMMONLY HAVE
HIGHER INSTRUCTIONAL COSTS IT
IS SMALLER CLASS SIZES AND
SPECIALIZED EQUIPMENT NEEDS.
THERE ARE PREFERRED ALSO
PROVIDES FUNDING FOR REGIONAL
COORDINATION. PLANNING IN THE
COMING YEARS BEING IN FOR. CTE
COURSES BUT COLLEGES I. WORKERS
SOME OF WHOM HAD LOST JOBS.
TURNING TO SCHOOL ADDITIONAL
RISK AROUND. AND WE THINK THE
STRONG WORK FORCE PRO COULD
HELP. NEED THAT INCREASED IN.
WHAT IN MIND AS AN ALTERNATE TO
COVER MAYOR OF A PROPOS. YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT TO RE FUN FROM
OTHER. IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN. A
COMPARABLE LEVEL FUNDING FOR
THE WORK PROGRAM. THE CURRENT
MODEL. WE SHOULD BE LOCKED OF
SOUTH. WOULD BE HAPPY TO
DISCUSS THE FURTHER YOU HAVE
ANY. PARIS PROPOSE FOR IT ALL
THAT YOU. CONDITIONS IN AMERICA
SHIN. WE CAN THESE PROPOSALS
AREAS AND OF THIS FISCAL
CONSTRAINTS. THANK YOU I'LL BE
HAPPY TAKING. WE MAY HAVE SOME
A MINUTE I'LL TRY TO FOLLOW
DANCE. SO LET'S GO TO THE CAL
COMMUNITY. REPRESENTATIVES I
THINK TO FIVE AND SHARED
EARLIER IN MY OPENING COMMENTS
WE ARE CONCERNED WITH THE CUTS
USE STRONG WORK FORCE GIVEN
THAT LIKELIHOOD OF. INCREASED
DEMAND ESPECIALLY IN THESE
PROGRAMS STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAMS SUPPORTS THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A REGIONALLY AND
RESPONSIVE THE EMPLOYER
PROGRAMS- AND ENABLE US TO
PROVIDE SHORT TERM PROGRAMS
THAT CAN. PUT CALIFORNIANS BACK
TO WORK SO WE DO ASK THAT YOU
SEEK ALTERNATE APPROACHES ARE
ADDITIONAL NINE NINETY FINDING
IF NEEDED- TO SUPPORT AND
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAMS- IN
RIAN FUSE THIS NECESSARY
INVESTMENTS. OKAY YOU A CALL
CEMEX. ELEVEN FOR ME HAS GOOD.
WHATEVER PERHAPS YOU COULD
COMMENT ON THE L. A. O.'S
ALTERNATIVE. HAVING TO DO WITH
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE FROM WORK
FORCE PROGRAM VIS A VIS THE-
AND TO TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM. SINCE. COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE GENERALLY PART OF
THE BOTH CONSORTIA ARE INTO.
IT'S A COMMUNITY COLLEGES WORK-
THE STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM
HAS TWO ELEMENTS HAS A LOCAL
LEVEL FUNDING 60% STRONG
WORKFORCE DOLLARS REMAIN
LOCALLY 40% ARE UTILIZED FOR
REGIONAL COORDINATION AND
PLANNING- THE OTHER PORTION OF
IT IS ALSO THE K. TWELVE STRONG
WORK FORCE. ONE OF THE KEY
ROLES THAT THIS THIS PORTION OF
FUNDING FROM PROVIDED IS
ACTUALLY MORE OF A PASS THROUGH
THE PROGRAM THAT GOES AND
SERVICE PRIMARILY T. TWELVE- WE
BELIEVE THAT THE ALLEY A
PROPOSAL ON THIS AREA IS ONE
WORTH LOOKING AT ESPECIALLY
SINCE AGAIN- THE K. TWELVE
QUESTIONS STRONG WORK FORCE IS
PRIMARILY A PASS THROUGH- OF
FUNDS THAT ARE NOT NECESSARILY
GOING TO. COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
DO THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
PRESERVE THE REGIONAL FOCUS- AS
WELL AS THAT THE LOCAL LEVEL
FUNDING YOU CAN CONSIDER YEAH A
SLIGHTLY. ATTRIBUTIONS ABOUT
MORE TO FROM THE LOCAL BUT
STILL I GET THE BIGGEST ISSUE
IS THE OVERALL 55% CUT TO THE
TWO STRONG WORK FOR I'M AT A
TIME WHEN AGAIN I WILL LET
WE'RE LIKELY TO SEE MORE DEMAND
IN THE AREA. THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO THE SIXTY FORTY
SPLIT. THAT'S CORRECT. AND IS
THERE SOME READJUSTMENT THAT
THE. SYSTEM WOULD PROPOSE. I
KNOW IF WHAT HOW DOES THAT AND
OF THE- WHEN I'M COULD BE
LOOKING AT SEVEN THIRTY. AGAIN
REMAINING ME. THE REGION
PARTNERS IN THE REGION
STRUCTURE WHAT ALL WHEN SHE
THAT I'M ARE THEY LOOK. TO YOU
FOR PRO AND SERVICES HERE TO
SUPPLEMENT THE COST OF CREATING
THESE PROGRAMS- ESPECIALLY
RECOGNIZING THAT MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS WILL HAVE TO BE
OFFERED UNDER SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIRE RE REQUIREMENTS AND MAY
INCREASE THE COSTS WE CAN GET A
LOOK AT A DISTRIBUTION AGAIN-
ONCE WE KNOW MORE ACCURATELY
THE AMOUNT. OF DOLLARS THAT
WOULD BE INVESTED IN STRONG
WORK FORCE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THOSE COMMENTS. A SINGLE.
LET'S ON THIS IS A OPEN ITEMS
COURSE LET'S ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
SEVENTY EIGHT. STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES AND FACULTY.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE EUROPE.
HI MICHELLE NEWMAN AGAIN WITH
APARTMENT OF FINANCE- AS IS
NOTED IN THE AGENDA THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES. A REDUCTION
TO USE SEVERAL. SEVERAL SUCH AS
INCLUDING A SIXTY EIGHT POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR REDUCTION
IN EQUITY AND ACHIEVEMENT
PROGRAM. IN ADDITION THOUGH THE
MAY REVISION WITHDRAWS-
INVESTMENTS FOR FOOD PANTRIES
AND DREAMER RESOURCE LEANS ON
THE- REVISION PROPOSED A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD REQUIRE- COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE
BOTH FOOD PANTRIES AND SUPPORT
DREAMER. RESOURCE LIAISONS AS A
CONDITION OF RECEIVING. A C.
PROGRAM FUND. OUR AGAIN AS IS
NOTED AND THE- THE AGENDA THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES THAT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SYSTEM SUPPORT PROGRAM- WHICH-
TOOK A PATCHWORK OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT IF I'D BEEN
SYSTEM INITIATIVES AND
CONSOLIDATED INTO A SINGLE
PROGRAM- THE INTENT OF THAT WAS
TO- I WANT TO PROVIDE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THE USE OF THE FUNDS ARE
BUDGETED PRESENTED- FOR THOSE
FINE- EVERY YEAR AS- IS
CURRENTLY. AS IT'S CURRENTLY
PROVIDE IN BILL AND YOU IT
WOULDN'T ALLOW. THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SINCE THE FOR THE
CALLER. TO EVIL OVER TIME AS
THE SYSTEM NEEDS INVOLVED. AND.
AND AS I HAD EARLIER IN THE MAY
REVISION THEY WERE OF EACH
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR TO THAT
PROGRAM. IN ADDITION THERE ARE
A FEW PROPOSED REDUCTIONS FOR-
PROGRAMS INCLUDING- ROUGHLY TWO
OR TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLAR REDUCTION TO
THE ACADEMIC SENATE FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- AND
APPROXIMATELY 15% REDUCTION TO
PART TIME PART TIME FACULTY
COMPENSATION AND OFFICE HOURS
PROGRAMS- AND WITH THAT. HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. JUST ONE QUICK ONE SO
WE'VE WE'VE CUT THE FUNDING FOR
DREAMER RESOURCE LIAISON AND
FOOD PANTRIES AND ALSO THERE'S
A TRIGGER CUT TO THE STUDENT
EQUITY THAT SHIPMENT PROGRAM
BUT YET IN ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR
THE CUT FOR THE FOR THE REDUCED
FUNDS FOR STUDENT EQUITY.
COLLEGES HAVE TO HAVE A DREAMER
RESOURCE LIAISON AND OPERATE A
FOOD PANTRY HOW DOES HOW DO YOU
EXPECT THAT TO WORK. WELL I AM
GONNA GET EVERYTHING'S GETTING
CUT I'M NOT BEING. I MEAN I'M
NOT BEING SMART WITH THE
QUESTION I WAS JUST CURIOUS
IT'S GOING TO MAKE A DIFFICULT
ISN'T IT. YES IT IT IT. IT IS
DIFFICULT AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT TIME-
FOR COLLEGES THAT AS WELL AS
OUR STUDENTS RIGHT NOW. SO WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE WE ARE
ASKING FOR COLLEGES TO DO MORE
IN THIS INSTANCE- BUT THE
STUDENT EQUITY AND ACHIEVEMENT
PROGRAM IT IS THE LARGEST
CATEGORICAL PROGRAM THAT THAT
COLLEGES USE AND WE EXPECT THAT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO- STILL.
ON AN ALLOCATION BY SUPPORTING
THOSE OTHER PROGRAMS. OKAY FINE
I APPRECIATE THOSE. HELLO THE
NAME REVISION PROPOSES CUTS TO
VARIOUS STUDENTS OF SUPPORT
FACULTY SUPPORT AND SYSTEM WIDE
PROGRAMS UNDER MAY REVISE THESE
CUTS WOULD BE ROUGHLY 15% FOR
EACH THOUGH- ACADEMIC SENATES
CUT ACTUALLY WOULD BE ABOUT 25%
OF THE BASE FUNDING. SO
COMMITTING MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER REPRIORITIZE THE
REDUCTIONS. PRIORITIZING THEM
IN A DIFFERENT WAY AND WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S DONE. IF CUTS HAVE
TO BE MADE- PERHAPS START WITH
THE SYSTEM WIDE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROGRAMS THE SYSTEM THE SUPPORT
PROGRAM YOU JUST HEARD ABOUT
MANY ACTIVITIES FUNDED IN THE
SYSTEM- SUPPORT PROGRAM
INVOLVED IN PERSON CONFERENCES
AND TRAVEL. THE MEDIA CAMPAIGNS
AND THEY'RE ALSO THE COMMITTEE
MIGHT WANT TO CUT THIS PROGRAM
DEEPER THAN WHAT MADE DOES. ANY
TURN. THAT MIGHT PROVIDE
ANOTHER TO PRESERVE AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE- BECAUSE THE PROGRAMS
ARE PROVIDED DIRECT SERVICES TO
STUDENTS SO YOU JUST HEARD
ABOUT THE STUDENT EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM. WHICH IS
AIMED AT REDUCING ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS OF THROUGH TUTORING AND
COUNSELING AND OTHER ENHANCED
SERVICES SO IT'S REALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO ASSERT ITS OWN PRIORITIES IN
THE BUDGET AND WE ACTUALLY
WOULD WOULD THAT GO WAY YOU
JUST MENTIONED. SENATOR ROCK
ABOUT. THE ABILITY TO CALL IT
TO. TAKE ON TWO NEW
RESPONSIBILITIES OR
REQUIREMENTS WITH THE FOOD
PANTRIES AND THE DREAMER
RESOURCE LIAISONS WHEN THEY
HAVE. PERHAPS. SIXTY EIGHT TO
SIXTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS LESS
THAN WHAT'S CURRENTLY FIND IT.
SO THAT'S ANOTHER REASON WHY
YOU MIGHT WANT TO MINIMIZE. ANY
REDUCTIONS TO THIS- EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM TO ALLOW
THEM TO BETTER RESPOND ALL THE
CHALLENGES OF VARIOUS. GROUPS
OF STUDENTS AT THE COLLEGES ARE.
THANK YOU. MR READ PERHAPS YOU
COULD- PROVIDE SOME COMMENTS
AND IN PARTICULAR IN INCLUDING
YOUR CALL INCLUDED IN YOUR
COMMENTS MAYBE RESPOND TO THE
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT PROGRAM
COMMENTS OF THE LA I REALIZE
YOU'RE NOT. IN A POSITION TO
NEGOTIATE AGAINST YOURSELF BUT
I WONDER IF THERE ARE
REDUCTIONS IN SOME AREAS THAT
WOULD BE EASIER TO TAKE THAN
REDUCTIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BEING PROPOSED. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU I'M I WOULD
ADD THAT THERE ARE OTHER
CATEGORICAL STYLE WITH A MORE
EXPANSIVE DEFINITION OF THINGS
THAT CAN BE UTILIZED CAN ALSO
SUPPORT SOME OF THE KEY
MISSIONS IDENTIFIED IN THE
SYSTEM WORK AGAIN HE ADDED THAT
IS AGAIN REMAINING AND
MAINTAINING THE OVERALL-
AFTERWARDS THAT THEY COLLEGE
PROMISE PROVIDES. WITH ANY MORE
EXPANSIVE DEFINITION YOU CAN
MEET SOME OF THE GOALS
IDENTIFIED IN SYSTEM WOULD BE-
AND THEN TO EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM AND SERVE A
BROADER. AND MAY HAVE NEED ON
JALEN THE SYSTEM SUPPORT MY
WAYS REPRESENTS OPPORTUNE TO
BETTER SERVE THEM BETTER.
LIMITED RESOURCE RESEARCH THAT
ARE CURRENTLY IN FIFTY ONE
PURSE TO SERVE THE ENTIRE ONE
HADN'T COLLEGES SEVENTY THREE
AND TWO POINT ONE MILLION
STUDENTS THIS WOULD ALLOW US TO
PROVIDE AND SERVICE KIND OF
SCALE MY MASK. EARLIER YOU
ABOUT TAKING NEEDS ONE NEED HAS
NOT BEEN FUNDED AND WE'LL GO ON
MAX WITHOUT FUN FOR AND ALLOW
FLEXIBILITY IN WHAT IS THIS
SINCE ORTIZ LIKE THE LIBRARY
SERVICE. THIS ALLOWS FROM ANY
OF THE CALL THAT THEY CAN TO
ABLE TO. UTILIZE AN ACT
PERIODICALS ANYTHING THAT THEY
NEED FOR RESEARCH THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT THE SYSTEM
SUPPORT COULD POTENTIALLY FIND
WITH IDENTIFIED COST SAVINGS
MINIMIZE COST CUTTERS SPENDS
ON- FISCAL AGENT AGREEMENTS AND
THEN AGAIN YES AS THE ELLIE-
DID IDENTIFY THERE WILL BE COST
SAVINGS FROM LESS TROUBLING
CONVENTION THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY
DELIGHTS TO BETTER SERVE
STATEWIDE NEEDS IN A MORE
COHESIVE. AND TRANSPARENT
MANNER. SIXTY FOUR FORTY
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SIXTY
SIX HUNDRED HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
LAW AND SIXTY SIX TEN
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
ISSUE SEVENTY NINE OPERATING
BUDGET REDUCTION. AFFIRMATIVE
FINANCE. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS BRIANNA FRIENDS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PRETTY
EASY AND THE SCO THE MAYOR
VERSION REMOVES MOST OF THE NEW
PROPOSAL PROVIDED AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT
MAINTAINS MET BUT MAINTAINS
SEVERAL PROPOSALS INCLUDING
ELEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR THE UC
RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
TICKET TO SUPPORT CURRENT
OPERATIONS. ONE POINT TWO
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND
FOR UCSF SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
FRESNO BRANCH CAMPUS TO SUPPORT
AN EXISTING UCSF UC MERCED
PARTNERSHIP. AND FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR
ANIMAL SHELTER DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS. THE MAYOR VISION ALSO
PROPOSES FURTHER ADJUSTMENTS TO
MAKE THEM CONTINGENT ON A
FEDERAL FUNDING UNLESS AND
UNTIL SUFFICIENT INCREASES IN
FEDERAL SUPPORT ARE AVAILABLE
FOR PROGRAM RESTORATION. EVEN
ACTIONS ARE NECESSARY TO
BALANCE THE STATE BUDGET THEY
INCLUDE THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION FROM THE
UCC MAIN GENERAL FUND ITEM AND
THREE HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
MILLION FROM CST IS REFLECTING
A 10% REDUCTION IN EACH. THIRTY
FOUR MILLION FROM THESE THESE
OTHER GENERAL FUND ITEM FOR THE
UC OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT USE
THE PATH AND THE DIVISION OF
AGRICULTURE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES. AND FOUR MILLION FOR
THE UC AND SIX MILLION FOR THE
CSTO SUPPORT SUMMER TERM
FINANCIAL AID. BUT THAT AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE. WELL THANK YOU. HELLO
I'VE- LIVED HERE FROM YOU AND-
YOU HAD SOME ALTERNATIVE
SUGGESTIONS. HE DOESN'T. THIS
IS GOING TO BE CHASING CONSTANT
TAURUS. HOW ARE YOU SIR. ARE
YOU SENATOR I'M FINE TAKE IT
AWAY. THAT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE INTRACELLULAR. FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOCUSED ON
BASE REDUCTIONS IN OUR VIEW IS
WARRANTED GIVEN THE STATES OF
STRUCTURAL BUDGET DEFICIT
HOWEVER WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
TIMING OF THESE RDUCTIONS I'M
ALL FOR THE SEGMENTS A LITTLE
TIME TO RESPOND TO THE
REDUCTIONS IN THE WAY THEY
HAVE. IN PREVIOUS RECESSIONS
FOR EXAMPLE ABOVE CERTAIN
CAMPUS THE CAMPUS IS A BOTH A
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS HAVE LARGELY
MADE FULL ADMISSIONS DECISIONS
FOR THEIR ABILITY TO ADJUSTABLE
NEXT ARM IS SOMEWHAT LIMITED AT
THIS POINT- LIKEWISE- THEIR
ABILITY TO INCREASE TUITION TO
OFFSET SOME OF THESE REDUCTIONS
ALSO SOMEWHAT LIMITED. GIVEN
THE STUDENT CONSULTATION
EXPECTATIONS ABOUT. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS MEETINGS
SEGMENTS. FROM WHAT MINE ARE IS
SHE HAS YOU KNOW DIDN'T
DEVELOPING A MUSTARD OF
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
TAKING. ON WHAT WITHOUT AIM OF
REDUCING- I'M OF A NOTABLE
PORTION OF THE SPACE REDUCTIONS.
I'M THE STAFF AND SO I WON'T GO
INTO GREAT DETAIL ABOUT NOT.
ALTERNATIVELY THAT UP FOR Q. NA
ALL BUT THE ESSENTIAL ELEMENTS
OF THE ALTERNATIVE ARE- TO
REFER MORE ONE TIME I SPEND ONE
TIME FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. ONTO BOTH
UNIVERSITY SEGMENTS- WE THINK
THERE COULD BE YOU- HELLO
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS IN TOTAL
IT ALL STRESSED AND SAD- COULD
BE REVERTED MOSTLY FOR-
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. AREA WE
THINK THE LEGISLATURE COULD
FOCUS A LOT OF ATTENTION ON IS-
DRYING DOWN CAMPUS RESEARCH
UNDER THIS APPROACH THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD STILL
INACTIVE BUDGET REDUCTION- BUT
THE SEGMENTS WOULD MAINTAIN A
PORTION OF THEIR OPERATIONS BY
DRAWING DOWN RESEARCH. ON BOTH
SEGMENTS HAD. I JUST OVER A
DOLLARS IN CORPS RESERVE. I'M
OUT AND A PORTION OF THOSE
RESERVES A LOT HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS WAS AVAILABLE
SPECIFICALLY FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES AND AT. A CERTAIN
ADVANCED FOR COMMITTED TO
CERTAIN CASTALDO CAMPUSES MIGHT
BE TRYING TO REVISIT SOME OF
THESE COMMITMENTS IN LIGHT OF
THE CURRENT OUTBREAK. I'M
LOOKING AT THE DATA WE FELT
THAT MAYBE UP TO TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ACTS YES YOU HAVE UP TO
A HUNDRED MILLION THAT YOU SEE-
COULD BE DRAWN DOWN FOR
RESEARCH TO HELP MITIGATE.
PRODUCTIONS WE HAD A FEW
OPTIONS TO MAYBE OFFER SOME
MORE TARGETED REDUCTIONS WERE
THOSE JOBS STILL NEEDED EVEN IN
LIGHT OF. WE'RE SENDING ONE
TIME FUNDING AND DRAWING DOWN
RESERVES FOR EXAMPLE FOR YOU
SEE POTENTIALLY TARGETING SOME
REDUCTIONS TOWARDS PROGRAMS
THAT- ARE LESS RELATED TO
INSTRUCTION OR A NEED BASED
FINANCIAL AID FOR STUDENTS TO
THINGS LIKE RESEARCH FOR
EXAMPLE. ONE MORE THING I WOULD
EMPHASIZE IS THAT WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE TAKE ALL APPROACH.
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD STILL.
FACE DFFICULT DECISIONS IN THE
FOLLOWING BUDGET SO IT'S NOT A
PERMANENT SOLUTION THE- IDEA
HERE WOULD BE TO MINIMIZE MOST
OF THE REDUCTIONS. AND GIVE
BOTH UNIVERSITY SEGMENTS MORE
TIME TO RESPOND TO START
THINKING ABOUT AND WILL NEED TO
START THINKING ABOUT TUITION
AND START THINKING ABOUT-
YOU'RE VERY DEFICIENCIES
OPERATIONAL REDUCTIONS OF ANY
GIVE YOU MORE TIME TO REVIEW
THAT SEARCH. ENGINES ARE MAKING.
IS IT YOUR THOUGHT THAT. WE
WOULD ALLOW THE US TO SYSTEMS
WHETHER IT'S YOU SEE YOUR C.
ISSUE. TO DETERMINE WHICH
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
TO PROCEED WITH AND SOME THAT
BOOK PERHAPS ARE DEEMED
ESSENTIAL WOULD BE ALLOWED TO
PROCEED AND THOSE THAT. ARE
DEEMED LESS ESSENTIAL SINCE I'M
SURE THEY'RE ALL ESSENTIAL BUT
LESS ESSENTIAL UNDER THE
CURRENT ENVIRONMENT. WOULD BE
POSTPONED AND THAT MONEY
DIVERTED TO ALLOW THEM TO
DIVERT THAT THE INSTITUTION TO
DIVERT TAT MONEY. INTO CORPS
CORE FUNCTION. YEAH THAT'S
THAT'S CORRECT WE WERE
THINKING- BUT BASICALLY THAT
WITH THE FUNDS HAVEN'T BEEN
COMMITTED. ALREADY FUNDS THAT
HAVE BEEN COMMITTED TO ANY
PROJECT JUST SIMPLY BE
REVERTED. TO THE CENTER OF THE
FUNDS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
COMMITTED- OBVIOUSLY THOSE
WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
RECURSION BUT ANY ANY CASE
WHERE THE FUNDS ARE SPENT WE
WOULD THINK. WOULD BE WE WOULD
WE WOULD THINK DIVERT THOSE
FUNDS. THERE IS TO THE CAMPUS
RESERVE A CAMPUS RESERVES THE
SAME. A LOT OF SYSTEMS TO
DETERMINE. THE LEVEL OF
RESERVES AT STATE MINIMUM
ESSENTIAL LEVEL OF RESERVE AND-
AND BURN THROUGH THE REST IF
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT CORE
FUNCTION. YEAH HERE WE WERE
THINKING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD WORK WITH THE SEGMENTS
TO- THINK ABOUT AT A HIGH LEVEL
OF YOU KNOW RESERVES THAT WOULD
BE AVAILABLE TO BE DRAWN DOWN
AGAIN WE SORT OF. JUST LOOKING
OUT THERE- RESERVES PRIOR TO
THE OUTBREAK. SINCE YOU THE
RECORD HOLDER RESERVED FOR
ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
YOU SEE WAS ABOUT ONE POINT ONE
BILLION- OF THAT AMOUNT MOST.
DIFFICULT PORTION WAS COMMITTED
FOR THINGS LIKE CONTRACTS. IN
NEW FACULTY STARTUP CONTRACTS
AND CAPITAL OUTLAY THE REST WAS
UNRESTRICTED. ON IN ANY CASE IF
YOU SEE IN SOME CASES THERE
AREN'T EVEN FORMAL POLICIES ON.
A DESIGNATED THINGS RESERVED
FOR SPECIFIC PRIORITIES AND SO
WE FELT KIND OF LOOKING AT THAT
DATA AND SERVER RECOGNIZING
THAT THERE MIGHT BE SOME
DEFICIT SPENDING GOING ON
CURRENTLY. BUT ALSO THAT THERE
COULD BE SOME. RIGHT COULD BE
MAKING TO TRY THAT- ELEVEN
REDUCE SOME OF THE COMMITMENTS
THEY MADE WE THOUGHT THOSE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION A HUNDRED
MILLION LEVELS COULD BE A
REASONABLE STARTING POINT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE BUT THAT WAS
THAT'S WHAT IT WOULD BE A
REASONABLE STARTING POINT FOR
DISCUSSION. SECONDS I'LL BE
INTERESTED IN HEARING FROM THE-
THE INSTITUTIONS OTHER
PERSPECTIVE IS THE AUTHOR.
THAT'S IT THANK YOU OKAY ABOUT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR OFF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
SAFER CANNON FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA I PROVIDED A
HANDOUT WITH A BLUE COVERED TO
COMMITTEE STAFF AND WILL BE
REFERRING TO IT DURING MY
PRESENTATION. A PERMANENT
FINANCE IN LA- HAVE DISCUSSED
THE STATE IS FACING SIGNIFICANT
LOSS OF REVENUE FROM CODE
NINETEEN AND UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IS NO EXCEPTION.
UNIVERSITY MAKES TO ASK OF THE
SENATE. IF YOU APPROVE A BUDGET
THAT MAINTAINS THE UNIVERSITY'S
GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION. AT THE
LEVELS PROVIDED IN THE BUDGET
ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN. AND THE
GREATEST DEGREE POSSIBLE AS THE
STATE RECEIVES FEDERAL FUNDS
YOU CONSIDERED THE UNIVERSITY
HAS A STRONG INVESTMENT. LIKE
TO DETAILS UNIVERSITIES COVERED
NINETEEN RELATED FINANCIAL
LOSSES THROUGH APRIL THIRTIETH.
A TOTAL OF NEARLY ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN EXPENDITURES
AND LOST REVENUES. AS THE
WORLD'S LARGEST PUBLIC RESEARCH
UNIVERSITY OUR ACADEMIC HEALTH
CENTERS ARE TREATING PATIENTS
OUR RESEARCHERS ARE SEEKING
THERAPIES AND VACCINES WE ARE
PROVIDING OUR TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS
WITH REMOTE INSTRUCTION. AND
CONTINUING TO EMPLOY OUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES. THE UNIVERSITY HAS
ACCESS TO OVER TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY MILLION IN FEDERAL
SUPPORT PROVIDED BY THE KERR
SACKED ONE HALF OF WHICH GOES
TO CAMPUSES AND THE OTHER HALF
IS DIRECT EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE
THE STUDENTS. A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION THE CAMPUSES WILL
RECEIVE COVERS ONLY A FRACTION
OF THE COST ATTRIBUTABLE TO
COPE WITH NINETEEN. USING THESE
ACADEMIC CELL HEALTH CENTERS
HAVE RECEIVED AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION TO
DATE IN THE CARADOC FUNDING FOR
HOSPITALS AGAIN THIS WILL NOT
ONLY COVER. THE FIVE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE MILLION IN LOST
REVENUES FROM CANCELED
SURGERIES AND OTHER MEDICAL
CARE. THE UNIVERSITY WILL ALSO
TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF BEING A
REIMBURSEMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PANDEMIC RELATED COSTS BUT FEMA
REIMBURSES ACTUAL EXPENDITURES
ONLY AND NOT LOST REVENUES. DO
THE CODE NINETEEN IMPACTS
CAMPUSES HAVE LOST MIKE'S
ABILITY WITH FUNDING. WE HAVE
ALSO IN EVERY AREA OF OUR
OPERATIONS AND WE DON'T YET
KNOW WHERE THE BOTTOM IS.
DURING PRIOR ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS
UNIVERSITY HAD OPTIONS FOR
INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL BORROWING
TO CHRISTIAN PRODUCTIONS AND
NOW THAT OPTION FOR BORROWING
IS NOT AVAILABLE IN THE SAME
WAY WE ARE NOW FAR MORE
CONSTRAINED. WITH THAT CONTEXT
IN MIND I WILL ASK YOU T TURN
TO SLIDE THREE. THE CHART ON
SLIDE THREE SHOWS THE CORE
FUNDS PER STUDENT. EACH BAR ON
THE CHART REPRESENTS TOTAL
EXPENDITURES PER STUDENT.
ALTHOUGH THE TOTAL AMOUNT HAS
GONE UP THE MOST RECENT YEAR
SHOW THE FINANCIAL AID OUR
RETIREMENT PROGRAM
CONTRIBUTIONS AND THE
UNIVERSITY'S DEBT SERVICE ARE
TAKING UP AN INCREASINGLY LARGE
AMOUNTS OF THE CAMPUS FUNDING.
THIS MEANS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
DOLLARS PER STUDENT ARE NOW
ABOUT THE SAME AS THEY WERE IN
TWENTY TEN. WE ALSO FACE
UNCERTAINTY REGARDING OUR
INTERNATIONAL ENROLLMENTS. ARE
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS
CONTRIBUTE NEARLY ONE POINT
THREE BILLION THE CAMPUS
BUDGETS FOR SUPPLEMENTAL
TUITION PAY PAY. AT THIS TIME
WE DO NOT KNOW IF OUR NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE
TO RETURN OR IF THEY WILL
CHOOSE TO RETURN TO THEIR
STUDIES AND ALL. THIS COULD
IMPACT THE FUND'S OUR CAMPUS IS
RELIED UPON TO EDUCATE ALL OUR
STUDENTS. THIS IS THE CONTEXT
IN WHICH YOU ARE ASKED TO
CONSIDER THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE RECOMMENDATION A 10%
REDUCTION WITH THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA. UNIVERSITY ONLY
HAS THREE POSSIBLE WAYS OF
DEALING WITH REVENUE LOSSES
CUTTING EXPENDITURES INCREASING
REVENUES ARE USING RESERVES.
CANVAS CARBINES RESERVES ARE
NOT SUFFICIENT TO DEAL WITH
THESE UNEXPECTED COSTS. I ASK
YOU TO PLEASE TURN TO SLIDE
FOUR TO SEE HOW THE UNIVERSITY
INITIALLY DEALT WITH THESE
UNEXPECTED EXPENSES AND LOST
REVENUES. COLLECTIVELY ALL UC
CHANCELLORS OF PRESIDENT
APPALLING KANO ANNOUNCED ON
APRIL SECOND THAT THERE WOULD
BE NO COVERT NINETEEN RELATED
LAY OFFS FOR CAREER EMPLOYEES.
THROUGH THE END OF THE FISCAL
YEAR ON JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY. THIS DECISION WAS MADE
TO GIVE PEACE OF MIND ARE
VALUED EMPLOYEES. AS THE THIRD
LARGEST EMPLOYER IN THE STATE
USE THESE ACTIONS ARE KEEPING
PEOPLE EMPLOYED AS POSITIVELY
IMPACTED LOCAL ECONOMIES.
HOWEVER CONTINUE TO PAY OUR
EMPLOYEES WHEN MULTIPLE
COMPONENTS OF OUR REVENUE HAVE
EXPERIENCED TREMENDOUS LOSSES
IS NOT POSSIBLE WITHOUT
SUTAINED STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDS. SO FAR TO CONTAIN COSTS
TO CUT EXPENDITURES YOU SEE HAS
TAKEN A NUMBER OF STEPS THESE
INCLUDE A SYSTEM WIDE FREEZE ON
SALARIES FOR NON REPRESENTED
STAFF A SYSTEM WIDE FREEZE ON
SALARY SCALES FOR NON STUDENT
ACADEMIC EMPLOYEES OF OUR TERRY
PAY CUT OF 10% OR CURRENT
CHANCELLOR SAID THE PRESIDENT.
ELIMINATING NONESSENTIAL TRAVEL
AND RENEGOTIATING PROFESSIONAL
SERVICE AGREEMENTS. SLIDE FIVE
SHOWS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE PROPOSAL REDUCES THE
UNIVERSITY'S BUDGET BY 10% OR
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO
MILLION FROM THE NINETEEN
TWENTY FUNDING LEVEL. WE
BELIEVE THAT REDUCTIONS THE
UNIVERSITIES BASED BUDGET
COMBINED WITH THE INCREASED
COST IN LOST REVENUES THE
UNIVERSITY IS EXPERIENCING WILL
HAVE NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF OUR
ABILITY TO DELIVER INSTRUCTION
CONDUCT RESEARCH AND CARE FOR
PATIENTS. WE THEREFORE REQUEST
THAT YOUHOLD THE UNIVERSITIES
BASED BUDGET LIVE FROM THE
CURRENT YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY
TWO THE BUDGET YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WE ALSO SEEK YOUR
ASSISTANCE IN RECEIVING AS MUCH
FEDERAL FUNDING COMING TO
CALIFORNIA AS POSSIBLE WE
REQUEST THIS BECAUSE THE
UNIVERSITY IS GOING TO BE
ENROLLING ADDITIONAL STUDENTS
THIS FALL. WE ARE COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THAT THESE INCOMING
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES
RECEIVE THE EDUCATION THEY
DESERVE. IN PRIOR RECESSIONS
UNIVERSITY RACED REVENUES WHICH
HELPS COUNTER LOSSES IN STATE
GENERAL FUNDS AND MAINTAIN
ACCESS AFFORDABILITY AND
QUALITY. BUT IN THIS CORPORATE
NINETEEN INDUCED RECESSION WE
KNOW THAT MULTIPLE REVENUE
SOURCES HAVE BEEN IMPACTED OR
NOT I'M NOT AVAILABLE. FOR
SUPPORTING OUR STUDENTS STAFF
AND FACULTY. EARNERS MAY REVISE
ALSO CONTINUES TO MAKE MUCH
NEEDED INVESTMENTS IN MEDICAL
EDUCATION INCLUDING ELEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION FOR THE UC
RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
UNIVERSITY CONTINUES TO REQUEST
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR UC
RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
BECAUSE THE SCHOOL IS UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO EXPAND MEDICAL
EDUCATION IN A REGION THAT HAS
BEEN MEDICALLY UNDER SERVED OR
ARE TOO LONG. AND CENTER ROSTER
I HAVE BEEN REQUESTED TO READ A
BRIEF STATEMENT OR UC HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF THE LAW ON THEIR
BEHALF IF THAT IS ALL RIGHT
THAT'S FINE THANK YOU PLEASE.
RATE THIS IS- A FORTY UC
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE LAW ON
BEHALF OF CFO DAVID SEWARD. HE
THINKS COLLEGE OF THE LAW
FOUNDED IN EIGHTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT SORRY. I MISSPOKE ISN'T
COLLEGE OF THE LAW AND IN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT IT'S A
STRONG AND RESILIENT
INSTITUTION DEDICATED TO
FULFILLING ITS PUBLIC MISSION
THE MAGNITUDE OF. THE SCHOOL
CARNAGE COSTS AND TO BE CAUSED
BY THE CODE NINETEEN THAN
DEMOCRATS IT'S A GOOD STORY
PROPORTIONS. IF THINGS VALUES
ITS AFFILIATION WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
ITS RELATIONSHIP WITH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE HASTINGS
DOES NOT BENEFIT FROM THE
FINANCIAL HEALTH OF OUR
COMPATRIOTS IN CALIFORNIA'S
SYSTEM OF HIGHER EDUCATION WE
WILL PERSEVERE MANAGED THROUGH
THESE DIFFICULT TIMES AND LOOK.
FORWARD TO BETTER ONCE HATCHED.
IT WAS MY BROTHER. THANK YOU
WELL BEFORE WE GO TO SEE ISSUE
OF THANK YOU FOR THAT THE
PRESENTATION I WANT TO
COMPLIMENT THE PRESIDENT ON THE
QUALITY OF THE FILM A LETTER
THAT. DR PAN AND I RECEIVED-
DATED MAY TWENTY SECOND TWENTY
TWENTY ON THE- ISSUES THAT THE
SYSTEM UC SYSTEM IS FACING.
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO. FIND MORE
MONEY FOR. OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS IN THE STATE MY
SPECIFIC QUESTION THOUGH BEFORE
WE GO ON TO. SEE ISSUE AND MY
COLLEAGUES- WITH RESPECT TO THE
ITEMS RAISED BY THE LA- IN
TERMS OF ALTERNATIVES AND
SPECIFICALLY. THOSE PERTAINING
TO THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FUNDING AND- THE RESERVE
FUNDING- FUNDS MAINTAINED BY
YOU SEE. IS THERE SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO DO IN THIS
BUDGET ACT TO PROVIDE YOU SEE
WITH FLEXIBILITY. WITH REGARD
TO THE USE OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDS PREVIOUSLY
APPROPRIATED AND ALSO YOUR
RESERVE FUNDS. BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOME STOP GAP OR
SHORT OR SHORT RANGE- BACK FILL
IS NEEDED. TO TRY TO PRESERVE
MORE OF YOUR CORE FUNCTION WE
WOULDN'T BUDGET BILLING TO
SWEEP THOSE OLD FUNDS AND
PROVIDE THEM TO US AS
UNALLOCATED FUNDS BECAUSE THE
UNIVERSITY IS REQUIRED TO
SPEND. ONE TIME FUNDS ON THE
PURPOSE SPECIFIED IN THE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE SO WE'RE NOT ABLE
TO SWEEP THOSE LEGALLY AND
SPEND TIME ON SOMETHING ELSE-
IF WE DON'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO DO SO. I WILL NOTE THAT. AND
WE DID NOT GET THIS INFORMATION
TO THE LA- SO I APOLOGIZE TO
THE ANALYST- WE SURVEYED OUR
CAMPUSES AS TO HOW MANY OF THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDS WERE
ALREADY COMMITTED THROUGH
CONTRACTS AND THERE ACTUALLY IS
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AT THIS POINT. THAT IS
FULLY- UNCOMMITTED SO NOT THE
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION THE REST
OF IT DOES HAVE CONTRACTS
ATTACHED TO IT- IN TERMS OF THE
EAGLES TWENTY FIVE MILLION IS
UNCOMMITTED. AND SEVENTY TWENTY
BY TWENTY FIVE MILLION AT THIS
POINT DOES NOT HAVE A CONTRACT
THAT HAS BEEN SIGNED BY THE
UNIVERSITY. OF THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDS THAT WE
RECEIVED. IN THE PRIOR YEAR.
THE LA- REPORT REFLECTS MAYBE
I'M MISREADING IT. TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTEEN MILLION FOR UC.
THE LARGEST SINGLE COMPONENT OF
THIS WAS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS I SEE SO
IT'S TWO EIGHTEEN TOTAL AND
THEN SOME PORTION OF THAT WAS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND YOU
ARE SUGGESTING THAT THAT WAS A
HUNDRED MILLION. YES THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDING
THAT IS AVAILABLE TO BE SWEPT
US LESS I THANK THEM AS IN THE
LA- REPORT. WILL WORK WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF TO GET AN
ACCURATE NUMBER. FOR THEM BUT I
WANTED TO MAKE NOTE OF THAT- OF
THE APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
MILLION IN THE PRIOR YEAR
ALLOCATIONS THERE'S ONLY ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE IT CURRENTLY. DOES
NOT HAVE A CONTRACT ATTACHED TO
IT OKAY. WELL I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE I ASKED THE
QUESTION BECAUSE WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO PROVIDE. BOTH UC AND C.
ISSUE THE FLEXIBILITY TO USE
MONEY PREVIOUSLY APPROPRIATED
IF THE INSTITUTIONS TO.
DETERMINE THAT THERE IS A MORE
APPROPRIATE. CORE FUNCTION
RELATED USE- SO WE'LL WORK ON
THAT. THANK YOU MA'AM.
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY SEE
IF YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
SO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PROVIDE. C. ISSUES COMMENTS ON
THIS ISSUE OUTLOOK AND THE
REVISION I'LL SPEAK TO A
PROPOSED CUT. IN THIS ITEM CAN
BE PROPOSED FISCAL FLEXIBILITY.
IN WHICH ARMY. HI MY NAME IS
RYAN STORM ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR BUDGET ALBANY
STATE UNIVERSITY CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. SO AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR THIS ISSUE WAS N
STRONG FOOTING- THE CSU'S FOUR
YEAR GRADUATION RATE FIRST TIME
STUDENTS INCREASED TO TWENTY
SEVEN AND A HALF PERCENT. UP
FROM NINETEEN POINT 3% SINCE
THE LAUNCH DATE OF GRANT
MICHIGAN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. WE
GRADUATED TWENTY THOUSAND MORE
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS IN JUST
FIVE YEARS AGO. AND WE MADE OUR
PROGRESS IN ENSURING THAT OUR
FACULTY AND STAFF ARE BEING A
FAIR AND COMPETITIVE WAGES. SO
WHILE OUR CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE
CHANGED IN THE STATE IS NOW IN
AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN WE
CONTINUE TO BE FOCUSED ON OUR
MISSION. AND SERVING OUR
STUDENTS AND CALIFORNIA AS BEST
AS WE CAN. CERTAINLY WE
UNDERSTAND THE SITUATION THAT
KOBE NINETEEN HAS USHERED IN
THE NEW FISCAL REALITY. ANY
VERY UNFORTUNATELY OF A
PROLONGED STATE BUDGET CRISIS.
SO FIRST- ABOUT MY COMMENTS
ABOUT THE PROPOSED CUTS. MR
SHIVERS PROPOSAL AS DETAILED AS
A THREE HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR ONGOING BUDGET
REDUCTION THAT'S A 10%
REDUCTION TO OUR GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION. FIVE PERSPECTIVE
ALL RIGHT THAT IS EQUIVALENT TO
TWO TIMES ALL OF THE ON GOING
MONEY DEDICATED SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN. TO CSU'S
GRADUATION ISSUE TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. NOW THIS CANCEL REDUCTION
CLEARLY IS FORMIDABLE MOREOVER
THE ACTUAL IMPACT TO SEIZE YOUR
BUDGET IS MORE SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE WE HAVE CLOSE TO ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF MORE
MANDATORY COSTS AND COMPUTER
RELATED COSTS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR THAT ARE NOT FUNDED.
THEREFORE WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION MINIMIZE
A REDUCTION TO OUR BASE
OPERATIONS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
ONE POSSIBLE PATH IS TO ADOPT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
ALTERNATIVE WHICH SWEEPS
UNSPENT CURRENT YOUR DOLLARS
AND LESSENS THE REDUCTION BY
THE SAME AMOUNT IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. IN FACT WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE ONLY ALTERNATIVE BEADOPTED
IN LIEU OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL. IT IS A WASH FROM THE
STATE'S FIRST GENERAL FUND
PERSPECTIVE TO DO THIS CURRENT
YEAR BUDGET CHANGE IT PROVIDES
US TEMPORARY RELIEF. IF HE L.
A. O.'S ALTERNATE IS ADOPTED IT
COULD REDUCE THE BUDGET YOUR
CUTS THIS ISSUE BY AS MUCH AS
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS OR CUT WHAT WHAT WOULD
BE A REVISED KIND OF TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS INSTEAD. OF THE THREE
HUNDRED NINETY. MALENKO I NOW
LIKE TO TURN THAT FISCAL
FLEXIBILITY ISSUE THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER. WELL THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE POTENTIAL CUTS
TO THE CSU IS DAUNTING- WE
LEARNED FROM THE GREAT
RECESSION. AND WE THAT SEES YOU
CURRENTLY HAVE A NUMBER OF
TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO MITIGATE
THE IMPACT ON OUR STUDENTS OR
FACULTY OR STAFF. HE SEES YOU
AS PRUDENTLY GROW RESERVES TO
MEET CERTAIN STRATEGIC GOALS.
ONE OF WHICH HAS BEEN
PREPARATION FOR POSSIBLE
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY. I THINK
YOU SHOULD DRAW UPON THESE
RESERVES ALREADY TO MAINTAIN
OPERATIONS AND PROGRAMS
IMPACTED BY THE COLD IN
NINETEEN. AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO DO SO. REALLY THE USE OF
RESERVES UP WHICH ARE ONE TIME
FUNDS CANNOT BE A PERMANENT
SOLUTION. BUT THEY ARE A
VALUABLE ASSET THAT CAN BE
UTILIZED UNTIL SUCH TIME AS
OTHER RESOURCES BECOME
AVAILABLE. OUR CAMPUSES ALSO
HAVE RECEIVED FUNDING FROM
FEDERAL CARERS ACT FUNDING
WHICH WILL MITIGATE SOME OF THE
COSTS AND LOSSES REVENUE LOSSES
DUE TO THE NINETEEN. IN APRIL-
C. SHIPMENT OF THE HIRING CHILL
AND REDUCE NONESSENTIAL TRAVEL
BOTH OF WHICH WILL SAVE MANY
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY. AND WITH THE CSU
TOOLS AND MINE WE ASKED THE
LOGISTICS PROVIDES YOU MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY IN BEING ABLE TO
OPERATIONALIZE FINAL BUDGET
REDUCTION. STOREKEEPER CREDIT
REFERENCING B. SIDE SEES YOU
TOOLS WELL THERE IS A SINGLE
PROPOSED NEW TOOL THAT IS IN
YOUR AGENDA TODAY AS OF RIGHT
NOW STAFF. DOES NOT RECOMMEND
THAT YOU ADOPTED. THAT PROPOSAL
IS THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD ALLOW
EXCUSE YOU TO USE RESTRICTED C.
ISSUE FUNDS ACROSS UNIVERSITY
TO ADDRESS A CUTE LITTLE BIT
NINETEEN RELATED IMPACTS AND
REVENUE LOSSES. WE FULLY
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL AND
REQUEST THAT YOU NOT. WE ARE
ALL OVER WE FULLY SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL I'M REQUESTING YOU ACT
NOW AND NOT A DELAY ACTION ON
THAT ON THAT PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL. WE NEED THE
FLEXIBILITY AS WE ENTER THESE
TOUGH FINANCIAL TIMES IN THIS
PROPOSAL I'M SURE THAT IF
NEEDED WE WILL HAVE THE FINAL
TOOL NECESSARY TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE ABLE TO MITIGATE IMPACTS
TO STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF.
AS WE LOOK TO THE FALL IN THE
FUTURE THERE ARE A HANDFUL OF
ITEMS FOR YOU TO KEEP IN MIND.
FIRST THE CHANCELLOR RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED THAT ARE PLANNING.
WHICH WILL RESULT IN SUSHI
COURSES PRIMARY PRIMARILY BEING
DELIVERED VIRTUALLY. ALL TWENTY
TWENTY TERM. WITH LIMITED
EXCEPTIONS FOR IN PERSON
ACTIVITIES THAT CANNOT BE
DELIVERED VIRTUALLY. THERE WILL
BE HYBRID APPROACHES AND THERE
WILL BE A VARIABILITY ACROSS
THE TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES. DUE
TO SPECIFIC CONTEXTS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES. PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS PREDICT WAVES OF
INFECTION. IN LATE FALL TWENTY
TWENTY IN EARLY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND IF WE WERE TO BEGIN FOR
A FACE TO FACE MODALITY WE
WOULD LIKELY HAVE TO SWITCH TO
A VIRTUAL FORMAT AND THAT WOULD
COMPROMISE RIGOROUS STANDARDS.
FIFTY AND WELFARE. SECOND AS I
NOTED EARLIER THE UNIVERSITY IS
MORE THAN JUST ACADEMIC AND
STUDENT SUPPORTS INCLUDES STATE
SIDE STUDENTS SPORTS LIKE
HEALTH CENTERS. ARE HOUSING
PARKING AND STUDENT CENTERS.
SOME OF THESE PROGRAM AREAS ARE
UNCHARACTERISTICALLY
INSIGNIFICANT THIS STRESS
BECAUSE STUDENTS EMPLOYEES AND
THE PUBLIC ARE LARGELY ABSENT
FROM OUR CAMPUSES. THESE
CHALLENGES COULD NEGATIVELY
IMPACT OTHER AREAS OF THE
UNIVERSITY. BUT THAT HAS NOT
HAPPENED YET. BUT WE'RE WORKING
TO AVOID THAT- AGAIN BUT WE ARE%
AWARE THAT IT COULD BE THAT BUT
I WANTYOU TO BE AWARE THAT IT.
COULD BECOME A SERIOUS
CHALLENGE IN THE FUTURE. OUR
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION HAS TO
BE A PRIORITY. IN THE STATE NOW
AND IN THE FUTURE REMEMBER THEY
SEE ISSUE IS THE LARGEST FOUR
YEAR PUBLIC UNIVERSITY IN THE
COUNTRY. IN HALF OF ALL NEW
DEGREES THE STATE NEEDS TO KEEP
THIS THING MOVING FORWARD
ORIGINALLY OUT OF THE C. ISSUE.
DOES YOUR FUTURE TEACHERS YOUR
NURSES YOUR SCIENTISTS YOUR
AGRICULTURAL EXPERTS SENIOR
ENTREPRENEURS. FOURTH AND
FINALLY WE WILL CONTINUE TO
FULFILL OUR MISSION TO
CALIFORNIA WE WILL CONTINUE TO
BE A BEACON OF OPPORTUNITY AND
SOCIAL MOBILITY IN THE GOOD
TIMES AND NOT SO GOOD TIMES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
LET ME ASK ONE QUESTION CAN YOU
GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE OF
RESTRICTED FUNDS AND THEN THE
USE WHAT TYPE OF FUNDS ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT. SURE YEAH THERE
ARE THERE ARE SEVERAL OF THEM.
B. R. MANY YEARS AGO AND THERE
WERE A NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT
WERE CREATED IN STATE LAW THAT
AND THESE ARE STUDENTS SUPPORT
SERVICES SO THERE ARE THERE
SUCH THINGS AND START TORIES.
ARE PARKING THEIR STUDENT
UNIONS THERE STUDENT CENTERS-
HEALTH CENTERS AND THE WAY THAT
IT STRUCTURALLY WORKS IN
STATUTE IS ESSENTIALLY ALL.
CRAZY BUT IT'S JUST BASICALLY.
IF YOU IF YOU COLLECT REVENUES
TO SUPPORT A PARTICULAR
ACTIVITY YOU HAVE TO USE THAT
MONEY ON THOSE THINGS SO FOR
EXAMPLE WE COLLECT REVENUES FOR
DORMS WHICH REVIEW. YOU CAN
ONLY USE THEM FOR DORMER HOUSE
STUDENT HOUSING. THESE WHAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT- MAYBE
NOT IMMEDIATELY- WE'RE STILL
ANALYZING ALL OF OUR OPTIONS
AND- CASH FLOW ON ART. HISTORY
PROGRAMS BY CAMPUS- SO THERE'S
A LOT OF YOU KNOW TWENTY THREE
TIMES. ALL THE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT MEDICATIONS THAT CAN
OCCUR. BUT WE DO ANTICIPATE
THAT AT SOME POINT IN THE
FUTURE IF CONDITIONS PERSIST
THAT WE MAY HAVE TO. YOU
REALIZE SOME MONIES THAT MIGHT
BE. WE MIGHT HAVE MORE RESERVES
SAY MAYBE IN PARKING AND MAYBE
SHIPPED IT TO HOUSING TO HELP
SUPPORT HOUSING. TEMPORARILY OR
IF OR YOU KNOW TWO DIFFERENT
FUNDS IN THAT WAY SO THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THAT
FLEXIBILITY IS TRYING TO DO IS
JUST HAVE THAT TOOL AT OUR
DISPOSAL LIKE I SAID IN MY
COMMENTS WE DON'T THINK THAT WE
NEED TO UTILIZE IT RIGHT AWAY-
BUT WE THINK THAT IF THE
PROJECTIONS ARE CORRECT THEY
WERE ENOUGH FOR YOUR- REALLY
BAD TOUGH. BUDGET SITUATION WE
REALLY ANTICIPATE THAT OF ALL
OF OUR CAMPUSES ALL THOSE
VARIOUS PROGRAMS THAT WE WILL
RUN INTO A SITUATION WHERE WE
DO NOT HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS-
DEFICIENCIES IN THOSE AREAS.
THANK YOU BEFORE I TURN IT OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE SAID. FOR
QUESTIONS PERHAPS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MAY WANT TO COMMENT ON-
THE LAST POINTS ON RESTRICTED
FUNDS. OR ANY OF THE OTHER
ITEMS SO TOUCHED ON BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
REPRESENTATIVES. YEAH CHRIS
FERGUSON WHAT. FIRST. OF YOUR
GUN. SOUND. YES RIGHT. OKAY.
CAN HE SEE US. YEAH. I WISH I
COULD READ LIPS. AND EATEN. IN
THE TENTH DAY OF THE NIGHT.
WITH LIKE A BOSS OF MINE. HELLO
YEAH. SORRY IT MUST HAVE BEEN
GOOD LOOKS GOOD- WE HEARD AGAIN
YOU CERTAINLY CAN SO. I THINK
WE'RE YOU KNOW CHRIS FERGUS
WITH FINANCE WE'RE CERTAINLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE LANGUAGE THAT
WE PUT FORWARD- WITH THE USE OF
RESTRICTED FUNDING. TO HELP
COLLEGES MITIGATE THE IMPACTS-
CODE NINETEEN THEIR SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE WITHIN THE YEARS TO
RESTRICT FUNDING THAT DIRECTS
THE UNIVERSITY'S MCALLISTER
FIRST USE THAT FUNDING. TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS TO OUR
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENT
POPULATIONS BOTH IN TERMS OF
SERVICES PROVIDED TO THEM AND
IN ACCESSING THE UNIVERSITY. AT
THE UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES.
WERE ALSO OPEN TO A
CONVERSATION ON PROVIDING SOME
FLEXIBILITY WHEN IT COMES TO.
THE USE OF BY- NEED DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDING BALANCES.
WHAT WE CERTAINLY DO THAT- YOU
KNOW MORE IN LIGHT OF PROVIDING
RIGHT OR AT LEAST THE
CONVERSATION MORE IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
THE UNIVERSITIES TO USE
EXISTING RESOURCES. AS OPPOSED
TO TRENDING PROPOSED REDUCTIONS
SO. OPTION FOR ALL GOING IN
NATURE. AND WE REMAIN CAN ABOUT
THE I'LL HERE IN. FOR THE STATE.
CHRIS THE PROBLEM DEALING WITH
IS THESE ARE ALL UNCHARTED-WATERS. I THINK YOU'D AGREE WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH FEDERAL
FUNDING WE'RE GOING TO RECEIVE
WE DON'T PROBABLY REALLY KNOW.
HOW MUCH REVENUE WE'RE GOING TO
RECEIVE AS A STATE SO IT'S
SEVEN. IT'S SORT OF A GUESSING
GAME BUT YOU'RE DOING A GREAT
JOB AND I APPRECIATE THOSE
COMMENTS. TELLING ANY QUESTIONS
THE LEVEL OF FEDERAL. OKAY
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION LET'S MOVE ON TO
OUR FINAL- DISCUSSION ITEM
ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTY WHICH
IS FINANCIAL AID REDUCTIONS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HELLO
AGAIN BRIANNA'S FRIENDS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M
MOVING ON TO THESE COMPANIES DO
NEED COMMISSION AND FINANCIAL
AID THE MAYOR VISION IT
MAINTAINS ALL FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS FOR PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION. WITH ONLY TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS. IN A CONTINUING
EFFORT TO BALANCE THE BUDGET
AND FACILITATE BUDGETARY
RESILIENCY MAYOR RICHARD
REMOVES MOST OF THE NEW
PROPOSALS PROVIDED GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. WILL FALL IN THE- WE'VE
BEEN. FOR IN ADDITION THE
FOLLOWING REDUCTIONS ARE
PROPOSED. EIGHTY EIGHT POINT
FOUR MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND PROVIDED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT TO SUPPORT
THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM. FIFTEEN MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND PROVIDED IN
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
TO SUPPORT THE CHILD SAVINGS
ACCOUNT GRANTS PROGRAM. FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO REVISE THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE STUDENT DEBT
LOAN WORKGROUP AND OUTREACH TO
ONLY SUPPORT THE WORKGROUP AND
NO LONGER PROVIDE OUTREACH. AND
FOUR MILLION FOR THE UC AND
EXPLAIN TO THE CS UNITS APART
SUMMERTIME FINANCIALLY. IN
ADDITION THE MAY REVISION
REDUCES THE MAXIMUM CAL GRANT
AWARD FOR PRIVATE NONPROFIT
INSTITUTIONS FROM NINE THOUSAND
EIGHTY FOUR DOLLARS TO EIGHT
THOUSAND FIFTY SIX DOLLARS.
REFLECTED AS AN EIGHT POINT
NINE MILLION ON GOING GENERAL
AND DECREASE. AS SPECIFIED BY
CURRENT LAW THE MAXIMUM HOW
GRAND IT JUST MEANT IS APPLIED
WHEN REQUIRED EMISSION LEVELS
FOR STUDENTS WITH ASSOCIATES
DEGREES FOR TRANSFERS ARE NOT
ACHIEVED. FIRST DOT YOU SHOULD
THE PRIVATE NONPROFIT
INSTITUTIONS MEET THEIR
SPECIFIED TRANSFER GOALS THE
AMOUNT OF THE GRANTS WILL
INCREASE AGAIN. I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HELLO. YEAH WE WOULD
LIKE TO SAY THAT UNLESS OFFICE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
SHARED THE COMPANY'S MARRIAGE
AND LARGELY RETAINS FUNDING FOR
ONGOING FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM.
PRODUCE A PRETTY SPECIFIC
PURPOSES THAT ARE COVERED
INITIATED HERE JOHN DOT. ONE IS
RELATED TO SOME FINANCIALLY YOU
SCENES YES YOU AND THE OTHER IS
RELATED TO THE KIND AWARD
AMOUNT OF PROSTITUTION. THESE
PROGRAMS PRIMARILY SUPPORT
STUDENTS WITH FINANCIAL NEED.
AND AS A GENERAL COMMENT WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
PRIORITIZE NEED BASED FINANCIAL
AID PROGRAMS. AS THEY'RE LIKELY
MORE ACTIVITY INCREASING
COLLEGE ACCESS AND NOT NEED
BASED PROGRAMS. THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS ISSUE
WHAT SHALL SENIOR GENDER.
RECOMMENDATION IS REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED REDUCTIONS
FOR THESE TWO PURPOSE AS AN
INSTRUCTOR FIVE ONE TIME
FUNDING TO SUSTAIN THEM JAN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. I
WOULD CONSIST OF SIX MILLION
FOR CSU INFORMALLY INCREASE
HEAT TO MAINTAIN SUMMER
FINANCIAL AID. AS WELL THE
POINT NINE MILLION FOR THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION TO
pMAINTAIN THE CURRENT MAXIMUM
AWARD AMOUNT A PRIVATE
NONPROFIT COLLEGES. THANK GOD
WE HAVE TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
ZERO THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH- IN
THE NINETEEN TWENTY UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA HAD RECEIVED FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
SUMMER UP FINANCIAL AID FOR OUR
STUDENTS WE UTILIZE THAT BY
PROVIDING- ABOUT TWO POINT SIX
MILLION OF IT LAST SUMMER AND
WE ARE SET TO PROVIDE ANOTHER
ONE POINT THREE MILLION FOR
THIS COMING SUMMER UP THE
FINANCIAL AID WAS PROVIDED TO
CAMPUS SAYS BASED ON THE NUMBER
OF CALGARY AND RECIPIENTS THOSE
CAMPUSES HAVE IN ORDER TO HAVE
THE STATE. FUNDED SUMMER AID
SHIRT AND A BIT LIKE A CAL
GRANT WHERE IT WOULD GO TO OUR
NEEDIEST STUDENTS UP FOR
MILLION DOLLARS IS ENOUGH TO
PAY FOR PORT THAT CONSUMER
CREDIT. IT WOULD TAKE. AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT INFORMATION.
FIVE SEE IF YOU. YES SENATOR-
BRENT BRAINSTORM ONCE AGAIN- SO
SIX MILLION DOLLARS WAS
PROVIDED TODAY CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY- TO DATE WE HAVE-
DEDICATED ABOUT FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO SUMMER
TERM FINANCIALLY. I THINK IT
MAKES IT MAKES SENSE TO THINK
ABOUT THIS PROGRAM IN A COUPLE
OF DIFFERENT WAYS THE FIRST IS
THAT- WHEN- THIS IS THESE ARE
BRAND NEW PROGRAMS AND THEY ARE
ITEMS THAT- WHEN IT COMES TO
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF IT
MAKES SENSE TO SUPPORT
UNIVERSITY OR NOT DIRECTLY- WE
WOULD OBVIOUSLY. SUPPORT OF A
IF THERE'S NOT ENOUGH MONEY TO
GO AROUND BECAUSE WE ARE IN
EXPERIENCING AND- SIGNIFICANCE.
IT WOULD MAKE SENSE FOR BUT
MOST OF THE FUNDING TOWARDS
UNIVERSITY FIRST IN SUPPORTING
OPERATIONS SECOND THING THAT
MIGHT OCCUR OVER THE LONG TERM
AND WE'LL HAVE TO SEE HOW LONG.
THIS YES WE WERE RECEPTION GOES
BUT- AS TIME GOES ON YOU WILL
BE MORE DIFFICULT FOR CAMPUSES.
TO OFFER A SUMMER TERM COURSES.
IN THE GREAT RECESSION. OUR
EXPERIENCE WAS THAT WE DIDN'T
HAVE A LOT OF. FLEXIBILITY IN
TERMS OF DEALING WITH A LOT OF
THAT WHAT WAS AT THAT TIME AND
IT'S THIRTY WERE GENERAL FUND
BEING REDUCED. AT TIMES. IN AS
MANY GAMES SHOULD MEASURE WE-
WE- CURTAILED SIGNIFICANTLY ARE
OFFERINGS DURING A STATE
SUPPORTED SUMMER. KEEP THAT IN
MIND GOING FORWARD WHEN YOU'RE
WHEN YOU'RE DECIDING WHETHER
TO. SUSTAIN THIS PROGRAM OR NOT
THAT AS TIME MARCHES ON- WILL
OBVIOUSLY BE. WILLING AND ABLE
TO PROVIDE THAT FINANCIALLY
GETS TO STUDENTS. AS WE'RE ABLE
TO OFFER SUMMER TERM. COURSES
THANK YOU. I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
ONLINE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS ALEX GRAVES OF THE ICY CEO-
I HAD PROVIDED A COUPLE OF
SLIDES THAT- AND HAPPY TO
EITHER IS REFERRED TO IN MY
COMMENTS OR TO PULL UP ON A
SHARE SCREEN WHATEVER THE
PLEASURE OF THE COMMITTEE IS
HERE. WELL LET'S SEE WHAT WE'RE
ABLE TO DO. PUT HIM UP ON THE
SCREEN. IF YOU CAN TRY THAT
LET'S WORK TO THAT- OKAY THAT
LOOKS LIKE IT'S DISABLED FOR ME
IT'S ALL ALL- I'LL JUST REFER
TO SOME OF THIS IS I WALK
THROUGH MY COMMENTS THAT'S FINE
THANK YOU. ALEX GREAT WITH. YOU
ANYWAY SO THERE YOU GO. WE ARE
PERCENT EIGHTY FIVE NONPROFIT
COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES IN THE
STATE- THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY I
JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY SPEAK
ABOUT THE PROPOSED CAL GRANT
CUT OF MORE THAN A THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS
WHO ATTEND ONE TO ATTEND OUR
INSTITUTIONS- THE STUDENTS HAVE
TREMENDOUS NEED AND REDUCING
THEIR AWARD UNDERMINES SHARED
GOALS FOR INSTITUTIONS THE
STATE LEGISLATURE. AROUND
HIGHER EDUCATION ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY COMPLETION
INEQUITY. WE AGREE THAT THE
STATE SHOULD BE PRIORITIZING IT
SLOWING COME UP UNDER
REPRESENTED STUDENTS RIGHT NOW
AND LOOKING AT THE MORE THAN
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND KILOGRAMS
STUDENTS ATTENDING OUR
INSTITUTIONS ARE SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY COMPARABLE TO
THEIR PEERS ATTENDING A UC OR
CSU. AFTER FIRST GENERAL
COLLEGE STUDENTS 47% ARE
LATINO. AND THE AVERAGE FAMILY
INCOME THE STUDENTS IS LESS
THAN FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. IF
APPROVED THIS CAT WOULD MAKE
THE CAL GRANT AWARD WORTH 17%
LESS THAN IT WAS IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE. OVER THAT SAME
TIME PERIOD FOR COMPARISON
DEKALB GRANT AWARD LEVEL FOR
STUDENTS ATTENDING A CSU WAS
INCREASED A HUNDRED NINETY TWO
PERCENT. I AM FOR STUDENTS
ATTENDING UC IT'S INCREASED
2210026% THE UNDERLYING POLICY
AND STATUTE THAT PERMITS THIS
CAT. HAS TO DO WITH THE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
TARGETS WHICH I'D LIKE TO
BRIEFLY SPEAK ABOUT AND MY APPS
LIES THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE. A
WALK THROUGH THAT. IF YOU LOOK
AT THE TIME LINE WHICH IS
SLATED TO- YOU'LL SEE THAT
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF WORK
DONE IN A RELATIVELY SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME. SINCE THE
AGREEMENT WAS REACHED IN THE
SUMMER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN- YOU
KNOW A FEW MONTHS LATER THAT
FALL WE HAD THIRTY OR
INSTITUTIONS YOU'VE GOT
ARTICULATED PATHWAYS AND BEGAN
ACCEPTING. AT EIGHTY T.
APPLICATIONS- JUST A SHORT TIME
LATER. AND WHAT WE SEE NOW AS
OF THIS PAST FALL. IF WE DON'T
HAVE THIRTY NINE INSTITUTIONS
THAT ARE PARTICIPATING WITH
ARTICULATED PATHWAYS ACROSS ALL
THIRTY SIX EIGHTY MAJORS. AND
SO THE FACT TODAY IS THAT THE
MAJORITY OF EIGHTY
PARTICIPATING INSTITUTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OR A. I. C. C. O. S.
T. SHINS AND KNEES PROVIDE
TREMENDOUS REGIONAL ACCESS FOR
TRANSFER STUDENTS. ON THE NEXT
FLIGHT JUST GIVES YOU A
SNAPSHOT. OF OUR PARTICIPATING
INSTITUTIONS BROKEN DOWN BY
REGION- AND SLIDES FOR GIVES
YOU A SENSE OF WHAT ARE CALLED
DATA ALL TWENTY NINETEEN EXCUSE
ME COLLECTION LOOKS LIKE-BUT
I'D LIKE TO TURN TO SLIDE FIVE-
WHICH GIVES YOU. THE THREE
REPORTING PERIODS AND THE
TRENDS WE'VE SEEN- AND I WANT
TO SAY YOU KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN
CHALLENGES IN IMPLEMENTING THIS
PROGRAM THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT
THAT. YOU'RE CREATING THESE
PATHWAYS IN THE TRAINING AND
TIME NEEDED ACROSS MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS AT THE
INSTITUTIONAL LEVEL. FOR STAFF
TO IDENTIFY AND COLLECT THIS
DATA AS WELL AS INCREASING THE
AWARENESS OF THESE PATHWAYS FOR
STUDENTS. THE WHAT I THINK
YOU'LL SEE THERE IS THERE'S
BEEN. A SIGNIFICANT GROWTH IN
YEAR TWO IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER
OF EIGHTY STUDENTS EXPECTED.
ARE THE NUMBER OF PARTICIPATING
INSTITUTIONS. OUT CERTAINLY. AT
THE NUMBER OF PARTICIPATING SO
THAT THAT AGAIN ARE ON THESE
BUT NOT RECEIVING ANY
APPLICANTS HAS GONE DOWN
SIGNIFICANTLY- WELL WE'VE SEEN
THE NUMBER OF INSTITUTIONS ARE
RECEIVING OUTLOOK AND STUBBLE-
IN JUST A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
AND YOU KNOW THIS. I WOULD ADD
THAT THIS METRIC- IN STATUTE IS
ONLY EIGHTY TWO TRANSFER
STUDENTS IT'S NOT ACCOUNTING
FOR OTHER TRANSFER STUDENTS.
THAT ARE COMING TO OUR
INSTITUTIONS THROUGH OTHER
LOCAL ARTICULATION AGREEMENTS
STAR SECTOR REMAINS COMMITTED
TO PROMOTING AND GROWING
TRANSFER PATHWAYS SUCH AS EACH
KEY WHICH YOU CAN PROVIDE SOME
REALLY IMPORTANT- TRANSFER
PATHWAYS TO BE FINE STUDENTS
ARE REALLY UTILIZING. AT THE
REGIONAL LEVEL I'M IF YOU LOOK
AT THE LAST COUPLE OF SLIDES
YOU'LL JUST SEE SOME EXAMPLES
OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
INSTITUTIONS AND HOW THOSE
TRANSFER PATHWAYS. ARE
FUNCTIONING ON THE GROUND.
FUNDAMENTALLY YOU KNOW WE
BELIEVE THAT THE TRENDS WE SEE
IN OUR DATA. SUGGESTS THAT THE
PROGRAM IS IMPROVING AND
UNDERSCORES OUR SECTORS
COMMITTED TO THIS. AND WE THINK
THE RIGHT NOW IS EXACTLY THE
WRONG TIME TO PULL THE TRIGGER
ON CAT MORE TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO THE STUDENTS. WE
BELIEVE THE BENEFIT OF YOU KNOW
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
SAVINGS BUT THIS WILL BE
GENERATED BY THIS NOT FIFTY
FIVE OR SO BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT. ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
OVERSHADOWED BY THE ADVERSE
IMPACTS OF 11% CUT FOR THE
STUDENTS- SO IN CLOSING I JUST
SAY THAT WE APPRECIATE
RECOGNISE THE SITUATION STATE
FINDS ITSELF AND- RESPECTFULLY
BELIEVE THAT THIS CATCH NOT BE
IMPLEMENTED THIS YEAR- AND WE
URGE YOU TO BE REJECTED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS I JUST HAVE A COUPLE
COMMENTS AND THEN I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO MICHAEL ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE AND I'LL- TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES I MEAN
I. I HAVE TO SAY THAT GIVEN THE
STRUCTURAL AND OTHER
DIFFERENCES. BETWEEN THE
NONPROFIT. PIRATE COMMUNITY AND
OUR CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AND UC I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
WE USE THE SAME PROGRAM AND
APPLY THE SAME STANDARDS FOR
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES THAT WE USE FOR
THE UC IN THE UC SYSTEM I MEAN
THIS THIS CONCEPT OF ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER AT
STANDARD. BUT IT. THE CARD IS.
TO HAVE A SYSTEM TO SYSTEM
APPLICATION AS OPPOSED TO A
SYSTEM TO AN INDIVIDUAL COLLEGE
UNIVERSITY I WOULD SEEM TO ME
IT WOULD BE VERY VERY
DIFFICULT. TO IMPLEMENT THIS
EFFECTIVELY ACROSS THE SECTOR
WHEN YOU HAVE A SYSTEM IN THIS
CASE THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM. NEGOTIATING AND
DEALING DIRECTLY WITH
INDIVIDUAL COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. AND WHEN THE
STANDARD THAT WE APPLY FOR THE
BUDGET PURPOSES. IS A SECTOR
WIDE STANDARD IT'S ESSENTIALLY
AN AVERAGE. I DON'T SEE WHY ANY
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL COLLEGE
OR UNIVERSITY WOULD HAVE AN
INCENTIVE TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF TRANSFER STUDENTS.
AND CONVERSELY HOW THAT
INDIVIDUAL COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY WHO IS INTERESTED IN
DOING SO. COULD POSSIBLY IMPACT
THE RESULT. TO PROVIDE FOR AN
INCREASE IN CAL GRANTS SO YOU
KNOW I THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS- AND IF
THE GOAL IS TO HAVE MORE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFER
STUDENTS WHO ATTENDED- THESE
NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS IN ORDER
TO GET THE HIGHER TELL GRANT
WARD. I THINK WE HAVE TO
DISCUSS. THE STANDARD THEY WERE
APPLYING IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE BECAUSE THE SAME STANDARD
THAT WE APPLY TO SEE ISSUE AND
YOU SEE. IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT
STANDARD TO APPLY I THINK NOT
BEING A EDUCATOR. IN THIS NON
FOOD WORLD BUT LET ME- MISS
GRACE LET ME QUESTION DO WE- DO
WE HAVE A LOT. TO MANY
COMMUNITY CUP TRANSFER STUDENTS
BUT IN THE PROPERTY. AND
UNIVERSITY WHAT. TO WHAT OMING
IN THEN IT SAYS. THREE YES HE'D
PREFER TO. BURNING ELSE. YEAH
THANK THANKS FOR THE CALL THAT
IN THE COMMENTS YES THERE'S A
FEW DIFFERENT DATA SOURCES THAT
YOU YOU COULD LOOK AT- THERE'S
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE DATA MART-
THERE'S ALSO THE NATIONAL
STUDENT CLEARINGHOUSE THEN WE
ALSO. THE ICC YOU DO AN ANNUAL
SURVEY. SO THERE'S SOME
VARIATION DEPENDING WHICH
NUMBER YOU LOOK AT THAT BUT WE
WOULD SAY THERE IS THERE
SOMEWHERE IN THE RANGE OF ABOUT
SEVENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX
HUNDRED- NEW TRANSFER STUDENTS-
ENROLLING AT EACH YEAR. ONE
HUNDRED ASIAN WHICH WHICH WAY
YOU'RE MEASURING AND WHICH DATA
SORCERY I WOULD SUGGEST THAT IF
THE GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE A PATHWAY FROM
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. TO THESE NON
FOR COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
AND THAT IN FACT THEY'RE TAKING.
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
TRANSFER STUDENTS I THINK WE
OUGHT TO AT LEAST START
COLLECTING THE RAW DATA SO WE
HAVE SOME DEFINITE DATA POINT
AS TO HOW MANY. COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TRANSFER STUDENTS ARE
ACCEPTED EACH YEAR. A SECTOR
WIDE AND BY INDIVIDUAL COLLEGE
AND UNIVERSITY AND IF. IF AS A
MATTER OF STATE PUBLIC POLICY
WE WANT TO REWARD THOSE WHO
TAKE THOSE TRANSFER STUDENTS
AND- DISINCENTIVE EYES THOSE
WHO WERE REFUSING TO DO SO THEN
MAYBE WE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT.
OUR CAL GRANTS SYSTEM AND SEE
IF THERE'S SOME WAY WE CAN
DESIGN IT TO DO THAT BUT- THE
CURRENT SYSTEM. THIS SEEMS LIKE
A HAM FISTED WAY TO DEAL WITH
THE SITUATION TO ME BUT ANYWAY.
COMMENTS EXACTLY JOHN THIS.
ISSUE EIGHTY OF OUR PRESENTERS
SEVERAL. SEEING NONE THAT
CONCLUDES THE DISCUSSION ITEMS
IN PART BE. WE'RE GOING TO
PROCEED TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT I
WOULD NOW INVITE LIKE TO INVITE
THE PUBLIC WANTING TO PROTEST
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO DO SO TO
CALL AND NOW. PLEASE DIAL THIS
TOLL FREE NUMBER.
1-877-336-4441 THAT'S ONE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. THREE SIX THREE
THREE SIX EXCUSE ME FOUR FOUR
FOUR ONE. AND WHEN PROMPTED
PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS CODE.
788-506-0788. FIVE ZERO SIX
ZERO. LET'S BEGIN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD AGAIN WE WILL
TAKE COMMENT REGARDING ANY OF
THE ITEMS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
INCLUDING THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AT THE BEGINNING OF YOUR
COMMENTS THAT WILL BE FULL IF
YOU CAN IDENTIFY. THE ISSUE
FROM TODAY'S AGENDA THE CHECK
WRITING PROPER NON OBVIOUSLY AS
WELL AS YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING  LOT OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS THAT WE HAVE TO APPLY
HERE. COMMITTEES WILL INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY AND I
INTEND TO DO THAT TODAY.
ACCORDINGLY EACH PERSON
PROVIDING COMMON WILLBE
PERMITTED. AT LEAST AT THIS
POINT. A TOTAL OF ONE MINUTE WE
WILL HAVE TO SEE WHAT THE
LENGTH OF THE- LINE IS BOTH.
TEAMS AND ON THE PHONE. WELL
BEGIN WITH NY WITNESSES HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO PLEASE
IDENTIFY. OF COURSE YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION AND ANY ITEM
YOU WISH TO PROVIDE COMMENT ON.
SIR CINEMATIC WOMAN MADE A
PIECE IN THE PISSING BE WITH
YOU. MY NAME IS MENTALLY I'M F.
I AM A PROFESSOR EMERITUS AT.
SACRAMENTO STATE. AND I'M ALSO
THE FOUNDER OF SALAMI CEMEX
CENTER ACROSS FROM THE AMERICAN
RIVER COLLEGE. I'M HERE TODAY
TO SPEAK AGAINST INSERTING THE
AGE CAP OF TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
OLD. I AM IN THAT IN THE MAIN
SECTION. A LOT AND THEY MADE A
VISION. THE YEAH I. ARE
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOLS. USE
A FEW CLASSES OF OUR
FACILITIES. AND GO IN THE
COMMUNITY CENTER TO TEACH
ENGLISH TO THE REFUGEES AND
IMMIGRANTS. R. O. IN ORDER TO
HELP HIM ASSIMILATE INTO
SOCIETY AND BE ACTIVE CITIZENS
REMOVE DNA IT IS LEAVING THIS
KIND OF A CAB. I WOULDN'T.
CONTINUE HAVING THOSE OLDER
STUDENTS- IN WE FEARED AND
AMERICA AND ALSO IN HANDOUTS BY
THE AT PLACES OF WORSHIP AS AN
EDUCATOR HI H. ID MOVING THAT
CAB. IN ORDER FOR THOSE
STUDENTS TO REALLY GET
EMPLOYMENT AND BE ACTIVE-
CITIZENS IN THE COMMUNITY. AND
OTHER WAYS I BELIEVE THAT D. AT
WAS TENTATIVE COST COULD BE
HIGHER IN THE STATE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU COMMENTS
NEXT ANYONE ELSE IN FORTY TWO
OH THREE. NAME ORGANIZATION
ITEM NUMBER AND ONE MINUTE
PLEASE. HELLO EVERYONE AND GOOD
AFTERNOON. I HOPE WAS A I MEAN
THE CAPTAIN DAN FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS MY NAME IS ADAM. I'M
FROM AFGHANISTAN. I'M LEARNING
ENGLISH AT THE COMMUNITY. AT
HIGHLAND COMMUNITY CHARTER
SCHOOLS HIGHLAND IS IT A STATE.
FOUNDED AT ALL CHARTER SCHOOL.
THAT OFFERS HE IS IN AND THE
HIGHEST COURT. BEFORE I COME TO
HIGHLAND. I CAN'T DO ANY TEAM.
I NEED TO. MEETING GATHERING
WITHOUT A TRANSLATOR HEY LIFE
WANTS TO REALLY HARD FOR ME AS
A SINGLE MOTHER AND THERE WHO
DOES NOT SPEAK ANY ENGLISH LAST
YEAR I AM GOING TO HIGHLANDS.
S. IT CHANGED MY LIFE AND
THERE. ARE A LOT A LOT HI IN
ORDER TO HIGHLANDS VEIN I LOST
FIFTY FOUR YEARS OLD. ONE
HUNDRED IN ONE EAR. I BELONG TO
A STAR. AND I PLAN TO A STAR
ATTENDING HIGH SCHOOL AND GET.
CURRENT DIVVYING HI AT
HIGHLANDS. M. MY GETTING
EASTERLY A FAMINE INDUCING THEM.
COUNTRY INDEPENDENCE LEAVE THE
PMR CHARGED A FEE TO HELP ME.
WITH THE HELP. TO MY SCHOOL AND
TEACHERS. I THINK I CAN DO
EIGHT. PLEASE DON'T TAKE MY
HAIR VERY FOLLOW ME PLEASE OF
COURSE. THE AGE GAP HI CHARTERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO COME DOWN
AND PROVIDE COMMENT ANYONE ELSE
IN. FOUR OH THREE. HELLO MISTER
CHAIR. ALL MEMBERS ON HELLO IF
YOU WANT AND- I REALLY- PULLS
THE H. K. A ON LEARNING MY NAME
IS IN THE JEEP. I AM A STUDENT
AT A TIGHT INCOME WE DO TRY TO
SCREW. AS SOMEONE HI DON'T COME
WITH THE CHARTER SCHOOL IS-
ESTATE FUNDED SCHOOL FOR ADULTS.
IF THE DOOR OFF- YOU KNOW I AM
FIFTY FOUR YEARS OLD ON MY WIFE
IS- FORTY SEVEN YEAR OLD ON THE
REDESIGN INCUBATION IN HEIGHT
AND COMING TO CHART THAT IS
COOL. WE LEARNED ALSO TO INFER
KEEFE TOPICS ARE BOTH HOW TO
LEAVE IN THE UNITED STATES. IF
THE DOOR OFTEN HEIGHT AND
COMPLETELY CHOICE AT A SCHOOL
IN SCHOOLS. AND REMEMBER WE CAN
LEARN ENGLISH WE ARE WE CAN GET
A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA AND C. T.-TRAININGS BY WHO LATER CHRIS
THAT WE BOUGHT I AM TALKING ON
BEHALF DOES SIGNS OF ALL DO
STUDENTS LIKE ME DOES NEED
LEARN ENGLISH HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA- AND C. T. TRAININGS
THANK YOU FOR THAT ERIC THANK
YOU SIR. NEXT NAME ORGANIZATION
ITEM AND ONE MINUTE PLEASE OKAY
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY
NAME IS MARIA PILE I AM A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER WITH HIGHLANDS
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY I AM A WITNESS
TO THE FACT THAT HIGHLANDS IS
CHANGING BECAUSE OF CHANGING
STUDENTS LIVES STUDENTS ARE IN
THEIR FIFTIES YES WE JUST HEARD
OF STUDENTS IN THE FIFTIES AND
I AGAIN I'M TEACHING HIGH
SCHOOL THESE STUDENTS.
INITIALLY WERE UNCOMFORTABLE
DOUBTED THEMSELVES AND NOW THEY
ARE- EARNING THEIR DIPLOMAS
THEY'RE TAKING CERTIFICATE
PROGRAMS AND. RIGHT NOW I HAVE
STUDENTS WHO ARE LOOKING FOR.
HE'S FIFTY THE. YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND I APPRECIATE-
REJECTING THE CAP ON THE H.
THANK YOU THANKS THANKS FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO COME DOWN TO
US YES NEXTER. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS SANDRA SHOT INTO MY
HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER AT
HIGHLANDS COMMUNITY CHARTER
SCHOOL. AND I'M ASKING THAT YOU
ARE REJECTED THAT PROPOSAL
ISSUE ONE EIGHTY ONE- AND THE
REASON IS THAT MY CLASSES FULL
OF STUDENTS WHO ARE OVER THE
AGE OF TWENTY SEVEN. AND WHO
ARE THERE BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE SEX SUCCESS ANYWHERE ELSE.
AND THEY CAME IN NOT BELIEVING
IN THEMSELVES- THEY WERE THERE
AS KIND OF A LAST DITCH EFFORT.
AND THANKFULLY I'VE SEEN MANY
OF THEM GRADUATE I JUST DIDN'T
THE EVENING CLASS AT THE SCHOOL
LAST SUMMER. AND IT HAS GROWN
EXPONENTIALLY AND IT'S BEEN ONE
OF THE MOST AMAZING EXPERIENCES
OF MY LIFE TO SEE THE STUDENTS
COME AND- REALLY NOT SURE THAT
THEY WOULD BE TO SUCCEED. AT
BEING LOCKED OUT OF THE DOOR
WITH. HER HEAD HELD HIGH AND
REALLY HOPE BY YOU ALL ARE ABLE
TO. CONTINUE GIVE THEM THAT
OPPORTUNITY DESPITE WHAT THEIR
AGES BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
AMAZING. TO WATCH THIS
TRANSFORMATION WITHIN
THEMSELVES ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO THINGS LIKE MATH- NO
HE REALLY LIKES THAT AND THEY
WALK OUT KNOWING THAT THEY CAN
DO IT. AND THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE SUCCESSFUL- ON WORD SO I
REALLY HOPE THAT YOU TAKE A I
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AND REJECT.
THE PACKAGE CACHE. THANK YOU.
MENTION TO PROVIDING COMMON MY
REC. IS THAT WE'RE- FOR. THIS
CALL FOR OF THAT. SHORTENS THE
COMMENT PERIOD. SO BE IT ONE
MINUTE PLEASE HI MY NAME IS ALL
RIGHT LET ME OUT AND I'M THIRTY
FIVE YEARS OLD AND- I NEED ONLY
TEN CREDITS WERE FINISHED MY
HIGH MY HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
AND I LIKE TO CONTINUE STARKEY-
OFFICE ADMINISTRATION AND I'M
NOT AGREE WITH THE- H. R. COPY.
IT GOT IT TODAY THE PATIENT I
THINK WE NEED ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY- I HAVE THREE KIDS
AND I WANNA BE LIKE PROF THEY
CAN BE A PROBLEM. FOR ME AND-
MAKE ME- FEEL BETTER FOR A GOOD
A BETTER JOB AND A BETTER LIFE
FOR. ALL OF THE PEOPLE WE ARE
HERE IN SUPPORT I THINK WE CAN
MAKE THE DIFFERENCE. AND TRIED
TO SUPPORT WHEN WE CONTINUE TO
TELL OUR EDUCATE. THANK YOU I
THINK WE AGREE WITH YOU THANK
YOU FOR COMING DOWN NEXT PLEASE.
SENATOR ROB I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW MUCH I PROBABLY APPRECIATED
THAT COMMENT YOU MADE JUST
BEFORE THAT STUDENT WALKED UP
MY NAME IS MIKE REID. I AM THE
CHIEF OPERATIONS OFFICER FOR
HIGHLANDS COMMUNITY CHARTER
SCHOOL AND OF COURSE WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION ABOUT LANGUAGE THAT
TRAILER BUS LANGUAGE. BUT I
THINK ONLY OF CONCERN AT THE
CENTER LATER THAT I HEARD HER
SPEAK UP TODAY I JUST WANT TO
GIVE A FEW MORE STATISTICS IT
WOULD BE I THINK INCREDIBLE FOR
THE PANEL TO UNDERSTAND. 70% OF
OUR STUDENTS ARE WOMEN 62% OF
THESE WOMEN OVER THE AGE OF
TWENTY SEVEN. ALMOST TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED WOMEN. OF THAT ROUGHLY
SIXTEEN HUNDRED OR ENGLISH
LEARNERS 58% OF THOSE HAVE
CHILDREN BETWEEN THE AGES OF
TWO AND FOUR HALF YEARS OF AGE.
THIS EXACT DATA THAT WE USE TO
PUT OUR FULL IS A CERTIFIED CTE
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
PROGRAM IN PLACE. THIS ALLOWS
OUR STUDENTS ACCESS TO FREE
CHILD CARE DAILY SETTING THE
STAGE FOR EARLY LITERACY FOR
THESE FAMILIES THAT ARE SERVED
BY THIS PROGRAM. IN ALL ALMOST
TWO HUNDRED TODDLERS AND PRE
TKT CHILDREN BENEFIT FROM THIS
DAILY. AND IN THREE SHORT YEARS
ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN THE RECIPIENTS. OF
EARLY LITERACY AND LEARNING. IN
ADDITION AS A C. T. PRO. WE
GRADUATING CREDENTIAL TWENTY
FOUR ECD TEACHERS. NOW MAKE A
LIVABLE WAGE. SENATORS AND
SUBCOMMITTEE INSURING NO AGE
CAP ON CHARTER SCHOOLS INSURERS
THIS INCREDIBLE WORK WILL
CONTINUE. THANK YOU WE'RE DOING
PRETTY GOOD ON TIME. NEXT
PLEASE NAME ORGANIZATION AND
ONE MINUTE OR LESS THANK YOU TO
DO MY BEST. MY NAME IS DEANNA
BROWN I'M ALSO A PART OF THE
HIGHLANDS- COMMUNITY CHARTER
PROGRAM I AM ONE OF THOSE FIFTY
PLUS- STUDENTS. OF FIFTY YEARS
OLD PLUS STUDENTS- THAT IS A
PART OF THAT COURSE- I WANT TO
FIRST SAY THANK YOU FOR THE-
PROJECTED RE- REJECTION. OF
THIS PROPOSAL OF THIS AGE GAP I
FEEL THAT- EDUCATION SHOULD NOT
BE LIMITED TO YOUR AGE I THINK
THAT EVERYONE NO MATTER HOW OLD
YOU ARE SHOULD BE ALLOWED. THE
ABILITY TO GO AND GET AN
EDUCATION I MYSELF PERSONALLY
TRIED SEVERAL SEVERAL TIMES IN
MY LIFE TO GET MY HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA AND IT JUST DIDN'T WORK
OUT BECAUSE OF TIME TO SHOP SO.
YOU KNOW LIVE IN TAKING CARE OF
MY FAMILY SO I WAS UNABLE TO DO
IT BOTH. THROUGH THIS PROGRAM
THIS PROGRAM NOT ONLY GAVE ME
THE CONIDENCE TO DO IT BUT
ALSO THE TOOLS AND ALSO WITH
THE CHANCE TO HAVE A CAREER. BY
TAKING UP PART OF THE C. T. E.
PROGRAM. I JUST WANTED TO THIS
EXPRESS TO YOU IMPORTANT THIS
PROGRAM IS TO US AND AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR TAKE ON ANY. CUSTOMER IN.
FORTY TWO THREE. JUST AS A SHOW
OF HOW MANY OTHERS ARE GOING TO
WANT TO TESTIFY IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE WHO HAVE NOT ALREADY
SPOKEN. RAISE YOUR HAND.
PERFECT SIR YOUR OWN NAME
ORGANIZATION ON A SURGE OF ON
YOUR OWN HOUSE CAN YOU TRY IT-
HI THIS COMMUTER SCHOOL
STRUGGLING PROGRAM. AND I
WASN'T PLANNING TO SPEAK TODAY
BUT- THE STUDENT KNOWS
SUPPOSING COUPLE I COULD IT
COULD MAKE IT BECAUSE BECAUSE
OF PINES COMMUNITY CHARTER
SCHOOL- SHE GOTHER HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA. AND SHE GOT A CLASSY
LICENSE IN NOW SHOWS TWO TRUCKS
AND- SHE COULD MAKE IT BECAUSE
SHE'S GOING OVER THE ROAD. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR THANKS
FOR COMING DOWN ANYONE ELSE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE. SEEING NONE
OF THEM. WELL THE SURGEON SEVEN
BUCKS OR ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
COMMENT ON ANY OF THE ITEMS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. OKAY NAME
ORGANIZATION ITEM NUMBER AND
PLEASE LIMIT IT TO ONE MINUTE
OR LESS SIR. EUROPE HELLO MY
NAME IS NICOLAS VAN SANT- I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF HIGHLANDS
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOL IN
REGARDS TO THE AGE CAP THAT
THEY'RE PROPOSING AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT HIGHLANDS- HAS
REALLY CHANGED MY LIFE- IT'S
WAYS I JUST LIKE A MOUSE TO
ATTEND SCHOOL THERE. AND. THIS
REALLY IS JUST TELL ME A LOT-
BEFORE WE WENT TO HIGHLANDS
THAT I'VE BEEN TO PRISON TWICE
AND- BITING GRADUATE HIGH
SCHOOL AND I SPEND THAT AND THE
WITH THE HELP OF HIGHLANDS THEY
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HELP ME. NOT
ONLY GET MY HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
BUT ALSO. HELP ME FIND A JOB-
WELL ARE GOT MY CLASS A LICENSE
AND- ALSO CAREER AND- I REALLY
WANT TO TAKE HIGHLANDS GIVE ME
THE OPPORTUNITY. AND I WOULD
HAVE BEEN I WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY- IT WAS ISLANDS AND
THERE'S A LOT OF STUDENTS THERE
WHO- I WAS ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
YOUNGER STUDENTS THERE I'M
THIRTY YEARS OLD. I WAS
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE YOUNGER
STUDENTS WHO JAMES CLOSING. AND
THAT'S WHY WE WERE THERE WHO
ARE TRYING TO HELP THE
COMMUNITY AND JOIN THE WORK
FORCE AND WITHOUT. IRAN'S
BELIEVE VERY DIFFICULT. TO DO
THAT. AND YES THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS GOOD LUCK TO
YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE NAME
ORGANIZATION. ONE MINUTE PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS JOHN EVANS AND- I
AM AN ELT NAVIGATOR FOR SPANISH
SPEAKING STUDENTS HIGHLANDS
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOL I AM
HERE TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE
RECONSIDER THE AGE CAP- AS AN
EMPLOYEE WHO SEES THE GROWTH
AND THE DREAMS OF MY STUDENTS
COME TO LIFE BOTH OF THEM
BEING- OVER THE AGE OF TWENTY
SEVEN MOST OF THEIR DREAMS OF
AN EDUCATION WAS ALREADY
SNATCHED FROM THEM ONCE IN
THEIR HOME COUNTRY. HAVING IT
DONE TWICE WOULD BE DEVASTATING
WE ALL STARTED SOMEWHERE NO
MATTER THE AGE AND I ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE RECONSIDERTHE AGE
GAP THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. YOU KNOW WE'RE
REJECTING THIS PROPOSAL IN.
KEEPING TE PROGRAM ALIVE SO IF
THAT MATTERS. HE'S MADE GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M MY NAME IS MY
RESULT YEAH I AM THE LEAD ELT
COUNSELOR WITH HIGHLIGHTS
COMMUNITY CHARTER SCHOOL I AM
ALSO HERE TOO OPPOSED TO THE
PROPOSED EACH CAR- AND I AGREE
THAT EDUCATION AND LEARNING
SHOULD NOT BE LIMITED BY AGE.
AND STUDENTS HAVE ALREADY
STRUGGLED SO MUCH AND THEY'RE
REALLY TAKING THE ADVANTAGE OF
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE OFFER
AND THAT NOT HAVING THAT WOULD
BE DEVASTATING TO THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING OUR B. AND
SUPPORTING US AND THE I'M- H.
CAP AND- THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
TIME THANKS FOR COMING DOWN
NEXT PLEASE. ONE MINUTE PLEASE.
THE WIRE RETIRED AS THE DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDNT TWIN RIVERS
UNIFIED I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
MAKING THE DECISION ON THE AGE
CAP I WAS THE ADMINISTRATOR OF
CHARGE WHEN THIS BECAME
AUTHORIZED IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN I WAS 1100% AGAINST.
THE CHARTER AND THE FUNDING FOR
IT. HOWEVER I WAS WRONG AND IT
IS DOING A GREAT JOB IT'S DOING.
FIND A WONDERFUL THING FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. AND YOU'RE DOING THE
RIGHT THING BY SUPPORTING- THAT
NOT SUPPORTING THE AGE CAP. AND
I DO BELIEVE THAT YOU'RE GOING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
CONTINUE THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
THE FUTURE THANK YOU SIR NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOUR BODY LIKE I
THINK ON THE LAST SO- MY NAME
IS MIKE SMITH AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR HOUSE
COMMITTEE CHARTER SCHOOL. HELLO
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
BUT ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE TODAY. ON THIS
HUNDRED FIFTY SECOND
ANNIVERSARY OF MEMORIAL DAY. MY
PARENTS TAUGHT ME ABOUT SERVICE
THEY MET IN THE KOREAN CONCERT
MY MOM WAS A- AIR FORCE NURSE
MY DAD WAS MEAN FIGHTER PILOT.
AND I THINK THIS BEING MY
SECOND CAREER AFTER TWENTY
YEARS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT. DOING
THIS IS BEEN A LIFE CHANGING
EVENT YOU'VE HEARD A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND I WOULD WELCOME YOU
TO COME VISIT OUR SCHOOL WHERE
MANY SCHOOLS LIKE OURS AND- AND
GIVE US YOUR OPINION AND
GUIDANCE BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE
PART OF THAT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SOLUTION ONE OF THE
EARLY CHILD EDUCATION OR LITTLE
WAYS CAREER HIMSELF. THANK YOU
FOR TAKING TIME AND SUPPORTING
US TODAY. AND I HOPE YOU'RE
ABLE TO GET SOME TIME TO ENJOY
THE- HOLIDAY YOURSELF THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME AND FOR YOUR COMMENTS
ANYONE ELSE IN TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE LET'S SORT OF. MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ANY OF THE ITEMS RECOMMENDED
ITEM THAT YOU WERE COMMENTING
ON OBVIOUSLY AND YOUR NAME.
CERTAINLY LADIES JEMMA PHONE
LINES IF YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY
DONE SO YOU MAY PLACE YOURSELF
INTO THE QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. WE WILL START WITH ONE
NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN ONE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
YOU'RE YOUR OWN PLEASE NAME
ORGANIZATION ARE NOT WONDERFUL.
MR MEMBERS BEVERLY YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE CPU IT JOINT
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN UW AND AT
B. I. U. ON ISSUE NINE WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED THE 10%
DECREASE YOUR RATE WE
APPRECIATE THAT OUR LABOR
COMMENT THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS WORK AROUND THIS ISSUE
BUT YOU CAN PAY FOR A WORKFORCE
READY MAKING LOW WAGES WELL
THEY HAVE TO INCREASE. WILL
LEAD TO PERMANENT CLOSURES OF
MANY FAMILY CHILD CARE HOMES
ESPECIALLY IF IT REOPENS WE
SUPPORT REJECTING THE GROSS
ADJUSTMENT THE DOCKING FILLER
BILL TO ELIMINATE REDUCTION THE
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS SURE IF YOU
CAN WE OPPOSE TAKING ONE
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR MILLION FROM
THE CARE FACTOR THE PLANT THE
STATE GENERAL FUND. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO THE FUNDS. FIRST
BOX BAG. NO NOT LISTED ON THE-
WE OPPOSE THE COW WORKS FOR DA.
BIRTH ONE ME CHILDREN GOING TO
GET THANK. WE THE EMAIL SIX
FAMILY THE WAY FOR. SEVENTY
THREE MILLION EIGHTEEN. WANTED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR TEN
WHAT THE PROPOSED AN- WHICH THE
CORPORATE EXPANSION FOR THE
FUNDING OF FIFTY MILLION
PROVIDED. FOR EMERGENCY BELCHER.
I DON'T IF THEY'RE ON FUNDS FOR
THE PIE PEOPLE LIKE TO ENSURE
THAT THE FUND. OVER A WINDOW
THAT WE NEED MORE PEOPLE HI YOU
GOT YOUR PROVIDERS. AND FINALLY
WE URGE YOU TO EXTEND THE HOLD
HARMLESS. PROVISION THE ONLY
TITLE BY PROVIDERS BUT YOU
TITLE TWENTY TWO. THE ONLY
CHAPTER PROVIDER SUCK WELL FOR
THAT TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL
YEAR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL NOW GO
TO LINE NUMBER NINETY THREE
THAT'S NINE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. REMEMBER ONE MINUTE I CAN.
REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH F. B.
I. U. GOOD CLUB VIRTUALLY FEEL
AGAIN- I MEAN BE SPEAKING TO
THE CAPE YOUR TWELVE PROPOSALS-
BUT I WANNA LINE MY COMMENT THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER ON CHILD CARE-
WE ARE CONCERNED WITH THE CUT
BUT SHE SAID THE RAID AND- THE
CARD SLOT BE THE CHILD OF THE
COW WORKS CUT- ON HE WENT-
JETER TWELVE WE HAVE SOME REAL
CONCERNS WITH. THE PROPOSED
CUTS WE THINK NOW IS NOT THE
TIME WILL BE OPENING THE COMEDY
AND WE KNOW THAT OUR CORPORATE
HEALTHCARE SPENDS ALL COULD BE
REMOVING FUNDING THAT'S NEEDED
FOR THEM TO RE OPEN UNDERSTATES
THE CARE MANNER- ESPECIALLY IF
WE'RE GONNA NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO KEEP KIDS SOCIALLY
DESPERATELY TO PROTECT AFGHAN
GRAHAM- WE WOULD. URGE THAT YOU.
WHICH HI AND FIND. I REVENUE
SOURCES. RIGHT NOW WE LOOKING
AT LITTLE MORE WE SHOULD ALSO
PUTTING OF THE- ON THE BACK OF
THE- THAT RELY ON THE SERVICE.
AND OR OR PRINT THOSE SERVICES
WE ALSO ARE SUPPORTIVE OF. THE
PROPOSAL TO CUT FUNDING FOR.
OTHER EACH STUDENT ALTHOUGH WE
WOULD CONSIDER A
RECONSIDERATION. JUDICIAL
FUNDING TO THOSE STUDENTS HAVE
HIGHER NEED- WE THINK THAT
THOSE ARE THE THREE THINGS- AND
AT HOME LEARNING THAT THERE IS.
MORE RESOURCES NEEDED FOR THE
STUDENT POPULATION AS THEY ARE
STRUGGLING AND FALLING BEHIND
MORE SO THAN THEIR PEERS- WE
ALSO WOULD. URGE CONSIDERATION
OF ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR ON
DIRECTLY FOR CLEANING THERE WAS
SOME POINT IN THE UNUSUAL A. B.
EIGHTY NINETY ONE SEVENTEEN
THAT TARGETED CLEANING AND THEN
IT WAS. BROADENED TO INCLUDE
FOUR DIFFERENT LEARNING AND A
LOT OF MONEY TO GO WHERE NEEDED
TO AND WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT A
PANDEMIC THAT PREDICATED. ON HE-
WE THINK THAT INVESTING IN.
CUSTODIANS AND I BACK IN CLEAN
BIRD IS THAT THE TO HAVE. BEEN
CLEAN COAL WE ALSO MADE YOU TO
BY LABOR COSTS BY EMPLOYEES
SUMMER. PROGRAM AND WE THAT THE
WORKER AREN'T. HAVE JOBS THIS
SUMMER AND COULD BE DIFFICULT
FOR THEM TO WORK ELSEWHERE THE
THINKING THAT THAT IS THE
CENTRAL COMMAND AND IT WILL BE-
OUT OF FIND. HERE BEING KILLED.
THANK YOU YOU WERE A BIT OVER
MR MODERATOR CAN YOU GIVE ME A
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE. WAITING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. MANY
SAY LOOKS LIKE ABOUT SEVENTY
FIVE. OKAY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF SEVENTY FIVE PEOPLE ON THE
PHONE SO IF EVERYONE TAKES
THREE OR FOUR MINUTES AND
SOMEONE'S GOING TO GET CUT OFF
AT THE END. SO THINK ABOUT
THOSE WHO ARE BEHIND YOU MR
MODERATOR PLEASE THE NEXT. OUR
NEXT LINE IS WHY NUMBER NINETY
EIGHT NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NAME ORGANIZATION UNDER
NEW MR YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE YES
SIR. THANK YOU. AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS A CHANCE
HE'LL HEAR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
BECAUSE HE'D BE CHANCE TO
COMMENT TODAY. THERE'S AN ITEM
IN THE EDUCATION BUDGET THAT
UNFORTUNATELY WASN'T A JAN
DIES- AND IT WOULD NOT ONLY
SHIPPED PROPERTY TAX MONEY AWAY
FROM A HANDFUL OF COUNTIES. IN
AN OBSCURE SITUATION. FOR HER
TO ACCEPT THE RAP. IF ALSO
UNDERSTOOD. HELLO THOSE. BY
SHIFTING FUNDS FROM PREVIOUS
YEARS THAT YOU WOULD IMPOSE
CIVIL PENALTIES ON THE COUNTIES
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THEY
INTERPRET THE LAW YOU COULD
CREATE- AND IT WOULD INSTALL
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT
THE OVERSIGHT BODY. COULD THIS
ONE SPECIFIC ASPECT OF PROPERTY
TAX ALLOCATION. WITH THE
CONTROL OR YOUR OLDER SPECIES
PROPERTY TAX CALCULATIONS AND
HAS EVEN CLEAN AUDIT FINDINGS
FOR THE PROCESSES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN PLACE. WE THINK
THAT SHIFTING FUNDS
UNILATERALLY IMPOSING CIVIL
PENALTIES ON COUNTY YOUR COOK A
GREAT ACTION. AND INSTALLING
SEPARATE OVERSIGHT ENTITY FOR
THIS ONE SINGLE PIECE OF A
COMPLEX. PROCESS RIGHT. WHEN WE
LOOK EXPERTISE IN PART TAXES.
IS ONLY A PRO. AND SO WE WOULD
URGE. THE LEGISLATURE TO REJECT
THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU ABOUT ALIGN
NUMBER NINETY NINE NINE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE MINUTE
THEY'RE ABOUT YOU BUT THAT.
ABOUT THE BUT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS ON ITEMS ONE THROUGH
EIGHT WE MUST RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF PRIOR TAKING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR
STUDENTS AND STAFF WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR RECOGNIZING PUBLIC
EDUCATION IS CRITICAL TO RE
OPENING THE ECONOMY. WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GRAPPLE WITH THE
REDUCTIONS OF UP YOUR BATH AND
THE DEFERRAL COMBINED WE
BELIEVE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ME TO GATE B. ON REAL LEVELS OF
REDUCTION. IN JUST ONE CRITICAL
YACHT LET ALONE WINNING BACK
PUBLIC. HI HI AT LEARNING MODEL
TO SUPPORT THE FLEXIBILITY TO
DO INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES THE
LENGTH OF TIME IN EIGHTY EIGHT
HOLD HARMLESS IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND ITEM SIX
WE SUPPORT VALLEY I STOP
RECOMMENDATION REDISTRIBUTING
THAT. TWO POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLAR FEDERAL FUNDS TO ALL LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AFTER YOUR
CONTINUOUS. LEARNERS ABOUT
MICHAEL GRANT SUPPORT ON ITEMS
THAT. WE IN ORDER TO. YOU
SERVICE THE BANK MUST BE. TO
ALL OUR- AS WE GROW WITH HOW
OPEN SCHOOLS. AND ON THE EXTENT
EUROPE. IF THE ALLEGED. DOES
NOT OCCUR LET ME REVISE
PROPOSAL THAT'S A THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PER YEAR
REDUCTION TO PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT WITH ANY WITHOUT ANY.
STATE BACKFILL AND IT'S
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT ALL
COUNTIES ARE PAIN THERE DO YOU
PRAY- ACCEPT LIABILITY. ON
PROPERTY TAXES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU YOUR VOTE OVER WHAT I WOULD
SUGGEST TO THE CALL TO CALL IN
IS THAT YOU CONCENTRATE ON THE-
OPPOSITION POINTS AND IF THERE
ANY DETAILED COMMENTS THAT YOU
SUBMIT THOSE IN WRITING BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT. FOR YOU TO CONVEY
DETAILED I'M ANSWER SOMEWHAT
COMPLICATED AND CONVOLUTED IN A
ONE MINUTE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
GET SO MR MODERATOR PLEASE THE
NEXT CALLER. THE GOVERNMENT.
CALLERS FROM LINE ONE HUNDRED
ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRANDON ON
BEHALF OF THE INVOICE WE
SUPPORT STREAMLINING THE
FEDERAL HARDSHIP EXEMPTIONS FOR
LOW PROPERTY WEALTHY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COMMUNITY COLLEGES
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS CAN DEMONSTRATE
HARDSHIP BECAUSE OF
INSUFFICIENT PROPERTY TAX
SUPPORT LACK OF CASH FLOW AND
BUYING TOOLS MR CHERRY
APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTIONS ON
THIS ISSUE. WE OPPOSE CHARTER
SCHOOL AGE CAP PROPOSAL FOR THE
LITERACY PROPOSALS WE RECOMMEND
THE FOLLOWING LANGUAGE WHICH
ALLISON LONGSTAFF BE INCLUDED
IN THE TRAILER BELL CONTROLS
ACTION ON EACH ITEM SPENDING
FROM EARLY LITERACY ARE GOING
WHETHER BE TRANSIT OPTIONS
STAFF DEVELOPMENT AND RELATED
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS.
PURSUANT TO THIS ITEM WELL
ACTUALLY READING SHALL BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS ENGLISH LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT FRAMEWORKS
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
SCIENCE BASED STRUCTURED AN
EXPLICIT READING INSTRUCTION
AND LASTLY FOR MICHAEL COLLEGES
I'LL NOTE THAT IF THE PROPOSALS
FAX ELIGIBILITY TO CONTINUE ANY
PRODUCT I'M CURRENTLY APPLIES
TO ENROLLMENT PROGRAM
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN CAGE CALLED.
DISTRICT COLLEGES WE OPPOSE
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH LOOK
TO SET THAT TO US IN WRITING.
NEXT PLEASE ONE MINUTE. BACK
WHY HUNDRED AND THREE ZERO
THREE YOUR IS. CARLOS MARQUEZ
I'M HAPPY CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS IS THAT THEONLINE MY
COM WITH BRAIN INJURY AND ON
HARDSHIP WE ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR SUPPORTING
THE ADMINISTRATION'S CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITY CRACK PROGRAM
PROPOSED LINE ITEM ONE OF THE
APPENDIX REGARDING ISSUES FIVE
AND SIX RELATED TO CODE RELEASE
AND CARADOC BINDING. YET THEY
SUPPORT THE SENATE'S PROPOSED
ALLOCATION METHOD IN A PORTION
TO TOTAL ALTHEA THAT MONDAY
HOWEVER WE REMAIN CONCERNED
ABOUT THE EXCLUSION OF NON
CLASSROOM BASED PROGRAMS WITH
BLENDED BY DATE INSTRUCTION
FROM THE CHARACTER ACTING
AGAINST RATES EARLIER. WE
SUPPORT AN AMENDMENT THAT WE
WILL SHARE WITH YOUR OFFICE WE
SUPPORT YOUR RECOMMENDATION TO
REJECT THE PROPOSED H. CAP ON
CHARTER SCHOOLS ON ITEM ONE
EIGHTY ONE OF THE APPENDIX
REGARDING ISSUE SEVEN WE WOULD
NOTE THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
NOT INCLUDED IN THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISIONS FOR
DISTRICT HEALTH YET THAT AND
FURTHER. THAT HOLDING A LIAISON
WITH THE CURRENT YEAR AT A
LEVEL TO DISPROPORTIONATELY
HARMFUL TO GROWING ALLEY EIGHT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO DISCUSS ON THE ISSUE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AGAIN I THINK IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL IF YOU
CONCENTRATE WE APPRECIATE THE
COMPLIMENTS WHEN YOU SUPPORT US
BUT WE I THINK IF YOU
CONCENTRATE ON YOUR OPPOSITION
IS A GO. FASTER WE HAVE ABOUT
NINETY PEOPLE NINE ZERO ON THE
PHONE LINE SO NEXT IS ONE
MINUTE. OR LESS. CALLERS FROM
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHT ONE ZERO EIGHT TWO LINE
IS UP. HELLO MICHELLE STILL
PREVENTED YOU FROM CONTANGO
WHICH THE NONPROFIT CHILD CARE
PROVIDER ON ISSUE NINE WE ALIGN
OUR COMP WITH THE EASY
COALITION IN OPPOSITION TO THE
PROPOSED RATE CUT. TO THE CHILD
CARE PROGRAM- WHAT OUR WORK
OVER THE LAST ELEVEN WEEKS OF
PROVIDING EMERGENCY CHILD CARE
FOR SOCIAL WORKERS AND
PROVIDING LEARNING NUTRITION
AND MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS FOR
FAMILIES IS REVEALED. IS THAT
WHEN WE REOPEN OUR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. WILL BE COMING TO US
WITH ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES
THOMAS AND NEEDS CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
GOING TO NEED MORE RESOURCES
NOT LAST TO FULLY MEET THOSE
NEEDS MITIGATE THEHARMS OF THE
PANDEMIC AND ENSURE OUR YOUNG
CHILDREN ARE PROTECTED- ON
ISSUE CAN YOU SUPPORT EXTENDING
THE CHILD CARE PROVIDER HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION THAT'S-
RECOMMENDED. UNTIL PROVIDERS
CAN KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
WELL NOW THE LINES HUNDRED AND
SIXTY ONE ONE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS DANNY
MICHELETTI COLBERN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION I WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE
METACOMET AMBITIONS THAT THE
ECB COALITION. FURTHER WE
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
AND LEADERSHIP OF SENATOR LAID
BACK. IN REGARDS ISSUE NINE CAP
REQUESTTHAT YOU REJECT THE 10%
PROVIDER REDUCTION RATE
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE STATE
RECEIVED FEDERAL DOLLARS.
FIGHTERS THAT WILL BE IMPACTED
BY THE 10% REDUCTION ARE
CURRENTLY BEING REIMBURSED AT
TEN TWENTY SIXTEEN RIGHT. AND
DID NOT SHARE IN THE YEARS THE
STATE HAD INCREASED REVENUE.
THE RATE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
CUTTING ON THOSE ON AVERAGE
PROVIDERS ARE FROM TWO SIX TWO
DOLLARS AND SIXTY THREE CENTS
PER HOUR. TO NINE DOLLARS AND
NINETY SIX CENTS PER HOUR
DEPENDING ON WHO'S PROVIDING
THE CARE. WE ALSO ASK THAT YOU
ELIMINATE THE VARIABLE WORK
SCHEDULES FOR FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AS WAS DONE IN
EXECUTIVE ORDER FORTY FIVE
TWENTY. SO THAT PROVIDERS NOW
IN THE MONTH THE CHILDCARE WITH
PROVIDED THAT THEY WILL BE
PAID. FINALLY WE APPRECIATE THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION AND ISSUED
PENN TOOK DOWN THE FIFTEEN
MILLION CURRENT PARKING DECK
OUT YOUR YOUR LINE WITH THE
FEDERAL EXPENDITURE. SHORING UP
CHILDCARE AND BUILD HOW IS.
NEEDED CALIFORNIA ECONOMY TO
RECOVER OUR FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AND VENDORS HAVE
SHATTERED HEAVY CUTS HAVE
SHOULDERED HEAVY CUTS IN YEARS
OF GROWTH- WE ASK FOR YOU TO
MAKE THEM WHOLE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE MINUTE.
THANK YOU WILL GET A LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
ONE TO ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS ENTERTAINMENT
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS- BOND ISSUE- NUMBER SIX.
FOR TUNISIAN FUNDING WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT BY
SENATOR LEYVA TO GET CLARITY ON
THE CARROT ACT FUNDING-
APPRECIATE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AND AREN'T
STRONG SUPPORT I WOULD JUST ADD
IN TERMS OF NEEDING TO MOVE
FURTHER TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUNDING IS FOR MEALS NOT YET
SIR. WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THE
SUMMER- EVEN IN A REGULAR
SUMMER THE BANK AND SCHOOLS-
AND AGAIN WE APPRECIATE ALL THE
HARD WORK THAT'S GOING ON
DURING THE- THIS TIME BUT EVEN
IN A NORMAL SUMMER WE REACH
ONLY ABOUT 15217% OF KIDS THIS
SUMMER HUNGER COULD BE EVEN
WORSE WHEN YOU TARGET THAT
FUNDING WORKING IN MOST. IN
TERMS OF REIMBURSING IT SERVED
ONLY DURING THE SUMMER THANK
YOU. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT ON THE
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OPEN. HEARING NO RESPONSE FROM
MOVEON TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR ONE FOUR FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CHRISTOPHER
SCIENCES WHICH REMOVE THE
COLLISION REMAIN IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND ALSO REPRESENTING
OUR YOUTH ORGANIZATION THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM NETWORK WHICH
IS THE LARGEST IMMIGRANT YOUTH
LED ORGANIZATION IN THE STATE
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOCUMENT IN THE
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS GRADUATE
FROM. CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
EVERY YEAR AND THEY CONTINUE TO
GO INTO EDUCATION WHAT THE
MAJORITY OF THEM ATTENDING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IT IS
CRITICAL THAT THE STATE ACT AND
PROVIDE ADEQUATE SUPPORT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS OVER
SEVERAL. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS PUSHED THE
PRESIDENT ANTI IMMIGRANT AGENDA
BUT BLOCKING FEDERAL FUNDING
GOING TO UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
ALL THIS WHILE WE WAIT FOR A
PENNY DOCTOR DECISION FROM THE
SUPREME COURT. THREE ISSUE
SEVEN RELATED INTERMEDIATE ONTO
A MAJOR DRUG THE GOVERNMENT
REVIEWS. ON ADAMANT FOR THE
GENERATOR VERSION OF THIS ON.
BRIDGE STREET RELATED M. ADULTS.
ARE THE IS CRITICAL GIVEN THE
PENNY THIS IS WITHOUT READY TO
SUPPORT ON GOING ON. AND ALSO
SUPPORT THE TIME DOLLARS THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED. GOING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ISSUE FORTY
NINE RELATED TO TRIM SERVICE.
CENTER AND WE WOULD ASK THE
COMMITTEE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
ONGOING FUNDING. FOR THIS
PROGRAM THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. HE ONE MOMENT WILL
NOW GO NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX ONE FOUR SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MR TURN MEMBERS
WILL BE ABLE TO LEASH ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION. IN REGARDS TO
ISSUE SEVENTY NINE THAT ON PART
B. OF TODAY'S AGENDA YES I AM.
THE PROPOSED 10% GENERAL FUND
REDUCTION TO THE SKI IF YOU ASK
YOU IF YOU DIDN'T GRADUATE.
WILL BE KEEPING GOOD GREAT
ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN ADDITION
IF THEY SUPPORT THE USE OF
RESERVE. BY THIS YEAH IF YOU
OPT TO ANY GENERAL FUND
REDUCTION. ALSO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
ONE STUDENT INSTRUCTION TO
TECHNOLOGICAL TRAINING AND
EQUIPMENT PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT
OF THE RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT
REGARDING ONLINE INSTRUCTION
FOR THE FALL TWENTY TWENTY
SEMESTER. AND THREE
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCESSIBILITY
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO
STUDENT TUITION OR STUDENT FEE
INCREASES. WE WORK LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
GOING FORWARD. SHE THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
EXCELLENT ONLINE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ONE FIVE FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AFTERNOON MY NAME
SAMANTHA WHICH NOW WE ARE
ALIGNED WITH THE EASY BUDGET
COALITION AND THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTERS. FOR THEIR- I WOULD
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROTECT FUNDING
FOR SCHOOLS INCLUDING REJECTING
THE PROPOSED 10% BUT I'LL GET
BACK. AND A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR CONTRACT- SCHOOL
PROGRAM. IN TERMS OF INVESTING
HERE FUNDING WE THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THE FUNKY
EQUITABLY DISTRIBUTED AND WE
ALSO ENCOURAGE SPECIFIC
INVESTMENTS BEING MADE IN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF THE LANGUAGE LEARNERS
AND ENGLISH LEARNERS. AND
FINALLY WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT IT'S CRITICAL TO IT-
INCLUDING THE BUDGET AGREEMENT
THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ALPHABET
TRANSPARENCY AND THE NEED TO
SAFEGUARD COUPLE ALL
CONCENTRATION PLANS. TO ENSURE
THAT THEIR- SERVICE ABOUT THE
COURT- OKAY ON A STUDENT WHO'S
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC LOCAL.
CLOSURES AND THANK YOU NEXT IS.
WE NOW GO TO ONE OF ONE SEVEN
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENT
TODAY MY COMMENTS ARE GONNA BE
IN REGARDS R. EIGHT ISSUE SIX
UPDATE HEARING WE WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS. WE'RE NOT HEARING
YOU. PARDON ME ONE MOMENT HERE.
ONE ONE SEVEN TWO IF YOU WISH
TO QUEUE BACK UP AGAIN YOU'LL
HAVE TO PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO
WE CAN. JUST A MOMENT FAR NEXT
LINE. NOW GO TO LINE. ONE SEVEN
ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE HAD A
REPRESENTING CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THE SUBCOMMITTEE WAS
AWARE OF THE ATI LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUSES BUDGET REQUEST IS IN
THE PREVIEW OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
THE BUDGET REQUEST WOULD
ADDRESS THE DRAMATIC RISE IN
ANTI AGING HARASSMENT YEAH
THEIR COMMUNITIES ARE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING A COOK AT NINETEEN
THE BUDGET REQUEST IS A JOINT
PROPOSAL AMONG COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE ASIAN
AMERICAN STUDIES AND COOKIES AT
BOTH SECTIONS OF THE STATE
UNIVERSITY IN UCLA. A ONE TIME
INVESTMENT WOULD ALLOW
COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO SUPPLY
ITS MEMBERS WITH RESOURCES
EDUCATION AND ACTIONABLE
INFORMATION AND IT WOULD ALSO
ALLOW OUR RECRUITING CENTER TO
HAVE GREATER LANGUAGE
SENSIBILITY IN MULTIPLE ASIAN
LANGUAGES TO COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WHO HAVE BEEN TARGETED FOR
HARASSMENT THANK YOU FOR. YOUR
TIME THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
LINE TWO ZERO EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON LAURA SUBACUTE BEDS
WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS INDEX PROVIDING COMMENT
TODAY ON THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM
EVEN BEFORE CODE NINETEEN
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS STRUGGLED
WITH COLLEGE COSTS AND BASIC
NEEDS AND NEXT I'M GOING TO BE
A DEMOCRAT MADE THINGS FAR
WORSE MOREOVER DURING THE LAST
RECESSION HIGHER ED CUT LIKE A
DOUBLE TUITION AT PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES AND HALF A MILLION
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
TURNED AWAY ALL OF WHICH MAKES
INVESTENT IN HIGHER EDUCATION
AND NEED BASED FINANCIAL AID
AND THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM THE
BASICALLY. ALL THE MORE
CRITICAL IN ENSURING STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO TRULY EQUITABLE
AFFORDABLE COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITIES IN ADDITION THE
SHIELDING COW GRANT FROM CUTS
THAT WOULD DEVASTATE UNDER
RESOURCE CALIFORNIA AND THERE
ARE SEVERAL NARROW REFORM BUT
THE LEGISLATURE CAN ACT TO HELP
PROTECT CURRENT FINANCIAL AID
RECIPIENTS DURING THE CRISIS
INCLUDING EXTENDING THE TIME
PERIOD DURING WHICH ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS CAN RECEIVE THE
TRANSFER ENTITLEMENT HOW GRANT
AND WAITING TO UNITY SERVICE
REQUIREMENT DURING THE MARGIN
THE- RIGHT. GRANT MORE DETAILS
AVAILABLE IN A WRITTEN COMMENT
THAT I COMMITTED SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE ONE
EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE GO. GOOD
AFTERNOON KYLE HYLAND ON BEHALF
OF THE CURRENT TECHNICAL
EDUCATION JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY COALITION HERE TO
SPEAK ON THE ISSUE FOUR AND
THIRTY SEVEN IN REGARDS TO T.
T. FUNDING WE OPPOSE THE
PROPOSED 52% CUT TO THE CORRECT
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AT THAT A
GRANT IN CASE OUR CALL STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM AND FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO PRESERVE THE
THREE MILLION DOLLARS AND I'M
GOING TO KEEP FUNDING FOR
CRITICAL EDUCATION. WE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE ALIENS
RECOMMENDATION TO REPURPOSE
KATE RECALLS ONE MORE COURSE
PROGRAM DOLLARS TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SUMMER BRIDGE
PROGRAM AT KEEP RECALLED THE
TEETH ON IT ALREADY EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION DESPITE A
GROWING INCREASE IN DEMAND FOR
THESE PROGRAMS. BESIDES THE
REDUCTIONS WHATEVER
CATASTROPHIC ATTACK ONCE
DEFEATED CREATES CROSS STATE
LEGAL NUMBER THAT NEED TO CLOSE
THEIR DOORS THIS MONEY COULD
NOT BE LOOKED AT IT AND P. BUT
RIGHT THAN BETTER. THANK AND
TRAIN STUDENTS FOR EMPLOYMENT
THAT IS VITAL TO THE ECONOMY
INCLUDING FIRST RESPONDERS ON
THE FRONT. END AND BACK WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THE ISSUE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINE
ONE NINE. ONE BY ONE NINE LINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE ONE NINE
ONE IS DROPPED JUST A MOMENT
PLACE FOR THE NEXT CALLER. ONE
FIFTY. HI MY NAME IS BRENDA
BROWN I AM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CONTRACTORS AND I'M A TITLE
FIGHT- CENTER BASED AGENCY AND
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
TITLE BY- CONTRACTORS FOR
ISSUES NINE AND WE DO OPPOSE
THOSE RIGHT BECAUSE AND TO
APPRECIATE THE HOLD HARMLESS- I
HAVE BEEN OPENED AND RE
OPENING- SERVING ALL OF THOSE
CHILDREN AND ALL OF THE FAMILY
BACK TO WORK AND THEY DO ASK
THAT THEY ARE NOT LOOKING GOOD
THANK YOU. EIGHT AND WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO BE ABLE TO FOR TO
SERVE THEM AND WE WON'T ABLE TO
THAT. KIND OF HUGE REDUCTIONS
IN OUR CONTRACT THAT TAKE THE
BELOW THE PAST RECESSION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
PLAYING ONE FIFTY FIVE. BY ONE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT PEASE FINE TOLD BLIND
TWENTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
RECTANGLES ON BEHALF OF
ENCYCLOPEDIA BRITANNICA I'M
SPEAKING AND PROBABLY QUITE
QUICKLY TODAY ON THE K. TWELVE
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR SPECIFICALLY
RELATING TO ONLINE RESOURCE
INSTRUCTIONS FOR SCHOOL. VERY
CONCERNED A PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE ONLY COLLECTION
OF DISTANCE LEARNING ONLINE
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
EVERY STUDENT TEACHER AND
FAMILY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ABOUT 92%
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS
DEPEND ON THIS PROGRAM THE
STUDENTS TOTALING MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
SEARCHES. SINCE THE PROGRAM'S
INCEPTION ONLY TWO YEARS AGO HE
TOLD PROVIDE EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO HIGH VALUE CONTENT THE
DISTRICT COULDNOT MAINTAIN ON
THEIR OWN AND SO MUCH MORE THAN
I COULD ARTICULATE IN ONE
MINUTE. WITH THE RECENT
PANDEMIC ACCESS TO DIGITAL
CONTENT IS EVEN MORE VITAL MADE
PARENTS ARE HOMESCHOOLING
STUDENTS ARE BECOMING
ACQUAINTED WITH DISTANCE
LEARNING AND AS A RESULT
RESPOND OR EVEN MORE CRUCIAL
THAN WHEN THE FUNDS.
APPLICATION AN EXAMPLE OF HOW
THAT NEEDED ONLY GROWN IS THAT
A MID SCHOOL CLOSURES USAGE
INCREASED A STAGGERING TWO.
190% WE KNOW THAT IT IS
FEASIBLE TO INCREASE THE FINE
DURING TROUBLED TIMES
ABSOLUTELY. HI THERE ARE QUITE
A FEW TO REINSTATE THE FIVE FOR
READ FOR CAL TO THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. WHY ONE THIRD
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. DAVID
NELSON WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASIAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
JUST RE INTEGRATING- OUR
SUPPORT. STAFF RECOMMENDATION
REGARDING THE H. ROBERT AND
REJECTING THAT EVERYBODY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR BREVITY. IN YOUR CABINET
NEXT PLEASE. FIND ONE SEVENTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN VERSION OF COAL RICE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION MY
COMMENTS WILL BE RELATED TO
PART EIGHT ISSUE FOR GUARDING
THE CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
CENTER GRANT IN THE CASE TWELVE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM WELL
WE ARE ASKING FOR THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
TO REJECT THE MAY WE OPPOSE ALL
WITH A 50% CUT INTERVENTION AND
THE CONTINUOUS ANNUAL
APPROPRIATION WE SUBMIT MORE
DETAIL RELATED TO YOUR
CONDITION AND WRITING AND WE
THANK YOU FOR THE CALL TO BE
ABLE TO. PROVIDE FIFTY THREE-
DESCRIPTION OF OUR POSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
BREVITY NEXT PLEASE. WIND. FIVE
J. GREINER ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY- WE COMMITTED A
LETTER OUTLINING SEVERAL
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATIONS FOR
NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET TO ADDRESS
BOTH SHORT TERM EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AND LONG TERM EQUITY
IMPLICATIONS I'M ALSO GLAD JUST
TO SUCH ISSUES BUT WITH ROUGHLY
BALL- UNDER ISSUE SEVENTY NINE
AND EIGHTY UNDER PART B. OF
YOUR AGENDA I DO YOU KNOW THE
CARRIAGE ACTIVE EXCLUDED
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS FROM
EMERGING PA AND PROVIDED LITTLE
RELIEF FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
RELATIVE TO THE NEEDS. OF THEIR-
IT A COMPOUNDED. INEQUITIES IN
THE FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM AND WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
AID TO THE STUDENT. WE MUST
ALSO ENSURE THAT IF FEDERAL
FUNDING IS NOT RECEIVED WE CAN
AVOID HARMFUL CUTS TO BASE
FUNDING FOR A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY. AS A RESULT OF
STATEMENTS DURING THE LAST
RECESSION WE TURN AWAY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND WE MUST
IDENTIFY OTHER MEANS OF
MAINTAINING SUPPORT FOR
UNIVERSITY. AND AVOIDING CUTS
THAT WOULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT
CURRENT AND PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. I WANT.
TO TWELVE. GOOD AFTERNOON- THE
CHAIR MEMBERS- PRICE ON WITH
THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION. THE
ONLINE NUMBER SEVENTY NINE AND
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY NINE- WE
WOULD LIKE IF YOU REALLY ARE-
THE- COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER NOT
CUTTING THE UC BUDGET GIVEN THE
ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
IMPACT BECAUSE THE PHYSICAL-
AND ON TOP OF THAT ALSO WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT THE- BUDGET THE
QUESTIONNAIRE THAT WAS SENT OUT
BY THE CALIFORNIA HIRED
UNDOCUMENTED COALITION- EARLIER
ASKING FOR MY FATHER'S THINGS
FOR THE U. C. TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION AN ONGOING. SUPPORT THE
ON RESOURCE CENTERS ARE. ON TWO
POINT MILLION TIME FOR
FINANCIAL AID. AND I'M NOT HE
R. J. SPEAKING AGAIN TO SUMMER
DOG THESE INCREDIBLE IMPORTANT
GIVEN THE IMPACT THAT OURS ARE.
DISRUPTION WE FACED IN THE WAKE
UP CALL THE NINETEENTH SUMMER.
AID WILL HELP THEM BE ABLE TO
GET SOME OF COURSES AND- GET
THEIR EDUCATION BACK ON TRACK.
YOU KEEP THAT ARGUMENTS AND
THAT'S IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMPLETE. USERNAMES PLEASE.
BLIND TWO TWENTY ONE. HELLO MY
NAME PUT THAT ON THE BEHALF OF
THE SO SHOULD FIT INTO YOU KNOW
THAT AND USE IT TO NATIONAL
STATION EVERY ARTIST IS SEVENTY
NINE WE ASK THAT YOU DO NOT
HAVE TO USE THE BUDGET THE U.
T. AS IN A FINANCIALLY UNSTABLE
CONDITION AND THAT HAS OCCURRED
OVER ONE POINT TWO BILLION. AND
LOSSES DUE TO COVER NINETEEN.
J. EIGHTY OR ASKED FOR TWO
POINT MILLION ONGOING FUND. TO
MAINTAIN UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT
SERVICES. AND TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME FINANCIAL AID
FOR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS. WE
ALSO ADD THAT SUMMER THAT
SUMMER. EIGHT DOLLARS BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT CUT. FINANCIAL AID
OVER SOME OF THE- STUDENTS WE
HAVE SEEN THEIR EDUCATION
BECAUSE- THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THAT'S WHAT IT IS. ONE WAY.
SEVEN GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS TO SHERRY GOING WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DIRECTOR OF THE PATIENT COMING
BEAVER HOPING THAT WE CAN
EXPERIENCE PROVIDING SCHOOL
BASED SERVICES WE ARE
INTERESTED IN ANY OPPORTUNITY
TO COLLABORATE WITH LEDS ON
CONTINUED TO SOME POINT WHERE
FOR EXAMPLE WE HOPE TO
COLLABORATE ON PROVIDING USE
MENTAL EAT PILOT PROGRAMS AN
IMPACT COUNTY DURING THE
UNPRECEDENTED KIND LET'S NOT
FORGET ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS AMONG ADOLESCENTS
EXPERIENCING OR WHO KNOWS
SOMEONE EXPERIENCING MENTAL
HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS. THE GROUP ON A LOCAL
LEVEL THANK 3% OF CALIFORNIANS
ARE TRAINED TO RECOGNIZE AND
RESPOND TO FIND A MENTAL
ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE USE IN
TRACKING DURING THIS PERIOD OF
INCREASING THE INSTRUMENTS
SHOULD BE TRAINED TO ATTRACT
MORE CLIENTS FOR CHILDREN TO
PUBLIC. HEALTH I'LL JUST BUT
THEY'LL PAY THE- WHERE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT.
MEXICO NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE TWO TWO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MARTHA TERRY GOES THE
DS AND I AM REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER WE
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT IN THE
MAY REVISION THE PROPOSED
COMPONENTS OF PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING FOR TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS AND THAT AND
OTHER SCHOOL. PERSONNEL AS A
DRESSING LEARNING LOSS INCURRED
BY STUDENTS ESPECIALLY OUR
VULNERABLE STUDENTS SUCH AS
ENGLISH LEARNERS IN OUR DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS HOWEVER
ADDITIONAL EMPHASIS NEEDS TO BE
TARGETED FOR ENGLISH LEARNER
STUDENTS AND GAIL L. CHILDREN
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO MAKE
CONSTRUCTION ONLY. SUCH AS
ACCELERATED LEARNING FOR
ENGLISH LEARNERS WHO HAVE NOT
RECEIVED ANY INSTRUCTION DURING
SCHOOL CLOSURES WE APPRECIATE-
THESE COMPONENTS OF THE MAY
REVISION AND WE REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT MAINTAINING THE
COMPONENTS AND THE MARY VICE.
BUT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOUR BROTHER THE COMMENTS
NEXT. WILL NEXT GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS KIRTI UNITY AND
PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF STUDENT
DEBT CRISIS ON BEHALF OF OUR
ORGANIZATION AND OVER ONE POINT
THREE MILLION SUPPORTERS- I'M
CALLING TO STATE OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR PART B. ISSUE FIFTY
SEVEN. THE PROPOSED STUDENT
DEBT LOAN WORKGROUP AND OUT
REACH BUDGET ITEM TO BE HOUSED
UNDER CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. THROUGH YEARS OF
WORK SPEAKING DIRECTLY TO NON
BORROWERS WE HAVE HEARD THAT
MANY OF THEM ARE UNAWARE OF
AFFORDABLE REPAYMENT OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO THEM. DUE TO THE
KOBE NINETEEN CRISIS THAT'S
EXCITING TO ESSENTIAL WORKERS
AND HEALTH CARE WORKERS AS WELL.
IN A RECENT SURVEY THAT ONE IN
THREE STUDENTS. WORSE WERE
COMPLETELY UNAWARE OF CODED
NINETEEN RELATED RELIEF AND-
HERE IN THE STATE WE CAN HELP
BRIDGE THAT GAP. SO GIVEN THE
FEDERAL AND STATE RESPONSE TO
KOBE NINETEEN- TO AVOID
UNPRECEDENTED. RELIEF A STUDENT
BORROWERS NEED TIMELY AND
ACCURATE INFORMATION ON HOW TO
BEST NAVIGATE THIS ECONOMIC
CRISIS. AT THE SENATE WORKS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE FOR THE
BUDGET THAT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU TO REMEMBER STILL
KNOWN BORROWERS. AS THEY ARE.
AND IT ORDER TO ME AND FOR MANY
FRONTLINE WORKERS HEALTH CARE
WORKERS FOR PUTTING THEIR LIVES
ON THE LINE. SO FOR THAT
ORGANIZATION IS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF PART B. ISSUE FIFTY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOUR NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE TWO FIVE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE TWO
FIVE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHAEL BLOCKADE AND ALL
BECAUSE OF THE TOUGH DISTANCE
EDUCATION IS GOING TO HAPPEN IS
DIFFERENT FROM THE CLINICAL. IF
YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE. TO SPEAK
UP IF YOU WANT TO STAY HERE.
OKAY WILL BE. TALKING AGAIN
CANNOT. YES THANK YOU I DO NOT
REMEMBER MY NAME IS MIKE WE
OPERATE ON THE OUTGOING
PRESIDENT OF THE TOP FIFTY
ASSOCIATION WELCOMED CAPTAIN
WANTS TO BECOME A TWITTER
CANCER YES YOU CAN GET ON THE
SYSTEM. OUR STUDENTS WE
UNDERSTAND THE MARKET ACCORDING
TO THE CATALOG COMPANY AND WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNMENT
CONTINUED FOCUS ON SUPPORTING
THE POSSIBILITY ESPECIALLY OUR
MOST INCOME COMMUNITIES MOST
AFFECTED BY THE PANDEMIC THE
STIMULUS BE IF YOU'RE NOT
GETTING THEIR OWN UNIQUE
SITUATION MAKING DIFFICULT
DECISIONS HOW TO HOW TO GET TO
THE POINT THAT THEIR
EDUCATIONAL RECONCILING THE
DAMAGE OF THE PANDEMIC WE ARE
THE FUTURE WHAT DOES THE
COUNTRY ECONOMY IT SHOULD NOT
BE FORGOTTEN DURING THIS
CRISIS. SUPPORT STUDENTS TO
CHALLENGE THE STATE MUST ENSURE
THAT THE COMPANY STATE
UNIVERSITY I'M COMPLETELY FOUND
INTERESTED IN POTENTIAL FUTURE
DELAYED ENTRY EDUCATED WORK.
FORCE THAT KEEPS YOUR CAR.
HELLO THANK YOU CHAIR OFTEN
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING TO MAKE
THIS DIFFICULT DECISION R.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ESPECIALLY ON MEMORIAL DAY I
REALIZE THIS IS A DIFFICULT
BUDGET SEASON AND THE DECISIONS
ARE UNFAIR AND LITTLE BUDGET
EQUITABLE BUDGET WILL BE EVEN
MORE SO. I 'M REPRESENTING IN
HORIZON IN LONG BEACH WE HAVE
HIGH STANDARDS AND WE SERVE
OVER FOUR HUNDRED CHILDREN THE
PROPOSED CUTS TO OUR RATES
WOULD DEVASTATE OUR PROGRAMS
AND REPRESENT A CUT. THANK YOU
4% NO MATTER WHAT THE THERE
THAT. THERE'S NO WAY I COULD
CONTINUE TO I WILL CONTINUE TO
OPERATE- WITH THESE WITH THESE
CUTS. AND I WOULD HAVE TO CLOSE
CENTERS IF THE PROPOSAL IS
APPROVED WITH THE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE IN JANUARY WILL
FURTHER INCREASE OUR OPERATING
COSTS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU APPROVED. A POST HOLD
HARMLESS CLAUSE FOR PROGRAMS
AND REJECT THE RATE CUT
PROPOSAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. WELL NOW
GOT A LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND ONE ONE ZERO ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DONNA SNARING JR I'M WITH THE
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER.
SPEAKING ON ISSUE NUMBER NINE
WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
OPPOSE THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
TOUCH TO CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS ARE
ALREADY. SIGNIFICANTLY
UNDERPAID AND THE CUTS WILL
MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
REMAIN OPEN OR RE OPEN AS WE
TRY TO MOVE TOWARD ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. CHILD CARE IS
ESSENTIAL FOR THE CRISIS AND
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND WE JUST
URGE YOU TO REJECT THAT RATE
CUT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. WELL NOW BUT A
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY FOUR ONE NINE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
JASON MAYFIELD I AM A FULL TIME
FACULTY AT THE ELBOW VALLEY
COLLEGE. WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT IF I
MIGHT I'D LIKE TO STRONGLY
OPPOSE ANY CONTINUED FUNDING
FOR CALGARY COLLEGE. THE
COLLEGE HAS- HUNDRED. FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED TO IT
AND IN THIS TIME WHERE WE ARE
GETTING CUT LEFT AND RIGHT
CROSS THE STATE. THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS AT CALIBRATE SURGERY
HER SMALL THAT MONEY COULD GO
TO BACKFILL AND REINSTATE THE
CUTS THAT WERE MADE TO OUR
ADJUNCT FACULTY. ARE ADJUNCT
FACULTY STATEWIDE SO ALMOST A
MILLION STUDENTS ARE STRONGLY
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO REJECT
ANY CONTINUED HUNTING FOR COKER
COLLEGE LOOKING. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. PIXEL ALONG THE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX TWO FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOU'RE WATCHING US BUT
SHE RECALLS LEADER CALIFORNIA
WE ARE APPRECIATIVE OF MANY OF
THE MINISTERS AND PROPOSALS OUR
OFFICE YOU SEVENTY SIX WE ARE
CONCERNED WITH POTENTIAL CUTS
BETWEEN COLLEGE STATES FUNDING.
BY FIVE HUNDRED NINETY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AND WE BELIEVE
THE CUT IS TO KEEP SUCH A
BETTER SOLUTION IS TO MAINTAIN
THE SAME NUMBER OF STUDENTS ARE
TO GROW. INTO A SPOT IT JUST
CREATED DEMAND. ON ISSUE
SEVENTY SEVEN WE REQUEST THE
SENATE TO CONSIDER SCALING BACK
THE GOVERNOR'S POST CUT TO
STRONG WORK FORCE ARE
CONSIDERED JUST YOU FORGOT AS
WAS DISCUSSED REDUCTION OF UP
TO TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WOULD BE PROFOUND ABOUT PROGRAM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. IS
NEXUS LINE NUMBER TWO HOW. AND
FIFTY FOUR TO FIVE FOR YOUR
LINE IS A- GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS SAMANTHA THANK FOR NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
PART B. ISSUE FIFTY SEVEN THE
PROPOSED STUDENT THAT LOAN
WORKGROUP IN OUTREACH BUDGET
ITEM TO BE HELD IN THE
CALIFORNIA IN A COMMISSION. FOR
MORE THAN FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WITH STUDENT DEBT
TOTALING A HUNDRED AND FORTY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS. IN DEBT
CRISIS HAS ONLY BEEN
EXACERBATED BY COVER NINETEEN
IN THE ECONOMIC FALLOUT AND
IMPACT CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM FROM SOCIAL WORKERS
TEACHERS BETTER IN COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND NEARING OR ALREADY
RETIRED. GIVEN RECENT FEDERAL
AND STATE RESPONSE WAS BECAUSE
THE NINETEEN. TO PROVIDE
UNPRECEDENTED. BARS BEING HIGH
AND ACT INFORMATION ON HOW YEAH.
THE ECONOMIC CRISIS NOW MORE
THAN EVER WE DIRECT THAT THERE
STREAMING. THE CLIENT THE AS A
WAY. TO MEET THE CONSTITUTIONAL
DEADLINE FOR THE STATE BUDGET
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
KEEP IN BARS IN LINE. AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BE A KEY
COMPONENT OF THE STATE'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY PLAN THANK.
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. MAX
LINE ONE AND SEVENTY ONE ONE
SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AMERICA GOOD AFTERNOON ERICA
MERRILL BEHALF OF THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. ON ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY SIX WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO REJECT THE
PERFORMANCE BASED FUNDING
PORTION OF THE FCS. ASKED I
WISH YOU THE BEST PERFORMANCE
BASED FUNDING HAS HARMED THE
EXECUTION THAT SERVE THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF UNDER.
REPRESENTED STUDENTS AND GIVEN
WHAT ABOUT TO CUT. THE MOBILE
INDUSTRY PROGRAMS SERVE THOSE
WE YOU TO NEED TO BE PERFORMED
SPACE BUT MEASURE. WE URGE YOU
TO EXTENT POSSIBLE TO WORK YOU
IF YOU USE YOUR PROTECT.
GRADUATION INITIATIVE AND THE
OPENING LEVELS AND FAMILY HOMES
TO POTENTIAL HE'D BE SOME
CONSTRUCTION TRADE
RECOMMENDATIONS. ARE TO PROTECT
OUR STUDENTS WE KNOW 50% OF
LATINO STUDENTS WERE FAILING ON
ONE COURSE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE NOT PENALIZED IN
ACCORDANCE WITH IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
WE'LL GOLINE NUMBER TWO HOW
AND FOUR TUESDAY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS KILL TEN MEN ON THE DEAN OF
PLANNING RESEARCH AND
INSTITUTIONAL EFFECTIVENESS OF
TALK ABOUT THE COLLEGE. PICKED
THAT ONE OUT OF TWENTY HIGH
SCHOOL SENIORS IN CALIFORNIA
WILL DIFFERENT ROMAN IS THERE
FOR YOUR INSTITUTION AND ATTEND
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE INSTEAD. 17% OF
CONTINUING STUDENTS CLAIMED IT
TAKE A GAP YEAR NINTENDO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHICH
ANNOUNCED ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL STUDENTS.
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING THE IMPACT
OF DOCUMENTARY COLLEGE FOR
SUMMER TERM COMPARED TO LAST
SUMMER WE'RE SEEING MORE THAN
FIVE THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
ENROLLMENTS ARE TEMPTED IN
ROCKLEDGE. WE'RE NOW AT 98%
CAPACITY AND WE CAN'T ADD
CHORDS COURSE SECTION BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING TO DO
SO. MANY COLLEGES ARE THE
ENGINE OF OUR STATE'S ECONOMIC
RECOVERY IN THE SHORT TERM
BARGAINING IT CUT OUR SYSTEM
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SERVE THE-
NATION UNDER A THOUSAND. HELLO
TERM CUTTING OUR- FURTHER DOWN.
HAVE IT THERE ARE TWO.
RESULTING IN FEWER TRY. HORSE
RIDING ENTRANCE READY. I'D LIKE
TO MAKE TO SUGGESTIONS FIRST
CLOSING HOW BRIGHT THE START UP
ONLINE COLLEGE AND REINVESTING
THE HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS INTEREST OUTLAYS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THAT. WOULD
PUT IT IN A BETTER POSITION TO
HANDLE THE UPCOMING STUDENT
SEARCH SECOND PER STUDENT
FUNDING IN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IS EIGHT THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED SIX DOLLARS
COMPARED 218-000-4405 AT THE
CSU'S. THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
FIVE SIX NINE EIGHT BTC. NOW
IT'S TIME TO CONSIDER CREATING
MORE EQUITABLE FUNDING MODEL
FOR LOWER DIVISION COURSES. IN
THE TIME BECAUSE TIME AND SHE
THANK YOU. I WILL NOTE THE
WE'RE CURRENTLY WE HAVE SOME.
THREE MORE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
ON THE PHONE LINE SEVEN THREE
SO FOR THOSE OF YOU. RUN UP AND
THEN I'M ABOUT TO CALL THE NEXT
PLEASE TRY TO LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS. TO ONE MINUTE OR LESS
OR I WILL NEED TO REDUCE THE
TIME LIMIT NEXT PLEASE. WELL
NOW THAT A LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT TWO
THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CAN YOU CHECK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL
ADVOCACY ALLIANCE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR LEYVA FOR HER
COMMENTS TODAY ON ANY ISSUE FOR
TRIGGER CUT AFTER SCHOOL. AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS LIKE CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS ARE ESSENTIAL TO THE
pAND THEY WON'T SURVIVE. THEY'D
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSED RATE
CUTS PROVIDERS WILL BE ABLE TO
MEET THE INCREASING MY WEIGHT
REQUIREMENTS THE ADDED COST FOR
HELPING EIGHTY PROTOCOLS WITH
KOBE DIDN'T SERVE THE NAME. THE
SAME NUMBER OF STUDENTS ALL
WITH 15% CUT TO STATE FUNDING
PROGRAMS WILL BE INSOLVENT AND
SHUT DOWN LEAVING STUDENTS
BEGAN WHAT ABOUT SERVICING
CARRY. THE TIME WHEN THEY NEED
IT MOST ANY PROGRAMS NEED TO
STAND READY AND FLEXIBLE TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF SHIFTING
SCHOOL SCHEDULE I KEPT IT
CLASSIFIED THAT. LEAVES ABOUT.
HIS FAMILY IN SCHOOL SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO HELP RECOVER FROM
THE CAR THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT. THIS EXCELLENT-
I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
SEVEN ONE NINE SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS BOB-STOCKHOLM ATTACK REMEMBER
DEANDRE COLLEGE I'M CALLING
OPPOSITION TO CALIBRATE. THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
RECOMMENDS ELIMINATING CALVARY
TO HELP OFFSET THE PAIN OF THE
RECESSION ON THE COLLEGES
SERVING OVER TWO MILLION
STUDENTS. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL ALBERT'S
FUNDING CAN BE BETTER USED
DURING THESE UNPRECEDENTED
ECONOMIC TIMES TO HELP SUPPORT
STUDENTS IN ONLINE INSTRUCTION.
A HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
ACCREDITED COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
OKAY NOW WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FIVE TWO FIVE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS NOT ON THE
BALLOT I AM TWENTY YEARS OLD.
STUDENTS WITH AFFECT BUT
THERE'S SUCH A HIGH SCHOOL IN
BENTON HAS SPRINKLED APARTMENTS
WE WANT TO THANK THE LORD. FOR
REJECTING THE PROPOSED H. R.
ONLY HE ALSO PROVIDE. THE CHILD
WITH HIGH SCHOOL TO MOVE
FORWARD. I WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF FOR THAT ANALYSTS.
SUPPORT FOR ME IT'S ABOUT BY
THE BALL THANK YOU FOR BEING.
HELPING THEM TO PULL ME. TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TO TALK ABOUT
TWENTY YEARS MAY GOD BLESS ALL
WITH RIGHT CHARLIE LEIGHT.
FINALLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS DURING NEXT PLEASE.
EXCELLENT ONLINE TWO HUNDRED
AND THREE TWO ZERO THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
BELINDA MAMA FULL TIME FACULTY
MEMBER AT SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE- I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF YOUR COLLEGE
GRADUATION SPEAKERS AND THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION HELP WITH
ANY COLLEGES- ARE REGARDING
ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN AND SEVENTY
EIGHT WE STRONGLY. OPPOSE THE
CUTS IN EQUITY FUND AND- WAR
AND STRONG WORK FORCE WE
BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE IF WE HAVE
TO CLOSE OUT RIGHT THAT MONEY
COULD ACTUALLY HELP OFFSET A
LOT OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN THE
END BUT HONESTLY RIGHT NOW.
GIVEN THE BURGEONING ALL.
COLLEGES THE COMPANY INVESTED
NOT DIVESTMENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU BY THE WAY THOSE
OF US TO CALIBRATE I THINK IT
JUST SAY WE CAN RIDE I THINK WE
GET. THE MASS. IT WOULD HELP
THROUGH THE- PROBABLY SO PEOPLE
THAT ARE LESS ON THE PHONE LINE
BUT YOU FOR. IN YOUR NOW PLEASE.
WELL NOW GO LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE ONE TWO
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN THIS IS JEFF
FROST REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL LIBRARY
ASSOCIATION. ONE ITEM NUMBER
FOR THE CATEGORICAL TRIGGERS.
WE ARE REALLY CONCERNED THAT
THE ONLINE DATABASE FUNDING OF
THREE MILLION DOLLARS. COULD BE
ZEROED OUT. AT THE SAME TIME
THROUGHOUT. OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE FALL ARE
LIKELY TO CONTINUE WITH
DISTANCE LEARNING. THESE
DATABASES CREATE HUGE EQUITY
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR STUDENTS
FAMILIES AND TEACHERS. AND WE-
HOPE THAT YOU KEEP FROM- OFF OF
THE TRIGGER LIST THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT LITTLE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO TO THREE
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIRTY DOLLARS ADDED
TO THE BATHROOM PROJECT
CALIFORNIA I'LL FOCUS MY
REMARKS THANK YOU TO COLLEGE
CATION ISSUES WE BELIEVE
ADDITIONAL REVENUES ARE
WARRANTED BECAUSE- WE HAVE GOT
TO THINK ABOUT HOW EASY AND GET
THE CONVOCATION TRENDING CAN BE
HOLD ON LET'S. MAKE COLD BEYOND
THE CURRENT STATE BUDGET FOR
INSTANCE WE BELIEVE IT WILL
INQUIRE ABOUT MY YEARS AT THAT
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES FIRST
WHICH CAN BRING ABOUT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS FOR K. TWELVE
EDUCATION. PLEASE LOGIN.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND SHOULD
NOT BE INCLUDED IN CROSS THE
BOARD CUT. WE ASK THAT YOU
CREATE AND PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
THE OFFICE OF EQUITY. FOR
LEVERAGE ALREADY EXISTING
EQUITY IN ACCESS BRANCH WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. TO
WORK WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
MITIGATE WHAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
A LEARNING LOSS THAT HAD BEEN
EXASPERATED. MICHAEL THE
NINETEEN. WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
THE STATE MUST UTILIZE AN
EQUITY BASED FORMULA TO
ALLOCATE FUNDS TO EARLY
LEARNERS AND KEY TO TWELVE
STUDENTS MOST IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC FOR PROGRAMS LIKE
COLD. CHILD WELLNESS HUBS
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AND OTHER
HOLISTIC WELLNESS SERVICES THAT
PROVIDE. ONLINE ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS LASTLY
WE ASK THAT YOU FIND ADDITIONAL
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
SUPPORT FOR EDUCATORS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME I DO NOT PLEASE.
PIXEL LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY NINE TWO FIVE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE TWO
FIVE NINE WOULD YOU CHECK YOUR
LINE FOR MUTE WE ARE HEARING
THE AUDIO. DURING A RESPONSE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT CALLER
WHICH IS LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO ONE THREE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SH GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JEFF RICE FOUNDER AND
DIRECTOR OF THE EIGHT PLUS
PERSONALIZED LEARNING NETWORK
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE TO SPEAK
ON ITEM NUMBER SIX THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY RELIEF FUNDS. AND THE
EXCLUSION OF NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS- I
REPRESENT EIGHTY FIVE. NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS
ALL OF WHICH PROVIDE
PERSONALIZED LEARNING A WIDE
VARIETY OF. LEARNING PROGRAMS
AND ACTIVITIES AND EVENTS. THAT
LOPES LEAD USE SCHOOL SITES
THOSE ACTIVITIES IN FACT THE
MAJORITY OF SO CALLED NON
CLASHING BASED CHARTER. WHICH
IS A NOT FOR A TURN THAT LEADS
A LOT OF MISUNDERSTANDING AND
CONFUSION. DOESN'T ACT WE
DESCRIBE THE SCOPE OF. THE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS THAT. ALL
BACK BUT YOU ALREADY HAVE THE
TOOLS YOU'LL SCHOOLS FOR WHY
VARIETY OF SIR PARTICULARLY
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE
DISADVANTAGED WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU INCLUDE NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS. IN THOSE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY RELIEF FUNDS THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
ARE NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IN LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX ONE
SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF
OF THE SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT. WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE REQUIRING CUTS TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CATEGORICAL STRATEGIC AID
DISTRICTS. AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL FOR WHICH CATEGORICAL TO
CUT. THAT BOULDER WILL STUDENT
POPULATION CAN BE PROTECTED AND
THAT ANY FUNDS PROVIDED FROM
LOCAL PROPERTY TAXES BY THE
COLLEGES. USED TO BACKFILL THE
CATEGORICAL CUTS IS EXCLUDED
FROM THE 50% WALKCALCULATION.
WE'RE ALSO VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE COUNTY IS BEING RELEASED
FROM THEIR PROPERTY TAX YOUR
PLANS MID YEAR. THIS WOULD
DRASTICALLY DEVASTATOR DISTRICT
ENTIRE BUDGET FOR SEVERAL YEARS
TO COME. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO.
HAVING THESE ISSUES ANSWERED
AND AS- COMMITTEE COMPLETES THE
BUDGET PROCESS THANK YOU IT IS
OUR NEXT PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR TO TWO FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
APOLLO CUT OFF FROM THE COUNTY
OF SAN MATTEO. I'M SPEAKING ON
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
RECOMMENDED ACTION REGARDING
THE RAFT THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY
REFERENCED. BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
EARLIER DURING PUBLIC COMMENT.
WRONGLY OPPOSES THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO THE REVENUE
TAXATION CODE WHICH WOULD
IMPOSE CIVIL PENALTIES ON
COUNTIES IN CONNECTION WITH
THEIR QUEUE WRAPPED
CALCULATIONS. ATTORNEYS BELIEVE
THAT THEIR METHODOLOGY CONFORMS
TO THE EXISTING STATUTES. BUT
TO THE EXTENT THE DARK
QUESTIONS RETURNEES ARE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. WHICH IS
THE APPROPRIATE STATE
DEPARTMENT TO REVIEW THESE
CALCULATIONS FOR COMPLIANCE
WITH EXISTING LAW. THE PROPOSED
CIVIL PENALTIES ARE DRASTIC AND
UNPRECEDENTED IN OUR REQUEST IS
THAT THIS ACTION BE POSTPONED
UNTIL NEXT YEAR TO PROVIDE FOR
ADDITIONAL TIME TO JOURNEYS TO
WORK WITH THE APPROPRIATE STATE
AGENCIES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
WELL NOW THE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN TWO ONE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS TIM SHOCKLEY- PRESIDENT
OF THE FOOTHILL DE ANZA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK TO HIM BEING- NUMBER
SEVENTY EIGHT- PARTICULARLY IN
REGARDS TO CALIBRATE. AND I
HAVE THREE LETTERS FOR YOU- ER.
BUT THE ONLINE EDUCATION
INSTITUTE COULD HAVE DONE
ANYTHING THAT CALIBRATE SET OUT
TO DO AND STILL CAN SO IF THERE
ARE ANY LEGITIMATE. FUNCTIONS
WHICH CALIBRATE COULD STILL
SERVE- YEAH I CAN DO THAT MORE
EFFECTIVELY FOR LOWER COST CAN
I HELP YOU YOU WILL CONSIDER
THAT WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING IN THE
BUDGET THANK YOU. CAN I PLEASE.
THANK YOU CONTACTS GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
FIVE ONE NINE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
DANIEL SOLOMON. I AM AN ADJUNCT
INSTRUCTOR AT THE END THE
COLLEGE DEGREE- COLLEGE. ON
HERE REGARDING ISSUE NUMBER
SEVENTY EIGHT. ALL RIGHT SHOULD
BE CLOSE. OVER THE COURSE OF
THE PANDEMIC COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE SHOWN HOW NIMBLE WE CAN BE
IN ORDER TO MEET OUR STUDENTS
WHERE THEY ARE AT. ALBERT WAS
NEVER NECESSARY AND IN THIS
MOMENT OF EXTREME BUDGET CRISIS
IT IS COMPLETELY REDUNDANT. THE
OTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGES DO A
CREDIT WORK AT HER ACTION OF
THE COST. CALIBRATION BE
ELIMINATED. FINDING SHOULD BE
USED TO OFFSET CUTS AND TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
ONLINE INSTRUCTION. BY
INSTITUTIONS THAT WE KNOW WORK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
ARTICULATE I SUGGESTED ANY
FUTURE CALIBRATE TO CALLERS WHO
ARE OPPOSED TO CALIBRATE ALIGN
YOURSELF SIMPLY WITH THAT
CALLER NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED TWO ZERO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS TROY MYERS
A TEACHING ENGLISH ONLINE AND
FACE TO FACE AT SECOND CITY
COLLEGE AND I AGREE WITH THE
PREVIOUS CALLERS TIME AND
CALIBRATE. BUT AT A GIVEN%
AROUND WITH THE FORMIDABLE AND
EXPERIENCED LEADER IT IS
IDIOSYNCRATIC PROJECTS WERE NOT
ALWAYS PRODUCTIVE. YEAH RIGHT
IS MARKETED FOR ITS FLEXIBILITY
BUT AS WE JUST HEARD OUR SYSTEM
IS SHOWING GREAT ADAPTABILITY
THE LAST TWO MONTHS. ASK IF YOU
NEED A COLLEGE ALUMNUS PLEASE
OVER ALL CONTINENTS EXPENSIVE
EXPERIMENT. PUTTING COST
EFFECTIVE COLLEGES IN OUR
SYSTEM. THANK YOU AND YOUR NEXT
PLEASE. EXPECT A LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO TO
FIVE. HI MY NAME IS ANGELA
LAWRENCE FROM IT BECAUSE
CHALLENGE- LET ME TURN OVER
THOSE NINETEEN IN THE SPRING WE
WANT TO THANK THE CONNECTORS
AND AFTER REJECTING THE
PROPOSAL THAT. AGE GAP AND
ALLOWING THE FIELD TO PROVIDE
IT THIS IS CHARLOTTE HAS MOVED
FORWARD I THINK CURRENT CHANGE
MY LIFE I WAS THIRTY FIVE YEARS
OLD WHEN I ENTER THE PROGRAM IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THE
TECHNICALLY BEYOND MY LIMITS
AND MADE ME BELIEVE IN MYSELF
AND TO AIM FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
THANK YOU THAT BIG I'M A FIRST
GENERATION HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE. IN COLLEGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
LITTLE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND TO ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS GONZALEZ
AND SPEAKING AGAINST ANYMORE
CAL BY FUNDING. AS IT DEMANDS A
COLLEGE INSTRUCTOR I SEE
FIRSTHAND HOW STUDENTS BENEFIT
FROM HIGHER ESPECIALLY. IN OUR
COMMUNITIES LEFT BEHIND IN A
WINNER TAKE ALL ECONOMY I ALSO
SEE UP CLOSE TO REAL DAMAGE
DONE WHEN SCARCE EDUCATION
DOLLARS ARE WASTED. ON POORLY
CONCEIVED EDUCATIONAL. GOALS
BUT TO JUST BE A BAD IDEA THAT
WAS FUNDED OUT OF POLITICAL
CONVENIENCE BUT NOW WE CAN SEE
HOW BADLY IT FAILED BUT OTHER
COLLEGES HAVE STEPPED UP TO THE
CHALLENGE OF FULLY ONLINE
OFFERINGS. IN THIS SLASH AND
BURN BUDGET ENVIRONMENT
CONTINUING ITS MULTI MILLION
DOLLAR VANITY PROJECT IS SIMPLY
INEXCUSABLE- PLEASE HAVE THE
COURAGE TO DO THE RIGHT THING
AND HELP RIGHT NOW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. CURRENT
EXCELLENT UNDER TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE TWO TWO THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
JACKIE SMITH AND I'M A LOS
ANGELES NOT A COLLEGE STUDENT
ALSO A THREE FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE
STUDENT INTERN. OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
CORNERSTONES OF GROWTH AND
UPWARD MOBILITY FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AND ELISE AND
STABLE TIMES WE NEED COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THAT YOU SUPPORTED MORE
NOW THAN EVER. PLEASE CONSIDER
THESE FUNNY COW BRIGHT AND
SHINING ALREADY ESTABLISHED
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT HAVE
THOUSANDS MORE STUDENTS IN CAL
RIGHT AS- OUR STUDENTS WHO FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS IN THE
COMING MONTHS DUE TO THE LACK
OF. RESOURCES THIS IS NOT THE
TIME TO ESTABLISH INSTITUTIONS
THAT WERE MADE INDEED THIS IS
THE TIME TO SUPPORT
INSTITUTIONS AND ALWAYS BEEN
FULL OF STUDENTS GETTING
ASSISTANCE- I'VE DONE SOME
RESEARCH FOR THE LACC THAT
OFFERS ALL THREE CERTIFICATES.
BACK HOW BRIGHT ALTERS
YESTERDAY WEST LA COLLEGE AND
PEERS HAVE ALL THREE
CERTIFICATES BASTEN'S VOLLEY
LOS ANGELES CITY LOS ANGELES
MISSION HARBOR HAVE I. T. AND
MEDICAL CODING AND BILLING LOS
ANGELES INITIALLY. WHEN YOU
DROP. YOUR COMMENTS HE'S-
THAT'S- PRETTY MUCH IT THANK
YOU WELL YOU FOR COMMENTS.
WE'RE MAKING FOR. WE'LL HAVE
FOR FIVE FIVE FIVE. ON THE LINE
NEXT PLEASE. THANKS FOR THE
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR TO FOUR FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS ROCK AND LATER THIS IS
GREAT RUSSIA ON BEHALF OF
TEACHING BOOKS A BURGLAR GOOD
IDEATION. I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON
THE ISSUE FOR THE ONLINE
RESOURCE SUBSCRIPTIONS FOR
SCHOOL. OKAY SURE TO BE FACTS
REGARDING THIS PROGRAM WILL
SUBMIT ADDITIONAL FACTORS TO
THE COMMITTEE IN WRITING. ALL
RIGHT ONLY GOOD COMPLAINING
RESOURCES SPENCER ALL SIXTY
MILLION PLUS PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS IN
CALIFORNIA. IT IS THREE MILLION
DOLLAR PROGRAM IS CUT DISTRICT
FIVE TO PAY OVER ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
REPLACE THESE RESOURCES. WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS CUT AND
BELIEVE IT IS AGAINST THE
ADMINISTRATION STATED GOAL OF
THE EQUITY AND CLOSING THE
OPPORTUNITY GAP. WE'RE ASKING
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO FUND THE
THREE MILLION ONLINE
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES PROGRAM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO LINE
NUMBER ONE HOW AND NINE NINE
ONE. ONE REALLY. I THINK YOU'VE
GOT IT RIGHT ONE NINE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN AROUND HERE
BACKGROUND NOISE OKAY. THEY'RE
CURENTLY NOT THERE THEIR PHONE
WE'RE GONNA GO AND MOVE ON ONE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN TO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS L. U. G. G.
AND A COLLEGE STUDENT FROM THE
BRACE AND A TIME NOT UNTENABLE
PROPOSAL TO SCALP OR
ELIMINATED. UNDER POINT YOU
TALK WHEN YOU COLLEGES. RIGHT
PEOPLE PARTS OF YOUR ONLINE
EDUCATION HUB FOR STUDENTS
FACULTY AND STAFF. JUNI BECAUSE
WRITERS SEVERELY. UNDERFUNDED
FOR COVERAGE ON THE BENCH
DIRECTED TOWARDS LOOKING
COLLEGES WHICH IN EIGHTEEN AND
ALL THAT. I RECEIVED A SMALL
GROUP TUTORING APART FROM THE
OTHER END HELPING PEERS. AND
THE RIGHT HEARING A CONTRIBUTOR
OUR SCHOOLS. BETTER WHICH
ALLOWED ME TO SPEAK FOR SUCH A
PROGRAM WE NEED MORE RESOURCES
TO KEEP SERVICES. OUTSIDE OF
OPTING INSTRUCTION AND
IMPROVEMENT ALL COMPANY
FACILITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK PLEASE. LINE. NINETY
SEVEN. ONE NINETY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND ONCE AGAIN
ONE NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NEXT PLEASE MOVING
ALIGNED TO SIXTY FOUR. THANK
YOU TEAR DROP IN CENTERS GOOD
CHARLOTTE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS
IN THE SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION
COALITION OR TO SPEAK ON ISSUE
THREE OF THE WE POSED A 10% CUT
TO THE HOME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION BLOCK GRANT. AND
STATE REPORTS SHOWED HOW FAR IT
IS FROM THE SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. TO THIS
EXISTING TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING. BASED ON OUR
TRANSPORTATION COST NINETEEN
EIGHTIES. SEARCH TRANSPORTATION
COSTS FAR EXCEEDED THE FUNDING
PROVIDED TO THEM BY THE STATE.
HOME SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION
BACHRACH AND TWENTY THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN THE MOST RECENT YEAR
AVAILABLE DATA. DESTRUCTION
CALIFORNIA ONE BILLION OF THE
JOB ON THE COVER TRANSPORTATION
COSTS. NOT COVERED. IN THE HOME
THE SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION BLOCK
GRANT. OR YOU CAN JUST GO
SAFELYCONTINUE TO BE ON THE-
DR JANKO LITTLE DISTRICT BRING
STUDENTS BACK TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION COSTS WILL BE
INCREASED IMPLEMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS THE CDC GUIDELINES
ON SOCIAL BIRTH THANK. TO CUT
DOWN ON THE SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION BACHRACH AND
KIMBERLY ALLEY A GENERAL FUND
WILL PUSH SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
CUT MORE GENERAL EDUCATON
ROUTE SPARKLE FINDING OUT A
CAUTION TO COVER ADDITIONAL
COSTS TO TRANSPORT STUDENTS.
STUDENTS IN THE DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION HIGH TRANSPORTATION
COSTS ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
MORE FUNDING PULLED OUT THE
CLASSROOM TO TRANSPORT THEM TO
THE CLASSROOM THANK. YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. LYING TO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHRIS YOUNG
INVINCIBLE I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
BRIDGING THE ITEM PART BE ISSUE
NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN THE PROPOSED
STUDENT DEBT LONG LONG
WORKGROUP AND OUTREACH BUDGET
ITEM FOR BE HOUSED UNDER THAT
THERE ARE MORE THAN FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WOULD
COMBINE IT INSTEAD OF A HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
AND KOBE NINETEEN IN THE
ENSUING ECONOMIC CRISIS ON
MULTIPLY THE IMPACT. YOU KNOW
THAT DOESN'T IMPACT EVERY
BORROWER SANE SO WE NEED TO
HAVE DEDICATED OUTREACH IN OUR
STATE I'M SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA FARMERS ARE ABLE TO
RECOVER FROM AND REPAY ITS
CRIPPLING STUDENT DEBT AS OUR
ECONOMY RECOVERS YEAH COULD YOU
REMEMBER THE ONE MILLION
BORROWERS IN OUR STATE AND THEY
ARE A KEY COMPONENT TO OUR
FAITH ECONOMIC RECOVERY PLAN.
AS YOU MAKE YOUR BUDGET
DIVISION THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
BLIND TWO EIGHTY ONE. AARON
AFTER HE WENT PUBLIC ADVOCATES
A MEMBER OF THE OFF THE FF
EQUITY COALITION COMMENTING ON
ISSUES THREE FIVE AND SIX WE
ASK THE LEGISLATURE TO DOUBLE
DOWN ON THE ADMINISTRATION BACK
WHEN HE APPROACHED GET THE
IMPACT OF THE FISCAL HEALTH
CRISIS IS NOT THE SAME FOR ALL
STUDENTS. IT RECOMMEND HOLDING
HARMLESS HIGH NEEDS STUDENTS
EXCLUDING SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION GRANTS FROM THE
PROPOSED 10% CUTS OUT YES I
WOULD SUPPORT USING CARROTS
FUNDS TO MITIGATE LEARNING LOTS
AND ESTABLISH RESTORATIVE
LEARNING PROGRAMS AND SCHOOLS
SERVING HIGH NEEDS STUDENTS AT
THE BAR THE ALLEY AS
RECOMMENDATION TO INCLUDE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL AS AN
AUTHORIZED USER OF THE FRONT WE
ALSO AFTER THE FALL THREE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR COMMUNITY
SCHOOL BECAUSE IN JANUARY
BEHIND IT. EXPLAINING HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ATTEMPT
EQUITABLY ALLOCATE LEARNING
LOTS BAND THE PROPOSED
DISTRIBUTING THE TWO POINT NINE
BILLION TALLY EIGHTH
PROPORTIONAL TO THE PERCENTAGE
OF THE TOTAL PROBLEM MENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION TIME FOR EACH
OTHER GET RECEIVED BROUGHT IT
IN PROPORTION TO TOTAL UP THE
FF BINDING FINALLY WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY AID TO UNDOCUMENTED
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND ELIGIBLE
FOR CARROTS RELIEF PARTICULARLY
THOSE ENROLLED FULL TIME AT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THANK. YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. BLIND
SEVENTY FOUR. HELLO HELLO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I WOULD LIKE TO
STAND IN SUPPORT WITH MATTHEW
BUT- I THINK THAT HELPED BREAK
PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BLIND TO SIXTY. HELLO MY
NAME IS ABOUT THE METAL AND NOT
BECAUSE SHE'S NT ON THE TOPIC
OF SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
CONSIDER DEFINING JUMP RIGHT
UNDERNEATH THAT IS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT NEED MORE
RESOURCES. THANK YOU. THANK.
NINE TO EIGHTY THREE. MY TWO
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WELL YOUR OPEN. HI HI MY NAME
IS GABRIELA GUPTA AND I MAY BE
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT AND I WOULD LIKE TO
ORDER ON THE EVENING OF CABARET
I FIND IT CREDIBLE BUT THE
COMMUNITY AT THE END BUT WHAT
THE WHAT THE IMPORTANT PROGRAMS
THAT BENEFIT ALL MY FRIENDS AND
CLASSMATES IN ONE FORM OR
ANOTHER A LOT MORE ABOUT THE
BOXING CLASS A LOT MORE THAN.
THAT THE BEST HIGHER EDUCATION
IS THAT BETTER MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT PROGRAM BUT I'LL LET
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED
GROUPS BUT SHOOTER AND MUCH
MORE THAN WHAT WE COULDN'T THE
PATH FOR ON HOW RIGHT AND PUT
THAT MONEY INTO ALREADY
EXISTING STRUCTURES THAT ARE
STUDENTS WHO NEED AN ALREADY
GOING ON. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. ONE TWO NINE TWO.
MMHM GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
THANKS TO YOU IN THE OFFICE L.
A. O. L. L. A. O. C. D. FOR ALL
THE WORK TO LEAD ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE DURING THIS
TRYING TIME MY NAME IS KEN
OLIVER LEGAL SERVICES IN
PRISONS WITH CHILDREN. ALL OF
US OR NONE. I'M CALLING TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR TWO ITEMS
AND PART EIGHT. UNDER ISSUE
NUMBER FOR THE PRESERVATION. OF
AFTER SCHOOL FUNDING IN
CHILDCARE. THESE SERVICES ARE
AN INTEGRAL PART OF THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO RESTART THE ECONOMY
BY ALLOWING WORKING PARENTS THE
ABILITY TO GO BACK TO WORK. NOT
HAVE ANY SERVICES FORCES
PARENTS TO MAKE A CHOICE
BETWEEN WORKING AND CARING FOR
THEIR CHILDREN. ANOTHER ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE WE'RE ALSO ASKING
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. THIS HAD A
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT WOULD
JUMP START SCHOOL A
NEIGHBORHOOD TRANSFORMATION.
THROUGH THE INTEGRATION OF
SERVICES THE NEW APPROACHES TO
TEACHING AND LEARNING. THIS
INVESTMENT MUST. ALLOW FOR
FOCUS. ON TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO THE POOR DISTRICTS IN MAKING
THESE CHANGES. BOTH OF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT TO GIVE OUR CURRENT
MOMENT. THEY ALLOWED POINTED TO
SAFELY RESTART TO AFTER SCHOOL
CHILDCARE. ALSO PLANT THE SEED
FOR THE STATE TO INVEST IN THE
FUTURE OF EDUCATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
EXCELLENT LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN TWO ONE
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS CHRISTOPHER DIAZ I AM
MEDIA AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE-STUDENT I'M HERE AT THE GUN
ISSUE SEVEN EIGHT I WANT TO
ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE COLORS
ARE GETS CALLED FRANK MICHAEL
HAVE FULLY MOVED ON MINE AND
HAS DONE. THAT BUT WE JUST GOT
A CALL RIGHT NOW AND HAVEN'T
BEFORE YOU CONSIDER DEFINING
CALIBRATE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT I NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE TWO
NINE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MY NAME IS
ETCHED INTO THE CALIFORNIA
CHILD CARE RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL NETWORK. COMMENTS WITH
THE ECT COALITION PREVIOUSLY
SUBMITTED BUT I'D LIKE TO
COMMENT ON ISSUE NINE WE NEED
TO SUPPORT CHILD CARE
BUSINESSES TO STAY OPEN AND
DRIVE SO THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
COLLECT CHILD CARE FOR THEIR-
FAMILIES ARE CURRENTLY WORKING
AND ARE READY AT EACH STAGE OF
RECOVERY AS MORE PEOPLE RETURN
TO WORK. EVEN BEFORE THIS
CRISIS DOES NOT IMPROVE THE
CHILD CARE FOR EVERY FAMILY WHO
NEEDED. CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
WHO CARE FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES WHO RECEIVE CHILDCARE
SEPERTI I REPEAT THE LOW THE
COST OF CARE WE DO THINK THAT
WE HAVE TO PAY BY 10% CERTAINLY
IT DOES NOW A LARGE HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT INTERNAL SO
OUR RECOVERY BECAUSE WITHOUT
CHILD CARE MANY CALIFORNIANS
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO RETURN TO
WORK. WE URGE YOU TO MAINTAIN-THE CHILD CARE CENTER THE RIGHT
TO CARE FOR CHILDREN AND-
FAMILIES REMAINING THE END OF
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR THANK. YOU
PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL I NEVER
ONE AND SEVEN NINE ONE SO NINE
YEAR LINE IS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I GENE HEARST HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THAT SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
REGARDING A PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE ASSOCIATED WITH
ACCENTS HE RAPS I JUST LIKE TO
ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
IN THE COUNTY OF SAN MATTEO AND
URGED COMMITTEE TO GIVE US SOME
TIME TO WORK OUT THIS ISSUE
RATHER THAN RESORT TO WHAT WE
BELIEVE ARE PUNITIVE PENALTIES
THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IN LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED THREE ZERO
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
KATIE HARTMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
PTA TOP PRIORITY IS TO REOPEN
BECAUSE BASICALLY AND THAT WILL
REQUIRE MORE FUNDING NOT LESS
SO WE ASK YOU TO PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS
TO REOPEN. BASICALLY AND
PREVENT LAYOFFS OF TEACHERS AND
BACK I ALSO WANTE TO SPEAK
BRIEFLY TO THE CHARTER SCHOOL
AGE CAP PROPOSAL. EPA
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS A LOOPHOLE
IN THE LAW WHICH ALLOWED
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO GENERATE
ALTHEA FIVE DOLLARS FOR ADULTS
STUDENTS. THIRTY K. FOR
CORPORATE CORPORATE GENERAL
LANGUAGE AND WOULD HIGHLIGHT
THAT CURRENTLY THE PROGRAMS ARE
TAKING MONEY OUT OF K. TWELVE
CLASSROOMS THE THIRD ADULT.
WHICH SHOULD NOT BE AND HOW
ABOUT YEAH- ADDITIONALLY I
WANNA AND STAYED THAT TEACHES
THE COURT THE PROPOSED
CHARITABLE LANGUAGE AROUND
ACCURATELY AND CALCULATING THE
ACT. THAT THE RAPPER. THANK
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NEXT ON
THE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN TO ONE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE TWO ONE NINE
CHECK YOUR LINE FOR SELF MUTE
HEARING NO AUDIO HELLO. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN COOL. YES. AND I'M
A STUDENT AT DE ANZA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE- AND I WANTED TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF. THE COWBOY ISSUE.
YES MA'AM BUT YOU HAVE LESS
THAN ONE MINUTE IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO IT PLEASE. OUR
SYSTEM HAS BEEN A BLESSING. FOR
THE OTHER STUDENTS LIVE BOXING.
AN AWFUL BUNCH OF RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT NEEDED TO PURSUE AN
EDUCATION. AMERICAN TRIED AND
PROVEN TO WORK IN MANHATTAN
WORKING UNDER FUNDED IN PART BY
FASHIONING A DIFFICULT TIME
STRUGGLING FINDING A NEW FOR
PROFIT THEY FOUND THAT IT COULD
TAKE CLASSES AND HAD A MOMENT
BACK LIKE HOW BRIGHT. IT IS
WRAPPED UP IN A BIT THE RIGHT
DECISION TO DO FROM TOP RIGHT
AND ALLOCATE THE FUNDS TO HELP
CALIFORNIA. COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING. THANK
YOU NEXT FOR. TEXAS GOING TO
HIGH AND EIGHTY NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS KARLEY CODE MAKING
GETTING INTO COLLEGE I AM
CALLING TO OPPOSE THE FUNDING
FOR CAL BRIGHTER BETTER OUR
RESEARCH IN- AVAILABLE THAT CAN
USE THE MONEY I FOR ONE SIGNED
UP FOR CALCULUS CLASS. THAT
WOULD MEAN TO HAVE EXTRA CLASS
HOURS IN IN CLASS EITHER BUT
THANK YOU THE PANDEMIC THAT
COMPLETELY THROWN OUT THE
WINDOW WELL I CAN AFFORD A
TUTOR FOR MULTI VARIABLE
CALCULUS NOT EVERYONE ELSE CAN
WE SHOULD INVEST THE MONEY IN.
FUNDING IT TUTORING ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THE INSANE TIMES ARE
GOING THROUGH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LET ME MAKE ONE MAKE ONE
COMMENT LET ME SAY IT AGAIN FOR
THOSE OPPOSED TO CALIBRATE IF
YOU WOULD STATE YOUR NAME AND
SAY YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
CALIBRATE. I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE IT BECAUSE THE NEXT
TIME I THINK I'M JUST GOING TO
CUT SOMEBODY OFF. WE HAVE TO
TERMINATE THIS PHONE LINE AT
THREE FIFTEEN PM. THREE FIFTEEN
PM IT IS RIGHT NOW AT TWO FORTY
SEVEN. AND I WOULD SUSPECT THAT
WE HAVE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FORTY
AND FIFTY CALLS LEFT ON THE
LINE SO. PLEASE DO THE OURTESY
FOR THOSE THAT FOLLOW YU FOR
BEING BRIEF AND IF YOUR KALBA
CALIBRATE OPPONENTS PLEASE JUST
SAY THAT BECAUSE WE GET IT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
LITTLE WHITE NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN THREE ZERO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
ZERO SEVEN WE'RE HEARING THE
AUDIO CHECK YOUR LINE FOR MUTE.
DURING A RESPONSIBLE OF ON LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO ONE FIVE TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU HI THIS IS
JEFFREY MICHAELS I AM PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE INDEPENDENT. I TEACH
ENGLISH AT CONTRA COSTA
COLLEGE- I'D LIKE TO SUGGEST
THAT IN ADDITION TO THE CAL
BRIGHT- WHICH I OPPOSED BUT YOU
ALSO RECONSIDER. THE NEW
FUNDING FORMULA IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE BUT AS THEY'RE CUTTING
ALL THE SYSTEM CALL THE
COLLEGE'S. SUMMER GOING TO BE
BIGGER WINNERS THAN BIGGER
LOSERS THAN OTHERS WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT FUNDING
FORMULA IS MEANT TO INCENTIVIZE
THE SPECIALLY IN THIS ONLINE
ATMOSPHERE IT WOULD MAKE MORE
SENSE TO BE MORE FAIR. AND
MAYBE HELP MITIGATE THE CUTS
OVERALL IF YOU RECONSIDER THE
SUPPLEMENTAL IN THE PERFORMANCE
BASED ALLOCATION PUT THAT ON
HOLD THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE ONE TWO THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
JOHN MCDOWELL AND THE MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND THE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS DIRECTOR FOR THE LA
COLLEGE FACULTY KILLED. YOU
REALLOCATE THE- CHILD RIGHT
MONEY TO THE BASE OF A HUNDRED
FOURTEEN COLLEGES YOU'LL SERVE
MORE STUDENTS. YOU WILL. REDUCE
THE- CUT AND THE BASE BY TWENTY
PERCENT- AND SO WE ASK YOU TO
DO THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
THANK YOUR PATIENCE. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. MONEX CAROLINE
NUMBER SEVENTY FOUR SEVEN FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN YES THANK YOU
THIS IS ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION. THE ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
THE LONG BEACH UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT ON THREE ISSUES. FOR
DISTRICT AS THEY AND SCHOOL
THAT THEY PLAN TO RE OPEN ON
THE FEDERAL FUNDS ISSUES SO
THIS IS NUMBER FIVE AND SIX IN
YOUR AGENDA. WE APPRECIATE THE
FUNDS THEY'RE CRITICAL. WE
WOULD REQUEST THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF ED SEEK THIRTY
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
EXTEND THE TIME FRAME FOR
DISTRICTS TO USE THESE FUNDS.
RIGHT NOW THEY MUST BE USED BY
DECEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY THAT'S JUST A VERY SHORT
TIME FROM NOW AND THESE FUNDS
WILL BE MORE EFFECTIVE AS PART
OF A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN. SECOND
ON ISSUE SEVEN WE APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT THE ADA
AND INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTE ISSUE
SCHOOL IS GOING TO LOOK
DIFFERENT IN THE NEXT YEAR EVEN
SUMMER PROGRAMS WHICH ARE GOING
TO BE PROBABLY PROVIDED VIA
DISTANCE LEARNING. AND R. ADAC
TIME BASED FUNDING MODEL JUST
DOESN'T WORK. FINALLY ON
ATTACHMENT A ITEM ONE NINETY ON
ROUTINE RESTRICTED MAINTENANCE
ACCOUNT WE SUPPORT AND
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO EXCLUDE THE STATES
ON BEHALF OF PAYMENT. WE WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SEE THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT DISTRICT HAD
ON THE AMOUNT THE PERCENTAGE
AMOUNT THAT HAS TO BE
DEPOSITED. FROM THEIR GENERAL
FUND INTO THIS ACCOUNT WE HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY IN THE GREAT
RECESSION WE HAD EXTENDED TO
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
BUDGET ACT. AND THIS IS A
SOURCE OF FUNDING THAT REALLY
HELPS DISTRICTS IN THE PAST AND
WE'D LIKE TO- GET PART OF THE
PROCESS- BUDGET AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOU ON. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU NOTES WITH
HIS. ONE OR TWO AND NINETY
SEVEN TO NINETY YOUR IS OPEN.
YOUR HELLO MY NAME IS
SURROUNDED BY ENGINEERS WHO
ENTERED THE COUNTRY I WAS
GREATLY IMPRESSED THAT WE
WANTED THANK YOU LATER. ON THE
TOP OR EACH AND- DESJARDINS.
DEFEATED TOOK A GOOD MISSION
CHALLENGE HAS GROUP TO WALK OR
WHAT. I WILL BE IN THE GAME FOR
MONEY IF YOU WANT TO COME AND
IT'S FRIDAY I DON'T KNOW THEY
WANT TO DO MORE IN DEFENSE AND
I DECIDED TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL.
OUR MANUAL I AM A MODEL NOT
ONLY WHICH UPON WHICH IS THAT
THE LATEST REPORT. SHE ALSO
MADE HOW TO USE MY COMPUTER.
RIGHT READ AND- IT'S LIKE WELL
THERE'S- I TO CONTINUE. NINE
COME OUR- LIVES HEY LOOK ONE
NINE. YEAH BEST THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU NOT PLEASE. NEXT
WILL I NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
NINE TWO SO NINE YOUR LINE IS A-
I MISS THE CHAIR AND SENATOR
OUT OF THE WHEN YOU LOOK MY
GROUP. AFFAIR MOM OF THE OPERA.
ORGANIZATION WE WANT TO THANK
YOU. AND WE SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO ELIMINATE THE
AGE CAP LANGUAGE THANK YOU OKAY
NEXT PLEASE. THANKS ONE GOOD
LINE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE THREE TWO ONE YOUR
LINE. JUST HURTING HEARING. YES.
MY NAME IS ALEX I'M A SENIOR IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND THE YOUTH
ADVOCATE FOR BLACK STUDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA UNITED IN
CALIFORNIA'S REDUCTIONS ON THE
EAST SIDE OF SAN JOSE
EDUCATIONAL CONSTANTLY BEEN
INVOLVING IN ORDER TO BETTER
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
AND OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES AND
IN LIGHT OF THIS PANDEMIC THE
LACK OF COMMUNICATION THAT
EXISTS BETWEEN SCHOOL AND
FAMILY EVER APPARENT I'VE
EXPERIENCED LITTLE TO NO LESSON
PLANS IN MY CLASSROOM A LACK OF
A CURRICULUM THAT PARK
MEDICATION FACULTY. IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER TO ACTIVELY
ENGAGE LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN
ORDER TO BETTER RECOGNIZE THE
NEED TO STUDENTS IN
UNDERREPRESENTED CIRCUMSTANCES
SHE COMMUNICATION IS KEY IN
DEVELOPING NURTURING
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT WE NEED
GOING WITH HEALTHY LEARNING
STYLES THAT RECOGNIZE AND
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF
STUDENTS AND THAT INITIATE THE
ALLOCATION OF RESOURCES
INFORMATION AND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR FAMILIES DURING THE
PANDEMIC I STRONGLY RECOMMEND
PRIORITIZING HUMAN ENGAGEMENT
THAT STUDENTS LIKE ME CAN SHIP
TO CHRISTIANS WE MOVING. TOWARD
I'LL BE ABLE TO PLAY. THANK YOU
WE HAVE ABOUT. FIVE PEOPLE WERE.
IN A TWO. MINUTES SO. WHAT I
WOULD ASK YOU TO DO IS LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO ABOUT FORTY
FIVE SECONDS NEXT PLEASE.
EXCELLENT LINE NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR THREE
TWO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME'S BLANK COLEMAN AND I'M
A PARENT. TEACHER AT FACTOR THE
UNIFIED I'M ALSO A LEADER WITH
STOCK AFTER CALIFORNIA.
ABDUCTED YOU TEACHER AND
DISTRICT FOR MORE THAN 65% OF
THE STUDENTS ARE LOW INCOME AND
THE COLOR EXTREMELY CLEAR TO
ME. ALL STUDENTS EQUALLY IS NOT
FAIR. SOMETHING IN SCHOOLS
WHERE MANY FAMILIES HAVE ALWAYS
FACED DISPROPORTIONATE ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL CHALLENGES. THAT
IMPACT ON PHYSICALLY AND
MENTALLY IT IS DIFFERENT FROM
STOPPING AT SCHOOLS OR FAMILIES
DON'T FACE THOSE CHALLENGES. MY
DAUGHTER ATTENDED BY THE
AFFLUENT SCHOOLS FOR TWO YEARS.
AND HAD ACCESS TO MANY
PROGRAMMES IMPOSSIBLE TO HIGH
YIELD PJ FUNDRAISING. AND
EXTENT OF PARABOLIC YOUR HOURS.
ALTHOUGH WE'VE SEEN LESS
FUNDING THAN TITLE ONE SCHOOLS
SHE HAD ACCESS TO MUCH MORE
THAN THOSE STUDENTS. WITH
BUDGET CUTS LOOMING WE NEED TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON. EQUITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. GOVERNORS AND
EQUITY FOCUSED AND ALSO THEM
FUN STUDENTS FEDERAL. WE ALSO
NEED YOUR LEADERSHIP TO FOCUS.
ON THOSEWHO NEED NOT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT. FORTY SECONDS
SIX LITTLE LINE NUMBER. WHAT A
LINE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE TWO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS KEATING
IS EITHER I WILL BE
INTERPRETING FOR YOU DETERMINED
THAT YOU CANNOT GO AHEAD AND
START HER COMMENT. AND I BOTH.
LET THE DEMANDING. THAT THEY
ALL GOT DELETED THE EAGLE
COUNTY FARMER. WE HAVE NOT BEEN
BUT JOHN BUT I'M THINKING IF
I'M GOING TOO FAST YOU DON'T.
WANT TO THINK ABOUT ALL THOSE I
MEAN FROM THE MEDICAL IF YOU
CAN BUT THAT'S BASEBALL YEAH
I'M NOT GONNA I'M NOT FEELING
OF THESE BECAUSE THE CREDIT.
THANK YOU DOWNLOADABLE PDF YOU
MAIL FACILITY NOW I AM A BIT OF
A MINUTE AGO THAT. ONE OF THE
FOLLOWING ON INSTAGRAM. THANKS
ON THE DAY THAT IT. WELL YOU
CAN'T IN A THOUGHT HAVE A
STRONG YET. POSSIBLE I AM
INTERESTED TO THE THAT THEY'RE
NOT GONNA GREAT SO I THAT MIGHT.
YOU KNOW GOING UP VEVO. AND I'M
A DIFFICULT. JOB BUT- NOT BE
TRUSTED MANAGER TO THAT IS. BUT
I CAN I DO THAT THE ONLY A JOKE
NOT SO LONG FELLOW. BUT IT
PROVIDING THE BEST EDUCATION
WHICH AREN'T EVEN CONCERNS. AND
WHICH IS A RIGHT FOR EVERYONE.
UNFORTUNATELY BUDGET DEFICIT
HAS BEEN WORSE YEAR AFTER YEAR
IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT. WHERE
WE TALK ABOUT EQUITY BUT WHICH
WILL NEVER BE POSSIBLE IF THE
MONEY DOES NOT GO WHERE IT
SHOULD. BE DIFFICULT SERVING
STUDENTS WITH THE GREATEST P.
ONE CLEAR EXAMPLE IS THE
DISTANCE LEARNING WE'VE. BEEN
GOING HERE. I NEED CAN FAMILY.
WHO CANNOT AFFORD TO HAVE
INTERNET AT HOME MY- CONTROL.
WE YOU TO. INSURING WE WERE TO
THEIR NEED. FOR THAT EQUITY CAN
BE AREA. NOT WORDS BUT ALSO IN.
THANK YOU. PLEASE SIX POINT
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE THREE
TWO NINE LINE IS- OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JACKIE
BELL IN ON THE STOCK WELL
THANKS. ATHLETES TO JUST AND I
DO SUPPORT OF THAT THE- HAS
ABOUT. THE IS NOT EVERYONE THE
SAME WAY IT WE SHOULD NOT BE. I
WANT. TO CLOSE YOUR HAVE A LOT
OF EDUCATION AND BEEN VERY OF
THE SCHOOL YEAR NOT. MANAGER
TRYING TO HELP THE TEACHERS I
HOLD THE BILLS ARE GRADUATE.
RESULTS MOTIVATION TO ALL A
CONTRACT RANCH ALSO I TRAVELED
AND FORTH WITH MY BRAIN AND MY
OWN BY HOUSE WITH MY OLD
BECAUSE MY PARENTS WERE. LIKE A
BUDGET. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
FORTY FIVE SECONDS NEXT. GOT A
LINE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN THREE ONE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES PLEASE. OKAY MY NAME IS
MICHAEL JOHNSON A PARENT AND
THE EARLY EDUCATION TEACHER-
SORRY. CAN. FORTY FIVE WELL
GOING TO SAY THAT I CAN FIGHT
IT'S HARD TO HEAR. WE ARE DOES
SAY THAT THE I AGREE LINK VERY
IMPORTANT AS A PARENT I'VE I'VE
I'M WORKING BECAUSE. HERE YOU.
IT IT APPEARS THAT LINE IS
DROPPED ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX THREE
THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO SENATOR I'M JIM MILLER
WRITES IN ORGANIZING WITH
CALIFORNIA'S REJECTED. WE
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL TO INVEST IN COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS. I WORK WITH STUDENTS
FROM UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS IN
LONG BEACH AND RIGHT NOW THEY
NEED TO BE HEARD. STRUGGLING TO
KEEP UP WITH THEIR SCHOOL WORK
AND NOW I HAVE MORE
RESPONSIBILITIES AT HOME. EACH
ONE OF THEIR STORIES DIFFERENT
BETWEEN THE STRUGGLE THAT
UNIQUE. AND THAT YOU WILL LOOK
LIKE FOR STUDENTS IN THE FAMILY
TO HAVE ACCESS TO COMMUNITY
SCHOOL. CORP PROVIDED
HEALTHCARE TO FAMILIES. MAHLER
CLASS SIZES. HELP PARENTS LEARN
NEW SKILLS. R. K. THAT
MARKETERS WILL. WITH THAT
NURTURES TO WHEREAS TO THE- FOR
THE FIRST TIME WHEN I IMAGINE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS I SEE BELIEVE
CAP CLOTHING. IDEA OF UNEQUAL
ACCUSATIONS OF STUDENT BASED ON
A LONG HISTORY OF EXCLUSION.
I'M ASKING THAT WE INVEST IN
COMMUNITY SCHOOL. FOR THE
STUDENTS PARENTS. AND THE
COMMUNITY THAT THEY BELONG TO.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE FORTY
FIVE SECONDS. HELLO I. NUMBER
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
THREE THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M NOT
AVAILABLE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
EXCLUSION WE ARE VERY CONCERNED
WITH THE SIGNIFICANT CUTS BEING
PROPOSED TO WORKFORCE TRAINING
INITIATIVES LIKE THE STRONG
WORK FIRST PROGRAM CTP AND
APPRENTICESHIPS WE URGE YOU TO
MAINTAIN YOUR CRITICAL
INVESTMENT THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
BIRTHDAY AND YOUR COMMENTS NEXT
PLEASE. THANKS A LITTLE LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
THREE THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CENTERS
ARE OFTEN MADE ABOUT THIS IS
CHERYL MILLER ON BEHALF OF A
CLASS. PREHEAT THE GOVERNOR'S
FOCUS ON EQUITY- AND ON
INVESTING IN PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING FOR EDUCATORS AS WELL
THE DRESSING IMPACTED SCHOOL
CLOSURES WE BELIEVE TO FOCUS
THE RELIGIOUS FOCUS ON EQUITY
WE URGE THE SENATE TO EXPLORE
HOW TO MOST EQUITABLY
DISTRIBUTE THE CURES ACT FUN.
AND RECOMMEND THE APPROACH
OUTLINED BY THE LTFS EQUITY
COALITION. WE ALSO RECOMMEND
THAT THE BUDGET INCORPORATE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR FOR INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WITHOUT DEFENSE FUND PRINTER
THE FUNDS INTENDED FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS ACTUALLY
BENEFIT THEM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU PLEASE. THANKS A LITTLE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED THREE
THREE ZERO THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON HAPPY SURE
ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
LTFS EQUITY COALITION- WE ALSO
URGE YOU TO TAKE AN EQUITY
APPROACH AND PUT THE NEEDS OF
HIGH NEED STUDENTS FIRST.
ARTISTICALLY WITH REGARD TO LPS
WE URGE THAT YOU DO NOT CUT
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
FUNDS AND INSTEAD HOLD THEM
CONSTANT AT THEIR TWENTY
NINETEEN. TWENTY TWENTY LEVEL
S A MATTER OF FAIRNESS. SECOND
WE URGE YOU TO MAKE SURE THERE
ARE STRONG PROBLEMS IN PLACE TO
ENSURE THAT COMMUNITIES HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE INPUT INTO
STANDING DECISIONS ARE. THE
FEDERAL AND STATE PROVIDE. THE
COUNTY BILLET. AS THANK AND
FINALLY WE ASK THAT RESTORE THE-
THREE HUNDRED MILLION PROPOSED
IN THE JANUARY BUDGET FOR
COMMUNITY SCHOOL GROUNDS. AND
UNITY SCHOOLS PROVIDE HEALTH
MENTAL HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICE SUPPORTS THAT ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED NOW MORE
THAN EVER TO HELP COMMUNITIES
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. EXCELLENT THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY NINE THREE FOUR NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS ROCK AND LAY
OF A THIS IS DEBBIE KLEIN
PRESIDENT OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. TO MITIGATE
HARM TO OUR ONE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN COLLEGES WE RECOMMEND
ELIMINATING CALIBRATE. THIS
REDUCTION WHAT OFFSET CUTS THAT
WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
INCLUDING CUTS TO STRONG WORK
FORCE PART TIME FACULTY SUPPORT
AND THE ACADEMIC SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
TO ADDRESS THE LONG TERM FLAWS
IN THE FUNDING FORMULA AND
ENSURE ACCESS IS PRIORITIZED
THE 10% PERFORMANCE BASED
FUNDING ALLOCATION SHOULD BE
ELIMINATED. FINALLY WE URGE YOU
TO OPPOSE ANY EFFORTS TO BLOCK
GRANT THE E. L. P. S.
CATEGORICAL WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE BREVITY. ANY
COMMENTS NEXT PLEASE. NEXT LINE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TO EIGHT
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MICHELLE UNDERWOOD ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
FUNDING COALITION YOU HAVE OUR
LETTER SO IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I'LL JUST ADDRESS TWO
ISSUES. PART EIGHT ISSUE EIGHT
COME SPECIAL EDUCATION WE CLOSE
SPENDING A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS BASED ON LOW INCIDENCE
COUNT. NOT THAT THESE STUDENTS
ARE NOT WORTHY OF EXTRA FUNDING
BUT WE REQUEST THAT ALL
AVAILABLE FUNDS SUPPORT SPECIAL
EDUCATION BASED EQUITY. FINALLY
NOT ON YOUR AGENDA BUT WE NEED
MORE FLEXIBILITY THAT PROPOSED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION TO
WHETHER THESE CUTS. THEY'RE
LISTED ON OUR LETTER AND WERE
ALL MADE AVAILABLE BY THE
LEGISLATURE DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SEVEN TO EIGHT SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON WITH YOUR CHAIR AND
TENDERLY BOMBING IN THE COUNTRY
CODE ROGER AND I AM
REPRESENTING THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. YOU
HAVE A LETTER OF LARGE URBAN-
IN A COALITION THAT WE GOING TO
PROVIDE. IN B. TOWN ARE
PETITIONING I WOULD JUST. I'D
SAY TWO QUICK ITEMS WHICH IS-
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK AT THE
THING TRAINING DAY FINANCIAL
FUNDING SOURCE TO ADDRESS ISSUE
THREE AN EXTENSION CORD.
CURRENTLY ZERO DOLLARS ARE
BEING CONSIDERED FROM THE STATE
TRAINING GAVE HER SCHOOL. AND
WE WANT TO PUT A NEW ISSUE FOR
CONSIDERATION WHICH IS AN
ALLOCATION FOR STUDENTS. WITH
MODERATE TO SEVERE DISABILITIES
GOT THE PART OF THE ISSUE
EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT A LITTLE LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE FIVE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
HALLERAN AT THE CHARTER SCHOOL
DEVELOPMENT CENTER FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU FOR REJECTING THAT
CHARTER SCHOOL AGE GAP ISSUE
AND SECOND OF ALL WE WENT
ONLINE ARE COMMENTED SENATOR
MORALE. AROUND THE I. NINE
CHARTER I'M NOT GOING TO BE
STARTERS- WE SUPPORTED COMMENTS
AND BELIEVE THAT NON CULTURE
BASED CHARTER SCHOOL SHOULD
SHARE AND FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
CARRIED BACK. NEARLY ALL
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN STANDALONE
BIKE COMPONENTS CAN FACE THE
SAME PRESSURES THE TRADITIONAL.
SCHOOLS AND CHARTERS I'M AN
ATHLETE YOU REVISIT THAT ISSUE
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT A
LITTLE THREE AND FIFTY EIGHT
THREE FIVE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M HOPING THEY'LL WORK
OUT FOR YOUR PROJECT I MEAN
COMPARTMENT THE EQUITY APPROACH
FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED. WE
WORK WITH YOUR DENTAL BOARD
DISTRICT ACROSS CALIFORNIA IT'S
BEEN AN EASY TASK FOR THEM TO
RESPOND TO THE MMMY. MAY HAVE
FACED ISSUES OF INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY TECHNOLOGY ACCESS
MENTAL HEALTH OR LAYOFFS AMONG
OTHERS. THANK YOU- YOU HEARD
DIRECTLY FROM THEM THANK YOU TO
CHALLENGES SO WE ARE HERE TO
STAY TO DO THREE THINGS. ONE OF
THEM HERE DISTRIBUTOR. FRANKLIN
EQUITY APPROACH. AND WE ARE
LOCATED TWO POINT EIGHT BILLION
OF KERR TALK TO DISTRICT IN
PROPORTION TO THE AMOUNT OF
FINANCIAL AID CONCENTRATION
PARTY. EVERYTHING REQUIRED. IN
ON OUR STATE AND FEDERAL THREE
FOUR THE ADMIN PROPOSAL CAME
BACK THE COMMUNITY WHEN YOU GOT
TO GET FIRED TO THAT PROGRAM
BUT IT THAT'S TRUE BUT IT
EQUITABLY. ALL URGING NOW IN
OUR WHAT WE NEED IN THE LONG
TERM ADDRESS THE WHOLE CHILD
AND FRIENDS ARE PUTTING. OWN
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE NEED
EQUITY COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
MORE WE'VE COVERED YOU. WE ARE
NOT RECOMMENDING THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE ABOUT. NOT
MINUTES LEFT NEXT PLEASE FORTY
FIVE SECONDS OR LESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBERS THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT THREE TWO EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MARTHA GRAHAM SCHOOL
THE FIRST PRIVATIZATION IN
CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD LIKE TO
ALIGN MY COMMENT THE PDP
COALITION COLONY IN A NATION
NINE. OUR COALITION LETTER
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL DETAIL BUT
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
PROJECTOR TEMPERS THAT
REDUCTION PDP REIMBURSEMENT
RIGHT. CHILDCARE PROVIDERS ARE
STRUGGLING TO KEEP THEIR DOORS
OPEN AND THEN. AND IT'S BECAUSE
COUPLE FURTHER UNDERMINED. THE
AL CARE IS BENEFICIAL TO
COMPANY NUMBER RESPONSE AND THE
FRENCH CULTURE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY HAD TO ENSURE THAT.
CAN RETURN TO WORK. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TRAINING. THANK YOU WE
HAVE NINETEEN PEOPLE LEFT AND
WE HAVE A- EIGHT MINUTES TO GO
SO WHAT YOU'RE GONNA DO IS
YOU'RE GOING TO IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND YOU'RE GOING TO
TELL ME WHAT THE ISSUE NUMBER
IS AND YOU'RE GOING TO TELL ME
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
IT. AND ELIMINATE THE REST OF
THE DIALOGUE YOU CAN SUBMIT
THAT IN WRITING SO. PERSONAL
NEXT PERSON UP HIS LINE THREE
SIXTY THREE THREE SIX THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN MY NAME
EXACTLY THE MONTERO I DON'T
PROFESS THAT I NEED BECAUSE I'M
JUST COLLEGE AND THEN TO
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE LOW
THAT IS COLLEGE BACK ON BBM.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE COLOR
IN FEDERATION OF TEACHERS THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
LOCAL IN THE FIFTEEN TWENTY
ONE. AND I AM ALSO A FACULTY
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA WITH
THE COLLEGE BOARD MEMBER I AM I
WANT YOU TO THE FRONT RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. GREAT JOB. SECTORS
THANK YOU MY NUMBER'S THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE THREE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
ONLY A WITH YOU. BATTERY OF
STATE COUNTY MEDICAL REALLY
QUICKLY WE DO IT BECAUSE THE
ISSUE NINE- 10% RATE CUTS THAT
YOU'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT THIS
AFTERNOON. AND ESPECIALLY ON
OPPOSING VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE CUT AND- ISSUES THREE AND
FOUR. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GREAT JOB TOO NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE THREE SEVEN ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON I AM JACKSON BOROUGH-
TRANSFERRING STUDENT AT
FOOTHILL COLLEGE INTERESTING
ITEMS SEVENTY EIGHT- STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSED THE CAL RIGHT
EXIT THANK YOU THANK YOU GREAT
JOB NEXT. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
BE FIFTY SIX THREE FIVE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALL YOUR
LINE IS OPEN TO HEAD. IT MADE
BY ALL YES YOU CAN QUICKLY
ABOUT THE PROJECT- WE ARE BOTH
THE COURT AND THE COALITION
BACK WHICH WAS SUBMITTED IN
RITING THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
LINE THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
ONE THREE EIGHT ONE LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS GLEN
WARREN I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL LIBRARY
ASSOCIATION I AM CLOSE I DON'T.
ISSUE FOR THE CUTTING OF THE
ONLINE. RESOURCE SUBSCRIPTIONS
FOR SCHOOLS IT'S TIME WE'RE
PUTTING ALL STUDENTS ONLINE.
WHAT THEY CONNECT WITH THE
REALLY MATTERS AND WE GOT
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH TWELFTH
GRADERS WHO NEED QUALITY
CONTENT. NOT GOOGLE DUMPSTER
DIVING THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT LINE THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY TWO THREE EIGHT TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS WHAT I'M ASKING IF THEY
ATTEND A SUBSTANTIAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND I'M REPRESENTING A
F. P. FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE THE
FUND CALIBRATE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU GREAT JOB NEXT PLEASE. NINE
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
THREE SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THIS
IS JOHN I SUPPRESS IT BUT
DEVELOPING A SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION ON THE ISSUE THREE
WE URGE YOU TO CONDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO MITIGATE THE
PROPOSED 10% CUT TO HELP YOU
OUT. AND THE COLLEGE AT YEAH
BUT ON DIGITAL COUNTRY WE ARE
WORRIED THAT CLAPPED BACK THAT
WILL BEAR THE BRUNT OF THE CUTS
WE NEED MORE STAFF NOT AT.
SCHOOLS. AND COLLEGES WE OPEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU PLEASE.
TEXAS WIND EIGHTY EIGHT THREE
EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
GENEVIEVE KOLAR I'M A STUDENT
RESTROOMS WILL BE IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT- I
DIDN'T SEVENTY EIGHT. HUNDRED
YOU KNOW HALF MILLION STUDENTS
A HUNDRED FOURTEEN COLLEGES
PLEASE DEFINE HOW GREAT OKAY
FINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU GREAT
JOB NEXT PLEASE. NEXT LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
THREE EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE THREE EIGHT FIVE
CHECK FOR SELF MUTE. HEARING NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
THREE NINETY TWO THREE NINE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES YES YOUR LINE
IS OPEN SIR. HI MY NAME IS
JONATHAN CALLING I'M A FACULTY
MEMBER AND LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT I'M
A LITTLE I'M WITH AFT FIFTEEN
TEN FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE PLEASE
THE FUND CALIBRATED. THANK YOU
PLEASE. NEXT IN LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN THREE ZERO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CENTERS THIS PAUL YODER SHUDDER
INTO REGIONALS RELAYING I'M
HERE TODAY FOR SAN FRANCISCO IN
NAPA- ALSO THE PROXY FOR MARIN
COUNTY AS WELL THIS IS
REGARDING ACCESS YOUR **** IT'S
NOT ON YOUR AGENDA TODAY. AND
SHOULD NOT BE INCLUDED IN YOUR
JUNE BUDGET THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT LINE THREE
NINETY SEVEN THREE NINE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU-
SENATORS THIS IS MARK MCDONALD
MCCALLUM GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
NUMBER OF LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS INCLUDING
BOSTON SAN DIEGO SAN DINO KERN
AND MOUNT ST A SEATO AND- THIS
IS ISSUE SEVENTY SIX. WE
BELIEVE THE REDUCTIONS TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE TOO DEEP
BUT IF THEY HAVE TO BE MADE- WE
WOULD SAY THAT THEY SHOULD BE
ACCOMPANIED BY WORKLOAD
REDUCTIONS SO THAT DISTRICTS
CAN BEST MANAGE THOSE CUTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
ACTUALLY A LINE NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIVE FOUR ZERO FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
CHEROKEE COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS
IS JARED CALL WITH CALIFORNIA
FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT OF KATE YOU TWELVE
ISSUE NUMBER SIX IN REGARD
USING FEDERAL AFTER FUNDING TO
SUPPORT SCHOOL MEALS SERVICE
OVER THE SUMMER MONTHS. WE ALSO
SUBMITTED WRITTEN COMMENTS
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVEN
FOUR ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
SENATORS. WE'RE I WOULD LIKE HI
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN ONLY
HELP YOU TO DO IS WE NEED YOU
TO IDENTIFY YOURSELF THE ISSUE
INSIDE WHETHER YOU OPPOSE OR
SUPPORT PLEASE. YES HELLO MY
NAME IS VERONICA CODE I AM- I
AM SPEAKING ON ISSUE EIGHT
SPECIAL EDUCATION WE OPPOSE
DECREASING THE BASE RATE FROM
SIX FORTY FIVE AT SIX TWENTY
FIVE. WE ALSO OPPOSED. THE BILL
IF YOU COULD MENTAL HEALTH
RELATED SERVICES AND A DECREASE
IN TRANSPORTATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
BROTHER YOUR COMMENTS NEXT
WEEK'S. TEXAS LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ONE FIVE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THAT MANY THANK
YOU. HI DIANA I DOUBT OUR
PRESENT AT THE LOS ANGELES
COLLEGE FACULTY GUILT AFP
FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE REPRESENTING
FIVE THOUSAND FULL TIME AND
PART TIME FACULTY ON THE NINE
ACCREDITED COLLEGES IN THE LOCK
AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT ALIGNED WITH THOSE WHO
WOULD CUT OUT RIGHT WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
THE ECONOMIC ENGINE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S RECOVERY BUT HOW
BRIGHT IS THE DEFECTIVE PART
PLUG IN THAT ENGINE- IT'S NOT
ACCREDITED THE PROGRAM THANK
YOU OKAY THANK GOD THE
ENROLLMENT WILL DRAIN FURTHERED
THE CRISIS THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE REMEMBER SUPPORTER
POSE. NEXT PLEASE EXPLAIN
EXPLAIN. TO FIFTY NINE TWO FIVE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS. AND I'M A STUDENT THE
FALL I LOOK. AND I REPRESENTING
AMERICANS OF TEACHERS FIFTEEN
TWENTY ONE INTERNSHIP I'M
CALLING INTO THE STRONG
OPPOSITION OF CALCITE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT. POLICE DECLINED.
RIGHT THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT LITTLE LINE FOUR HUNDRED
AND EIGHT FOUR ZERO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
ANGELA HOW IT HERE AND I AND
THAT. KIND OF CHRISTIANITY
ACCOUNT A COUPLE AND THE CHAIR
FOR THE COALITION OF ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND I'D LIKE TO SPEAK TO AN
ITEM EIGHT. WE SUPPORT THING
HOLD THE REDUCTION OF THE BASE
RATE IS SIX TWENTY FIVE IT
SHOULD STAY AT THE PARK WITH
THE BASE RATE AT SIX FORTY FIVE
ACROSS THE STATE THANK YOU.
PLEASE SENATOR I AM PLEASED TO
WE HAVE THROUGH THE ENTIRE
QUEUE. WELL I HESITATE TO ASK
YOU COULD YOU RE CHECK JUST TO
MAKE SURE. OKAY I UNDERSTAND
YOUR HESITATION IT'S A ONE AND
ZERO TO PUT YOURSELF INTO Q.
AND NATURALLY WE DO HAVE A FEW
MORE WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE TO FIVE
WITH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIVE ONE YES WE CAN HEAR YOU GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ANDREA FERNANDES FROM
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S ACADEMY
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY RIGHT I
DON'T BUY PROGRAMS SERVING
SEVEN HUNDRED INFANTS TODDLERS
AND PRESCHOOLERS WE OPPOSE THE
CUTS IN ITEM NINE AND TEN AND
WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE HOLD HARMLESS REBUTTAL
BY PROGRAM IN ORDER TO KEEP UP
ON PROGRAMS SERVING CHILDREN
AND WORKING FAMILIES WE NEED.
OUR PROGRAMS BE HELD FROM
TWENTY TWENTY OR WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO DO IT I'M MORE PROGRAMS
ARE GOING TO SHUT DOWN AND
THERE WOULD BE AN IRREVERSIBLE
DEVASTATING LOSS WE WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO COME BACK FROM THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. SO
THE LINE THREE AND TWELVE THREE
ONE TWO LINE IS OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS EVEN JENNINGS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ASSOCIATION FOR
OCCUPATIONAL EDUCATION
COMMENTING ON STRONG WORK FORCE
WE APPRECIATE THE ALTERNATIVES
OFFERED BY THE LA- TO PRESERVE
AS MUCH STRONG WORKFORCE
PROGRAM UNDING AS POSSIBLE.
BUT WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
REDIRECTING ECONOMIC WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM FUNDS TO
STRONG WORK FORCE HE W. DEAL
OUT OUR COLLEGES TO WORK WITH
INDUSTRY TO ENSURE OUR PROGRAMS
ARE NEEDING REGIONAL NEEDS. IN
THE FACE OF A RECESSION IN
CHANGING WORKFORCE WHICH IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER A
STRONG WORKFORCE REQUIRES BOTH
STRONG WORK WORK FORCE PROGRAM
FUNDING AND ECONOMIC WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FUNDING THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE REMEMBER
SUPPORTER OPPOSE. THEM ATTACHED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU GO TO
LINES HUNDRED AND TWO THREE
ZERO TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND- GO AHEAD HERE ME
YEP A GOOD AFTERNOON THAT MANY
DEER PERFECT AND THE PANEL THEY
EVER BRING ME BECAUSE DISTRICT
RESERVE CHAIRMAN WE DOCUMENTED
A COALITION LETTER WITH OTHER
BASIC ANY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT EXPRESSING OUR
CONCERNS ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
REDUCE STATE FUNDING FOR
CHEMICAL OR COLD PROGRAM FOR
BASIC AGENT BECAUSE THE SEARCH
BUT WE GET BACK TO YOU CONSIDER
THAT LETTER OF LEADER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YOUR
YOUR OLD JOB REALLY HI THERE I
AM A MEMBER OF THE B. A. S. P.
AND- COURAGE I ASK YOU TO VOTE
NO ON YOUR RECORD ONLY
CHALLENGER NUMBER ONE SEVEN ONE
NUMBER ONE SEVEN ONE DOES NOT
HAVE TECHNICAL AMENDMENT.
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THE DISTRICT TO CLOSE SCHOOLS
IN A TIME WHEN STUDENTS NEED
MORE SOCIAL THIS DIFFERENT
THING THANK YOU THANK YOU. YOUR
NEXT PLEASE. FIND EIGHTY SEVEN
THREE EIGHT SO YOUR LONG IS.
OKAY ON ITEMS THAT MAKE IT
REPRESENTING THE LOOKS REAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALONG BEACH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT-
ACADEMIC COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
SANTA MONICA COLLEGE. POSTED A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT.
REQUIRES SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN
CAUSE CERTAIN NUMBER FGF
STUDENT EVEN THOUGH THAT THERE
IS. A REDUCTION IN FUNDING.
LONG BEACH. AND SANTA MONICA
OKAY FOR. ARE MISSION IS SENDS
THANK YOU NEXT. NEXT LINE I
SEVEN NINE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BY NINETY SEVEN CHECK
YOUR LINE FOR MUTE. YOUR NOAM
THE ITEM NUMBER AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE WERE RUNNING
OUT OF TIME. HI KATIE MACK
WHERE I AM PRESENT CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL LIBRARY ASSOCIATION I
OPPOSE. ISSUE FOR REMOVING THE
PTAB SAYS HE'S VERY SENSUAL OUT
THERE STUDENTS ARE CONTINUING
TO WORK ONLINE ANY QUALITY THAT
ENFORCEMENT FOR EVERYONE TO
CLOSE THE EQUITY GAP. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR AND COMMENTS NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT LITTLE LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE THREE
EIGHT THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CITY COUNCIL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR YMCA AT SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. ISSUE FOR WE
OPPOSE THE PROPOSED A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR CUT TO THE AFTER
SCHOOL EDUCATION AND SAFETY
PROGRAM. TWO NINE OPPOSED A 10%
RATE REDUCTION FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS THANK YOU. GREAT JOB
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOUR TO EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M UP IN. RIVERSIDE
PENNSYLVANIA OPPOSING ISSUE
NINE CHILD CARE REDUCTION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
YOUR BROTHER THE NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT A LITTLE LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO THREE
FIVE TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS DON DR DEPUTIES
BUT I CAN'T LOOK AT HEALTH
SCIENCES IN YEARS WE ARE FILLED
WITH MANTA THING DAN. I'M I'M-
WHICH ACCORDING THE ITEM
RELATED TO THE USER THE BUDGET
THAT THEY PLACE IS THE IS THE
ART SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
ALLOCATION. GOVERNOR NATHAN
DEMONSTRATED CONTINUE THE COURT
THAT YOU SEE ARE THE LOOK MAD
AT THEM BY PROVIDING THE
ADDITIONAL ELEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION AND I'M GOING TO REPORT
A LITTLE BIT ACCORDED THE
CRUCIATUS AND IT'S LESS THAN
TWENTY FIVE MILLION ORIGINALLY
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY. BUT YET WE CONTINUE TO
REQUIRE THE FULL AMOUNT FROM
THE LEGISLATURE IN ORDER TO
SUSTAIN AND GROW THE SCHOOL
WHICH IS UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO
EXPAND MEDICAL EDUCATION IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE REGION THAT HAS
BEEN MEDICALLY UNFIT THERE ARE
TOO LONG THANKS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU DEAN NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT IS ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY EIGHT ONE NINE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS A- HI THIS IS ERIC
REID FROM HELP ME COLLEGE. I'M
CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO THE
FUNDING FOR COPYRIGHT-
DIFFICULT- MEDICAL- CODING
PROGRAM BECAUSE THEY CAN'T EVEN
HANDLE THE FEW STUDENTS THAT
THEY HAVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
LINE THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN THREE FOUR SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
MARCELLA HERNANDEZ ON THE TEN
YEAR COUNSELOR AT LA HARBOR
COLLEGE. EIGHT ACC MEMBER AND
A. F. T. GOOD THING TWENTY ONE
MEMBER. CALLING TO. AFTER
YOU'VE DEFINED CAL BRIGHT AND
SUPPORT- STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
AND CAREER ADVOCACY AND
SUPPORT- INSTITUTIONS LIKE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES ARE ALREADY ACCREDITED
AND WORKING FOR STUDENT
POPULATION THANK YOU AND YOUR
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS ONE THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO THREE
EIGHT TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE THREE EIGHT TWO CHECKERS
LINE FOR ME PLEASE. HEARING THE
RESPONSE WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN THREE ONE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YEAH YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. ANDREA
SLEEVE FROM RANCHO CUCAMONGA
AND I'M A COZY THE CHILD CARE
REDUCTION- CHARACTER THE
CENTRAL TO THE WORK FORCE
OPPOSING ISSUE NINE. THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT PLEASE. AND CENTER
FOR THE SECOND TIME WE HAVE
GOTTEN THROUGH THE QUEUE. WELL
TWO TIME IS A CHARM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WE'RE
GOING TO PROCEED TO THE VOTING
ASPECT TO VOTING SECTION OF
THIS HEARING BUT BEFORE WE DO
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A- W. TWO
OR THREE MINUTE- RECESS TO
JUST. RE COMPUTE AND THEN WILL
BE BACK THANK YOU.
OKAY LET'S
GO AHEAD NOW AND- AND RESUME
AND BEGIN VOTING WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN VOTING ON THE PART A
GENDER K. THROUGH TWELVE IN
EARLY EDUCATION NOW. WE WILL
FIRST BE VOTING ON ISSUES
FORTY. FORTY FOUR FIFTY TWO
EIGHTY THREE AND ONE SEVEN SIX
ONE ATTACHMENT HEY. IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS. ON THOSE ITEMS.
THANK YOU THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR LEYVA THE MOTION IS
TO APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE ISSUES
IDENTIFIED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. IRIS ROSS
BYE. BYE RALPH YEAH. WE WILL
NOW BE VOTING ON ISSUES. FIVE
ONE OH SIX THROUGH. ONE SIXTEEN
ONE THIRTY NINE THROUGH ONE
FORTY SIX AND ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
THROUGH ONE EIGHTY. ONE EIGHTY
TWO THROUGH ONE NINETY SIX ALL
THE DETACHMENT HEY. IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON THESE ISSUES.
THANK YOU THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR MORALE. THE MOTION
IS TO APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. IRIS ROSS
FIVE. FIVE ZERO. NEXT WE WILL
BE VOTING ON DISCUSSION ITEMS.
EIGHT NINE TEN AN ATTACHMENT A
ISSUES ONE THROUGH THIRTY NINE
FORTY ONE THROUGH. FORTY THREE
FORTY FIVE THROUGH. FIFTY ONE
FIFTY THREE THROUGH EIGHTY TWO.
BEFORE THROUGH. ONE OH FIVE ONE
SEVENTEEN THROUGH. ONE THIRTY
EIGHT TEN ONE FORTY SEVEN
THROUGH ONE SEVENTY FIVE. ISSUE
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN AN ATTACHMENT
B. ISSUES ONE EIGHTY ONE AND
ONE NINETY SEVEN THROUGH TWO
TWENTY. IS THERE A MOTION ON
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THESE ISSUES SOME MOVED THANK
YOU THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
HAVE BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
LEYVA THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THE ITEMS AND ISSUES LISTED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AS ROSS HI EVA HI BRO.
NEXT WITH REGARD TO ISSUE SIX
WE WILL AMEND THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO HOLD OPEN.
THE SCHOOL RE OPENING. SUPPORT
BLOCK GRANT PORTION AND VOTE ON
THE REMAINING STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO ISSUE SIX.
IS THERE A MOTION ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS SOME OF IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR LEYVA.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THERE'S ROSS BY THE BY
WELL. LET'S MOVE ON NOW TO PART
B. OF OUR AGENDA HIGHER
EDUCATION. IS THERE A MOTION ON
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING ISSUE SIXTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN ON ATTACHMENT ONE. THE
ELEVENTH. THE MOVE VERY SORRY
THANK YOU THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR LEYVA THE MOTION IS
TO APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. TENORS
ROTHSTEIN. BY ROUTE. IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AT THE SAME L.
LEVEL I MEAN SEVERAL. WISHES TO
CHANGE HIS VOTE FROM OUTSIDE TO
KNOW. SO NOTED. IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE VOTE
ONLY ATTACHMENT ONE ISSUES TO.
TWO THROUGH SIX. EIGHT THROUGH.
FIFTEEN SEVENTEEN NINETEEN TO
THIRTY FOUR. ATTACHMENT TWO
ISSUES THIRTY FIVE THROUGH.
FORTY EIGHT FIFTY FIFTY THREE
THROUGH SIXTY SEVEN SIXTY NINE
THROUGH SEVENTY FOUR TEN
DISCUSSION ISSUE EIGHTY SIX. SO
MOVED THANK YOU THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THOSE ITEMS
HAVE BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
LEYVA THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO
THE ISSUE LISTED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS ROSS HI EVA HI RALPH.
WE NEVER VOTED ON ALL THE ITEMS
AND ISSUES THAT WE ARE SUPPOSED
TO VOTE ON. YES. THANK YOU TO
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE OR PLEASE
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THANKS TO EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ON
EDUCATION. THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.